GOOD MORNING.
WELCOME TO THE WEDNESDAY APRIL
TWENTY FIFTH MEETING OF THE
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE.
AT THIS TIME I DON'T THINK
WE'VE ENOUGH MEMBERS FOR A
QUORUM.
BUT I'M GONNA ASK THE SERGEANTS
TO CALL FOR ALL MEMBERS OF
REQUIREMENT IN THE ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM. WE WILL BEGIN AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE.
.
WHAT SETS?
WE HAVE MS AGUIAR-CURRY WITH US.
IF WE COULD CALL FILE ITEM
SEVEN AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY
SEVEN.
WELL GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING.
FEELS LIKE IT AND LEAVE THE
BUILDING AT.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR IN MEMBERS.
I'M HERE TODAY AND I WILL BE
BACK HERE EVERY YEAR TO MAKE
FARMWORKERS LIVES BETTER.
I'M ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS AND
THE UFW FOR WORKING WITH ME. SO
THAT I CAN NOW SAY THIS BILL HAS
NO OPPOSITION.
AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY SEVEN IT
WILL GIVE EACH COUNTIES
OPERATING AGENCIES GREATER
DECISION MAKING POWER. AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL ABOUT HOW TO UTILIZE
RESOURCES IN A MANNER THAT
BENEFITS THE NEEDS OF THE
RESIDENTS AND THE FACILITIES
MOST.
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE THAT
HOUSING SENATORS A STEP WILL
ESTABLISH A CAPITAL RESERVE
ACCOUNT. WITH ANY EXCESS FUNDS
TO BE USED FOR REQUIRED
IMPROVEMENTS ARE REPAIRS THAT
CAN DIRECTLY AFFECT. THAT
SPECIFIC CENTER.
IT WILL CLARIFY EXPLICITLY THAT
AGE SEE DEMAND ALLOW FOR
FLEXIBILITY IN THE CENTER'S
OPENING DATE TO ADJUST FOR
SCHOOL SCHEDULES AND VARIABLE.
GROWING SEASONS.
IT WILL REVISE THE CONTRACTING
PROCESS TO ALLOW FOR ONE
CONTRACT WITH ANNUAL AMENDMENTS
TO THE TO THAT AGREEMENT.
AND IT WILL ESTABLISH A PROCESS
FOR COLLECTING AGGREGATE.
ANONYMOUS DATA ABOUT THE
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS THAT RESIDE
IN THE CENTERS EACH YEAR. SO
THAT FUNDING AND SERVICES CAN BE
TAILORED TO FARM WORKER NEEDS.
I HAVE MY FRIEND AN EXPERT LISA
BAKER HERE WITH ME. TO PROVIDE
PERSPECTIVE AS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE YELLOW COUNTY
HOUSING AUTHORITY AND TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS AS AN OPERATOR.
THANK YOU YOUR WITNESS.
NO MORNING I ALSO LOVE ECHO THE
ASSEMBLY. A THANKS A TO THE
STAFF OF THE COMMITTEE AND TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR A BEING UP
THIS BILL I NOT ONLY AM
REPRESENTING. OF THE HOUSING
AUTHORITY THE COUNTY OF YOLO
ABOVE BUT IN THE BROADER CONTEXT
OPERATORS OF THE MIGRANT FARM
WORKER PROGRAM. YOU'RE VERY
EXCITED ABOUT AB TWO EIGHTY
SEVEN OF BECAUSE A AS THE
MEMBERS OF MOST LIKELY KNOW THIS
BILL HAS BEEN IN STATUTE FOR
VERY LONG TIME WITH OUT A CHANGE
AND. A TIME MARCHES ON AND WE'RE
CERTAINLY INTO A DIFFERENT
AGRICULTURAL WORLD.
THEN WE WERE.
FIFTY SOME YEARS AGO SO OF THE
MODIFICATIONS TO THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE STREAMLINING FOR THE
STATE AS WELL AS FOR THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS.
AS WELL AS ALLOW US TO COLLECT
AGGREGATED DATA TO BETTER MEET
THE NEEDS OF OUR. A COMMUNITIES
OF THAT WE SERVE. AND.
ALLOW US TO CONTINUE TO INVEST
IN THAT SO THAT WE HAVE STABLE
SECURE AND. DECENT FARM WORKER
HOUSING FOR OF THOSE MIGRANT
FARM WORKERS AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER A QUESTION TO THE
COMMITTEE.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
OTHER SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL.
PLEASE SIR STEP UP TO THE MIKE.
OH YES SIR ROB WIENER CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR RURAL HOUSING.
THE MIGRANT HOUSING STREAMS
HAVE CHANGED.
SEASONS HAVE CHANGED GROWING
PATTERNS.
PREPARES OF CHAINS AND THE
MIGRANT HOUSING PROGRAMS NOT
CHANGED SO THIS IS A A OF
IMPROVEMENT THAT'S.
WELL DO AND TO WE STRONGLY URGE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LIKE SPEAKER.
MELISSA ORDER ON BEHALF OF THE
FAMILY WHY MAKERS OF CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT.
AND ANY OPPOSITION.
NICHOLAS CHAVEZ ON BEHALF THE
UNITED FARM WORKERS.
I WITH REMOVAL OF SECTION FOUR
OF THIS BILL VFW REMOVES ITS
OPPOSITION OWN MAIN NEUTRAL
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
LET'S BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS.
I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMITMENT TO.
TO OUR FARM WORKERS.
WE KNOW THAT.
IT AS OUR STATE IS SUFFERING A
VERY INTENSE HOUSING CRISIS IT'S
OUR FARM WORKERS WHO ARE.
LIKE OTHERS SEEN THE
SIGNIFICANT PRINTER THAT'S
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON THIS
ALSO APPRECIATE YOU WORKING WITH
YOU OF W. TO.
TO TAKE THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE
HAD I KNOW THERE ARE STILL SOME
REMAINING ISSUES THAT AT SOME
POINT WILL HAVE TO ADDRESS. IN
THE SUBJECT MATTER THAT YOU
WANTED TO ADDRESS AND I DO HOPE
THAT ALL PARTIES CAN.
FIGURE THIS OUT.
IN THE FUTURE BUT THAT WITH
THAT.
I DO HAVE A TO PASS IS
RECOMMENDED AS AMENDED.
RECOMMENDATION FOR OUR
COMMITTEE OUT WE DO NOT HAVE A
QUORUM SO I CAN'T TAKE A MOTION
AT THIS POINT BUT WE WILL DO
THAT AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
JUST REMEMBER YOU'LL SEE ME BACK
EVERY YEAR TO MAKE THIS WORK
LOOK FOR TO SENIOR.
THANK YOU.
AND I'LL SEE YOU IN YOUR
COMMITTEE THIS AFTERNOON.
LET'S GO TO MISS IRWIN.
FILE ITEM TEN AB TWENTY NINE
TWELVE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND.
MEMBER.
AB TWENTY NINE TWELVE REQUIRES
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS TO
SECURE ADDITIONAL INSURANCE AND
REVIEW FINANCIAL DOCUMENTS ON A
MORE. REGULAR BASIS RECENT
INSTANCES OF EMBEZZLEMENT OR
FINANCIAL MISMANAGEMENT WITH
ASSOCIATION FUNDS OF CAUSE ALARM
WITHIN THESE COMMUNITIES A NEWS
ARTICLE FOR.
OCTOBER TWENTY SEVENTEEN
REPORTS THAT A RETIREMENT
COMMUNITY IN INDIO CALIFORNIA
FOUND A HUNDRED AND TEN THOUSAND
A DISCREPANCY BETWEEN. WHAT THE
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION RECORDED
IN THEIR FINANCES AND WHAT THEIR
MANAGEMENT COMPANY HAD RECORDED?
IT WAS LATER FOUND THAT AN
EMPLOYEE HAD EMBEZZLED EMBEZZLED
THE FUNDS.
THIS BILL TAKES A STEP FORWARD
IN PREVENTING THIS TYPE OF
MISMANAGEMENT BY REQUIRING
MONTHLY MONITORING OF FINANCIAL
DOCUMENTS PREVENTING ELECTRONIC
MONEY TRANSFERS WITHOUT BOARD
APPROVAL. AND REQUIRING
ASSOCIATIONS TO MAINTAIN PHI
DELTA THE BOND INSURANCE.
YOUR WITNESS.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBER
OF THE COMMITTEE LARA KNOW AND
HE DID ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNITY ASSOCIATIONS INSTITUTE
CALIFORNIA LEGAL AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE. IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL AND THIS IS A GREAT
STEP IN ENSURING THAT OUR
HOMEOWNERS ARE PROTECTED FROM
MISMANAGEMENT OR EMBEZZLEMENT OF
FUNDS.
AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND
I'M HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER SUPPORTERS.
ANY OPPOSITION.
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS.
MISTER GLORIA AMATUS CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU TO MY
COLLEAGUE FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND THIS IS SOMETHING I
HAD THE BILL SOME AND I'M HAPPY
TO SUPPORT IN THE FLORIDA HAD
UNICORNS DO SO. I AM I WOULD SAY
I THINK THIS IS AN AREA FOR
THEIR.
.
ACTION BY THE BY THIS BY THIS
COMMITTEE AND WHEN I LOOK AT
SOME OF THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR.
RENTAL OR PURCHASE AT IN MY
DISTRICT WITH MULTI FAMILY DENSE
URBAN WHATEVER.
YOU CAN GET BY ON THE RANCH OR
THE EIGHT.
OR THE MORTGAGE BUT IS THE H.
AWAY FEED THAT I DON'T THINK HAS
A LOT OF CLARITY IN IT YEAH I
THINK SOME OF THE EXCESSES THAT
OR THE. BADDIES YOU'RE
DESCRIBING A MOMENT AGO.
IN AUGUST OF THIS BILL
ADDRESSES SOME OF AB OF SOME
FURTHER EFFORTS TO MAKE SURE TO
TAKE THESE UNITS WHICH ARE MAYBE
ON THEIR FACE SOMEWHAT MORE
AFFORDABLE BUT ONCE YOU PUT THE
H. AWAY FEE ON TOP OF IT.
BECOME UNATTAINABLE AND THEN AS
WE LOOK AS A STRATEGY OF TRYING
TO DO MORE URBAN INFILL AND
DENSER.
KINDS OF PROPERTIES WE REALLY
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE ARE
THE FEES THAT ARE NECESSARY IN
ORDER MAKE THE PLACE WORK AND
NOT A BARRIER TO ACTUAL
HOMEOWNERSHIP.
OR OR BE IMPLEMENTED AT A
FAIRLY WAIT REASONABLE RATES ARE
JUST AN OBSERVATION FOR
ADDITIONAL WORK ON IT. THAT
THINK THAT MY COLLEAGUE IN FOR
THE BILL AND MAYBE ENCOURAGED TO
DO MORE IN THE SPACE BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT THAT'S A SIR THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
AND WE DO THINK THAT THIS IS THE
FIRST STEP TOWARD THAT TYPE OF
TRANSPARENCY
I THINK IT'S FANTASTIC.
GREAT THANK YOU AND.
I WOULD ALSO AGREE WITH THAT MR
GLORIA THINK THIS IS A.
SENSIBLE NARROWLY TAILORED
APPROACH TO HELPING TO ADDRESS
FINANCIAL MISMANAGEMENT AND
FRAUD.
IN THESE AREAS AND WITH THAT I
HAVE A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION OF
THE COMMITTEE WE DO NOT YET HAVE
A QUORUM SO WHEN WE DO WE WILL.
MAKE THAT MOTION WITH THE FORT.
MUCH THANKS FOR VISITING.
MISTER DALY.
FILE ITEM FIFTEEN AB THIRTY ONE
TWENTY FOUR.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
ALL BEGIN BY CONFIRMING THAT I
AM ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THIS MORNING.
AND I'M COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF AND
OUR SPONSORS.
AND THE OPPONENTS.
AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD IF IT
DOES MOVE FORWARD.
THE OBJECTIVE OF THIS BILL IS TO
STRENGTHEN THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT BY CLOSING
LOOPHOLES THAT UNDERMINE THE
LAWS APPLICABLE WOODY
INEFFECTIVENESS.
UNDER THAT ACT WHEN PROPOSED
PROJECT COMPLIES WITH OBJECTIVE
PLANNING RULES THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT CANNOT DENY THE
PROJECT OR REDUCE ITS DENSITY.
UNLESS IT MAKES OF FINDING THE
PROJECT WOULD HAVE A SPECIFIC
ADVERSE IMPACT ON PUBLIC HEALTH
OR SAFETY.
THE CANNOT OTHERWISE BE
MITIGATED.
UNFORTUNATELY SOME LOCAL
AGENCIES HAVE REQUIRED HOUSING
PROJECT PROJECTS TO OBTAIN
REZONING IS OR VARIANCES ON A
PROJECT BY PROJECT BASIS.
EVEN WHEN PROJECTS ARE
CONSISTENT WITH HOUSING DENSITY
AND OTHER OBJECTIVE STANDARDS.
SUCH REZONING IS OR ZONING
VARIANCES ARE AWAY FROM LOCALS
TO EVADE COMPLIANCE WITH HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT ON THE
GROUNDS THAT PROJECTS ARE
SUBSEQUENTLY INCONSISTENT WITH
THESE EXISTING ZONING STANDARDS.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO UPHOLD THE
ORIGINAL INTENT OF THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT WHICH IS TO
ENSURE THAT MORE HOUSING GETS
BUILT CALIFORNIA.
HERE TODAY WITH ME TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF MY BILL ARE. AIRING
GUERRERO. OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND MICHAEL LANE WHO'S THE
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR THE
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
YOUR WITNESSES.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
FAHRINGER WITH CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION.
AS YOU ALL WELL KNOW FROM OUR
CONVERSATIONS LAST YEAR THE
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT IS
PASSED BACK IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
TWO UNDER SIMILAR SITUATION AS
TODAY HOUSING CRISIS.
SINCE IT WAS PAST IT'S BEEN
CONSTANTLY RE JIGGER TRYING TO
REALLY CLOSE LOOPHOLES AND MAKE
IT EFFECTIVE.
AND I JUST WANTED TO SPEAK
BRIEFLY TO TO THE LOOPHOLES THAT
THIS BILL SEEKS TO CLOSE ONE HAS
TO DO WITH HEALTH AND SAFETY.
AND THE OTHER IS ZONING AND
JUST GIVE YOU A COUPLE QUICK
EXAMPLES.
AND IN ONE CITY FOR EXAMPLE THEY
HAVE PLANNED UNIT DEVELOPMENT
ZONING. WHICH IS FREE OF ANY
DENSITY REQUIREMENTS.
THIS BY NECESSITY REQUIRES WHEN
YOU GOING TO GET A PROJECT TO
PROVE THAT YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO BE REZONED WHICH
AUTOMATICALLY MAKES IT NOT FALL
UNDER THAT HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT.
AND A SECOND EXAMPLE RELATED TO
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY AND
EXEMPTION AND THERE IS A A CITY
MEMO WHERE THAT THE CITY STAFF
RECOMMENDS.
THAT THEY COME UP WITH CREATIVE
EXCUSES AND.
HEALTH AND SAFETY CONCERNS A
LITTLE BIT OF A SOMETIMES A
REACH JUST IN ORDER TO EVADE.
THE HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT.
SO THIS BILL SEEKS TO CLOSE
THOSE LOOPHOLES AND TRY TO MAKE
THE HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT
AS EFFECTIVE AS POSSIBLE SO WE
CAN GET SOME UNITS BUILT. WERE
CURRENTLY ON THAT EACH CD SAYS
WE NEED TO BUILD ABOUT A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY THOUSAND UNITS A
YEAR.
AND WE'RE PRODUCING ABOUT HALF
OF THOSE SO THIS BILL IS
INTENDED TO SPUR. BUILDING AND
AT A TIME WHEN WE NEED IT THE
MOST THANK YOU.
CHURCH IN MEMBER.
MICHAEL IN WITH THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION IN
CALIFORNIA GREAT WORK WAS DONE
LAST YEAR WITH THE HOUSING
PACKAGE INCLUDING BILLS BY SOME
A MEMBER DALY AND SENATOR
SCANNER TO STRENGTHEN THE
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT.
HOWEVER THERE IS AN OUTSTANDING
ISSUE THAT WAS NOT ADDRESSED IN
LAST YEAR'S LEGISLATION NAMELY
THE USE AND ABUSE OF THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY EXEMPTION THE ACT
WHICH IS OFTEN GONNA CATCH ON
LEUPOLD. TO DELAY DOWNSIZING
DENY AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS.
AB THIRTY ONE NINETY FOUR
CLARIFIES THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE PROVIDE SPECIFIC
GUIDANCE ONE HOW THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY STANDARD IN THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT. IS TO BE
INTERPRETED AND APPLIED AND
UNDER WHAT LIMITED CIRCUMSTANCES
IT MAY BE INVOKED. THESE
CLARIFICATIONS AB THIRTY ONE
NINETY FOUR INCREASE OBJECTIVITY
TRANSPARENCY CONSISTENCY AND
PREDICTABILITY AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT DECISION MAKING AND
PROJECT APPROVALS FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS AND REDUCE
THE POTENTIAL FOR LITIGATION.
AND FOR THESE REASONS WE URGE
AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
OTHER SUPPORTERS.
HI LIZ BRONTE FROM CALIFORNIA BE
I JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT
THE AJ'S A REALLY IMPORTANT TOOL
IN ESPECIALLY ARE MORE
EXCLUSIONARY SUBURBAN
COMMUNITIES. I'M AFFILIATED WITH
AN ORGANIZATION THAT IS A
SUCCESSFULLY SUING PLACES LIKE
UPLAND SOUTH LEO FOR AJ
VIOLATIONS AND I JUST WANT TO
REITERATE THAT IT'S NOT.
THIS ISN'T SO MUCH A SAN
FRANCISCO OR SAN DIEGO ISSUE
THIS IS MUCH MORE OF A AND A
EXCLUSIONARY SUBURBAN. THANKS.
IT'S A.
IN SUPPORT.
AND OTHERS.
OPPOSITION.
CITY GEORGE REPRESENTING
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH YOUR
STAFF AND THE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
STAFF WE APPRECIATE THAT. AND WE
HAVEN'T SEEN THE ACTUAL
AMENDMENTS YET SO IT'S DIFFICULT
TO SAY ONE WHERE THE OTHER
WHETHER OR NOT WE WOULD BE OKAY
WITH THAT. OUR MAIN CONCERN IS
TO MAKE SURE THAT IF THE ZONING
IN THE HOUSING ELEMENT IN THE
GENERAL PLAN ARE INCONSISTENT.
THAT IF YOU WANT TO USE THE
HIGHEST DENSITY IF DEVELOP ONCE
YOU THE HIGHEST DENSITY IN THE
HOUSING ELEMENT THAT'S FINE WITH
US BUT WE WANT TO BE SURE THAT
IT'S CONSISTENT WITH THE HOUSING
ELEMENT. NOT THE LAND USE
ELEMENT OF THE GENERAL PLAN IT'S
TOO GENERAL IT'S OUT THIRTY
YEARS AND I THINK IT INVITES
SPRAWL IF YOU'RE NOT REALLY
CAREFUL BECAUSE. IF THE
DEVELOPER DOESN'T WANNA DO
REZONING. AND IT'S MAYBE ZONE
FOR HOUSING BUT NOT YET AND WE
WANT TO BE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT
PUSHING OUT AG LAND THAT WERE
STILL WEAK CONSISTENT WITH S. B.
THREE SEVENTY FIVE.
.
FOR THE TRANSIT IS THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS IT CETERA SO.
IF IT'S CONSISTENT WITH THE LAND
USE ELEMENT WE WILL NOT BE ABLE
TO AGREE TO THAT IS JUST
TO BROUGHT INTO GENERAL IT'S
MEANT TO BE.
AND WE WANT TO BE SURE THAT
WERE CONSISTENT WITH S. B. THREE
SEVENTY FIVE WHATEVER CHANGES
ARE MADE TO THE BELL.
ON THE ISSUE OF.
ADVERSE IMPACT
THAT DEFINITION AND THERE WERE
NOT REALLY SURE WHAT IT DOES
IT'S AN INTENT LANGUAGE SECTION.
SOME OF THE DAY THAT TERMS THAT
ARE USED IN THERE ARE NOT
DEFINED SO WE WOULD LIKE TO WORK
WITH YOU ON THAT BECAUSE IT'S
AND IT'S NOT CLEAR US EXACTLY
WHAT IT DOES. ON AND WE DON'T
HAVE TO GO TO COURT TO DECIDE SO
THOSE ARE THE MAIN ISSUES FOR
US.
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES ALSO IN OPPOSITION I'M
ALL JUST ECHO THE ISSUES THAT
APA BROUGHT UP REGARDING THE
ADVERSE IMPACTS SECTION WE DO
THINK THERE'S A LOT OF UNCLEAR
NEW LANGUAGE. ADDED TO THE BILL
AND SO WHILE THE PROPONENTS
ARGUING THAT THIS IS GOING TO
INCREASE CLARITY WE THINK THAT
COURTS ARE GONNA HAVE TO GO
THROUGH LITIGATION TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT THOSE NEW PROVISIONS
ACTUALLY MEAN.
SEE STOCK IS THE REPRESENTATIVE
OF THE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA AS YOU KNOW COUNTIES
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR PLANNING AND
ZONING FOR HOUSING IN THE
UNINCORPORATED AREAS OF THE
STATE. AND SO WHILE WE
APPRECIATE THAT THE INTENT OF
THIS MIL BILL MIGHT BE FOCUSED
ON URBANIZED AREAS AND MAYBE
INFILL PROJECTS WHERE. I'M
THEY'RE CONCERNED ABOUT ZONING
AND NOT BEING AS HIGH AS ALLOWED
IN THE GENERAL PLAN WE THINK
THERE'S GONNA BE PERVERSE
IMPACTS IN THE UNINCORPORATED
AREAS OF THE STATE. WHERE ZONING
MAY ALLOW FOR LOW DENSITY
HOUSING RIGHT NOW BUT BECAUSE OF
THE LONG TERM DESIGNATION IN THE
GENERAL PLAN THIS IS ALLOWING
AND SOMEONE TO COME IN AND GET A
PROJECT APPROVED? THAT'S
INCONSISTENT WITH THE UNDERLYING
ZONING ORDINANCE AND DOING
CONSTRUCTION IN A WAY THAT'S
INCONSISTENT WITH OUR BROADER
SPRAWL GOALS WITH PROTECTIONS
FOR NATURAL RESOURCES AND OTHER
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES SO WE
ALSO WOULD APPRECIATE I'M
LANGUAGES EPA MENTIONED. TO LINK
THIS TO THE HOUSING ELEMENT
WHERE WE ARE ACTUALLY LOOKING AT
DENSITIES ON A PARCEL BY PARCEL
BASIS RATHER THAN JUST ASSUMING
THAT ANY RURAL PARCEL THAT
ALLOWS FOR SOME LEVEL OF
RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPMENT RIGHT
NOW. SHOULD BE AT THE MAXIMUM
GENERAL PLAN WHEN YOU SAYS A
NATION SO AND FOR THOSE REASONS
WERE OPPOSED AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR ON THESE ISSUES.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER. OPPOSITION.
JOINT FORCE WITH THE URBAN
COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA ALSO IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
OKAY COLLEGE ME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS.
I JUST WANNA THANK A MR DEL YOU
KNOW YOU HAVE BEEN.
CHAMPION OF MAKING SURE THAT
THE HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT
IS ONE THAT WORKS TO ACCOMPLISH
THE GOALS THAT WE NEED OF MAKING
SURE THAT JURISDICTION'S ARE
BEING HELD ACCOUNTABLE TO WHAT
THEY SHOULD BE BUILDING. DURING
OUR HOUSING CRISIS I APPRECIATE
YOU TAKING THE AMENDMENTS OUGHT
TO THIS BILL I ALSO APPRECIATE
THAT YOUR COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH OUR COMMITTEE ON.
FUTURE LANGUAGE I THINK I'M.
I HAS SHARED THE CONCERN ABOUT
HOW WE MIGHT BE INADVERTENTLY
ENCOURAGING DEVELOPMENT IN
GREENFIELDS AN AG LAND BY
RELYING TOO HEAVILY ON ZONING
AND OUR GENERAL PLAN SO.
LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH YOU
AND CONTINUE TO REFINE THIS BUT
THAT BEING SAID I THINK WE MADE
SOME GOOD HEADWAY TODAY. AND
DON'T WANT TO CONTINUE THAT SO
WITH THAT. BY THE DO PASSES
AMENDED RECOMMENDATION TO THE
COMMITTEE WE CAN'T TAKE A VOTE
AT THIS TIME WITHOUT A QUORUM
BUT WE'LL DO THAT AT THE
APPROPRIATE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ARM I
NEGLECTED TO MENTION THE.
CERN THAT I SHARE WITH SOME OF
THE OPPONENTS ABOUT.
THE DEVELOPMENT IN RURAL AREAS
OR ON GREEN FIELDS SO WE ARE WE
ARE READY TO CONTINUE TALKING TO
ON THAT SUBJECT.
.
ESPECIALLY TO ADDRESS A THE
PROSPECT OF SPRAWL.
THANK YOU GREAT THANK YOU.
IT'S A COLOR.
FILE ITEM THIRTEEN AB THIRTY
EIGHTY FIVE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CALIFORNIA'S HOMELESS
POPULATION CONTINUES TO
INCREASING ACCORDING TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND URBAN
DEVELOPMENT.
THEIR MOST RECENT AND.
ANNUAL HOMELESSNESS ASSESSMENT
REPORT AS OF LAST YEAR THE
OVERALL STATEWIDE COUNT HAS
SURGED TWO HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
EIGHT PEOPLE.
THIS BILL WILL INCENTIVIZE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO EITHER PURSUE A
HOMELESS IMPORT IMPLEMENT
PROGRAM OF THEIR OWN OR EXPAND
ON AN EXISTING ONE THIS BILL
CREATES THE NEW BEGINNINGS
CALIFORNIA PROGRAM WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY SERVICES
AND DEVELOPMENT. AND NEW
BEGINNINGS CALIFORNIA WILL
FUNCTION AS A GRANT PROGRAM
WHERE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS MAY
APPLY FOR MATCHING FUNDS
EMPLOYMENT OR EXPANDED
EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM FOR HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS. IN ORDER TO QUALIFY
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS EMPLOYMENT
PROGRAM MUST MEET CERTAIN
CRITERIA INCLUDING AN HOURLY
WAGE OF AT LEAST MINIMUM WAGE IN
CONNECTING PROGRAM PARTICIPANTS
WITH OTHER SERVICES AND
RESOURCES.
AT LEAST SIXTEEN CALIFORNIA
CITIES HAVE INTRODUCED HOMELESS
EMPLOYMENT PROGRAMS THE
PARTICULAR ADMINISTRATIVE AND
FUNDING STRUCTURES OF THESE
PROGRAMS DIFFER BUT THEY
GENERALLY RESTS ON
COLLABORATIONS BETWEEN CITY
GOVERNMENTS. AND SO SOCIAL
SERVICE NON PROFITS
THE CITY OF DENVER COLORADO
LAUNCHED ONE SUCH PROGRAM IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN CALLED THE
DENVER DAY WORKS PROGRAM. IN THE
IN THE PROGRAM'S FIRST YEAR NEED
NEARLY TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY FOUR
PEOPLE WERE MATCHED WITH WORK
OPPORTUNITIES AND A HUNDRED AND
TEN OF THESE PARTICIPANTS.
FOUND PERMANENT EMPLOYMENT
EITHER WITH THE CITY OR COUNTY
ARE WITH PRIVATE BUSINESSES
HIRING PARTNERS.
THE NEW BEGINNINGS CALIFORNIA
PROGRAM WILL BUILD OFF OF THE
SUCCESS THAT THESE EMPLOYMENT
PROGRAMS HAVE FOUND IN CITIES
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY COUNTRY.
AB THIRTY EIGHTY FIVE SEEKS TO
TO OFFER ANOTHER TOOL TO HELP
THE HOMELESS CITIZENS OF OUR
STATE BY CONNECTING THEM WITH
THE SERVICES THEY NEED WHILE
OFFERING THEM. THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ACHIEVE THE SELF CONFIDENCE
THAT OFTEN COMES WITH THE JOB
WELL DONE. AFTER SOME
CONVERSATIONS WITH OF THE
COMMITTEE I RESPECTFULLY ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS.
AND I WILL BE TAKING THOSE
TODAY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE ON THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE TO HELP COMBAT
CALIFORNIA'S EVER GROWING ON
THIS ISSUE.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
IS ANNA HASEBE LAD. WITH THE
UNITED WAYS OF CALIFORNIA.
YOUR WITNESS.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ON A HASSELBLAD WITH
UNITED WAYS OF CALIFORNIA AND WE
ARE PACKED PROUD TO SUPPORT A.
B. THIRTY EIGHTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMAN MAJORITY LEADER
CALDERON. WHICH WILL CREATE A
NEW BEGINNINGS CALIFORNIA GRANT
PROGRAM TO PROVIDE MATCHING
FUNDS TO ELIGIBLE CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO IMPLEMENT OUR EXPAND
EMPLOYMENT PROGRAMS FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. AS WE
ALL KNOW CALIFORNIA'S IN THE
MIDST OF A HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
WITH THE NATION'S LARGEST
HOMELESS POPULATION AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY SO FOR MANY
VULNERABLE GROUPS INCLUDING
FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN AND
VETERANS.
UNITED WAYS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
ARE DEEPLY INVOLVED WITH LOCAL
HOMELESSNESS INITIATIVES AND ARE
VERY AWARE OF THE IMPACT THIS
CRISIS HAS ON COMMUNITIES ALL
OVER OUR STATE. WELL THERE ARE
MANY SOLUTIONS NEEDED THE NEW
BEGINNINGS GRANT PROGRAM IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP TO MOVE HOMELESS
FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS IN THE
HOUSING AND FINANCIAL STABILITY.
CITIES AND COUNTIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF STARTED PURSUING
ADDITIONAL STRATEGIES TO AID OF
THOSE IN NEED WITH SEVERAL
IMPLEMENTING PROGRAMS THAT
PROVIDE HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS
WITH WORK WHILE PROVIDING EASY
IT EASIER ACCESS TO SERVICES. AB
THIRTY EIGHTY FIVE INSURANCE
FLEXIBILITY FOR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES TO RESPOND TO THEIR
UNIQUE NEEDS AND POPULATIONS.
AND ACTS AS ANOTHER TOOL IN THE
TOOL CHEST TO INTERVENE EARLIER.
WITH HOUSING AND SECURE
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES WHILE
PROVIDING THE DIGNITY OF FAIR
WORK AND WAGES THE NEW
BEGINNINGS CALIFORNIA GRANT
PROGRAM WILL ALSO PROVIDE MUCH
NEEDED RESOURCES TO DEVELOP
RELATIONSHIPS AND TRUST WITHIN
COMMUNITIES IN KEY DEMOGRAPHICS
THAT MAY NOT BE CONNECTED WITH
THE SERVICES AND SUPPORTS. THAT
WILL LIFT THEM UP AND INTO SELF
SUFFICIENCY OUR LOCAL UNITED
WAYS NO WELL THE CHALLENGES THAT
TOO MANY INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS FACE AND ACCESSING
DESPERATELY NEEDED CERTAIN
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS. FROM
HOUSING EMPLOYMENT MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
SERVICES AMONG MANY OTHERS.
AB THIRTY EIGHTY FIVE PROVIDES A
SMART INCENTIVE FOR EMERGING
PROGRAMS THAT WE KNOW HELP MEET
THE NEEDS OF AT RISK POPULATIONS
AND CREATE STRONGER COMMUNITY
CONNECTIONS AND OPPORTUNITIES.
FOR DIGNITY AND PURPOSE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO SERVE FOR THESE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU BEFORE
WE CONTINUE I AM FORTUNATE HAVE
TO GO VOTE ACROSS THE HALLWAY
TO.
ALLOW COMMITTEE TO END BUT I
WILL TURN THE GAVEL OVER TO OUR
VICE CHAIR MR MAIENSCHEIN AND I
JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR HIS ENGAGEMENT WITH ME AND
OUR STAFF ON THIS I THINK. YOU
BROUGHT FORTH AN INNOVATIVE WAY
TO GO ABOUT HELPING TO.
TO TO MOVE ALMOST FOLKS AND
OFFER STREETS AND AND INTO
GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT I ALSO
APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
ACCEPT THE AMOUNTS TO. UP BRING
IT IN CLOSE ALIGNMENT WITH WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO WITH OUR
HOUSING FIRST POLICY AND. WITH
THAT I WILL AT THE RIGHT TIME WE
HAVE INTO THE QUORUM.
AT ENTERTAIN A THOUGHT DO PASS
TO THE NEXT COMMITTEE WITH A
MOMENT SO WITH THAT I'M GOING TO
PASS IT OVER TO MISTER MAY CHECK
THINKING.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES WITH THE AMENDMENT TO
ADD COUNTIES TO THE ELIGIBLE AYE
GRANTEES AND WILL BE MOVING INTO
SPORT THANK YOU.
JOINT OR SO THE URBAN CABS A
CALIFORNIA ALSO HAD A SUPPORTIVE
AMENDED BUT VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THAT THE I MUST INCLUDE COUNTIES
THAT WE PROVIDE THAT CRITICAL ON
SERVICES NEEDED TO THE HOMELESS
THANK YOU.
MORNING TRACY RYAN RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTS A CALIFORNIA ALSO
WITH THE SUPPORT IF AMENDED
APPRECIATE.
THE AUTHOR TAKING THE AMENDMENT
AND.
WE ASK PRIVATE.
THANK YOU YOU KNOW WHEN
ASSISTANCE SUPPORT SEEN NINE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE.
.
SCOTT ON THE I THINK THIS A
GREAT BILL I THINK I'M I'M
REALLY PLEASED TO SUPPORT IT
TODAY A COUPLE THINGS THAT I
THINK ARE IN THE EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES ARE AVAILABLE WAS
IS. A GOOD ANGLE AT DOING THIS I
WORKED WITH THE UNITED WAY. AYE
IN SAN DIEGO ON HOMELESSNESS
AND.
SECTOR SHAPE THEIR INVOLVEMENT
THEY'VE ALWAYS BEEN.
UP AND DOWN THE STATE YOU GUYS
HAVE BEEN STRONG SUPPORTERS OF
HOMELESSNESS.
AND I I THINK TO WHAT'S
IMPORTANT THAT YOU'RE DOING HERE
IS YOU HAVE MATCHING FUNDS
AVAILABLE AND.
THE THIS IS ALLOWING CITIES AND
COUNTIES THAT ARE SERIOUS ABOUT
ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS.
TO. GET HELP FROM THE STATE BUT
IT'S ALSO IN THE FOR THE PLACES
THAT DON'T WANT TO DO ANYTHING
ON HOMELESSNESS.
IT'S NOT INCLUDING THEM IN THIS
WHERE THAT MONEY WOULD GO TO
SOMETHING ELSE
SO I THINK THIS IS OUR.
BOTH THE RIGHT THING TO DO FROM
A POLICY STANDPOINT AT HIS
FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE AS WELL AND
IT'S A IT'S A. GREAT BILL AND
I'M REALLY PLEASED TO SUPPORT IT
ONCE WE GET A QUORUM IN HERE AND
I WAS WISEMAN ON FOR IN A SECOND
BUT.
IF I'M PLEASED TO MOVE THIS
BILL SCRAPED OFF. MISTER GLORIA.
THEY CAN IT'S MAIENSCHEIN A LOT
OF EXTRA SUCK IT IS WHILE I'M
JUST OUT COMMENTS I THINK THIS
IS SO IMPORTANT AND THAT IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT I HAVE A PROGRAM
THAT'S OPERATED SOMETHING LIKE
THIS INCENTIVE FOR MANY YEARS
WITHOUT THE PROJECT TAKE BACK
THE STREETS PROGRAM. I WOULD SAY
IN THE CONTEXT OF EVERYTHING
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS A STATE TO
ADDRESS THE HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO SHOW TO.
KATHLEEN TAXPAYERS THAT WERE
WILLING TO ASK THOSE WHO ARE
ABLE BODIED NAY AND WILLING TO
WORK TO WORK ON CERTAINLY A GOOD
NUMBER OF FOLKS.
WHO ARE HOMELESS ARE NOT
CAPABLE OF DOING THAT BUT FOR
THOSE THAT ARE ARE CREATING AN
AVENUE?
TO PUT THEM TO WORK AYE AS WELL
AS TO ENCOURAGE THEM TO DEVELOP
SKILL SETS THAT CAN ACTUALLY
POTENTIALLY SOMEDAY MAKE THEM.
THIS.
INDEPENDENT I THINK IS ACTUALLY
NECESSARY AND I APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS FOR TO SUPPORT
PROGRAMS LIKE ALFA PROJECTS OF
PROJECT IN SAN DIEGO AND THEY'VE
BEEN DOING IT FOR YEARS AND SOME
TO GET SOME STATE SUPPORT. A TO
CONTINUE THAT WORK WHICH IS
REALLY PRODUCTIVE I THINK MR
MAIENSCHEIN LIKE I HAVE SEEN OF
FOLKS WHO PARTICIPATE IN THAT
PROGRAM COME BACK AND AND AND
GET BACK ON THEIR OWN TWO FEET
WHICH SHOULD BE OUR OBJECTIVE
WHEREVER POSSIBLE SO.
I APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENT TO
INCLUDE A CEO SEES.
I KNOW THAT ARE WHAT WE TRY TO
DO IN SAN DIEGO'S CONSOLIDATE
ALL OF OUR PROGRAMS UNDER A
CONTINUUM OF CARE IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT BE. A
COLLABORATIVE REALIZED APPROACH
SAN DIEGO DOING IT BUT THE AGING
TWENTY CITY NOT DOING IT IS NOT
IS NOT GONNA CUT IT.
AND HOUSING FIRST DE CONNECTION
I APPRECIATE THAT ANOTHER I
RECOGNIZE THERE'S NOT ENOUGH
UNITS OF FOR EVERYONE AND.
THE IDEA THAT MAYBE SOME OF THE
WORKING.
POTENTIALLY GETTING UNIT WOULD
BE IDEAL BUT.
I APPRECIATE WORKING WITH THE
WITH THE CHAIRMAN TO TO GET THE
STUFF BUT ANYWAY THAT WAS BUILT
ON THE SCOTT ON THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BRINGING AFFORDABLE FOR
DEVOTING YES.
THANK YOU MEMBERS I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS I REALLY
DO I I THINK IS REALLY IMPORTANT
ISSUE THERE LOT OF DIFFERENT
WAYS A LOT OF DIFFERENT IDEAS ON
HOW WE SOLVE THIS ALMOST CALLS
HOMELESSNESS ISSUE.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THING THAT WE WE TOOK A LOT OF
BIG STEPS LAST YEAR WHEN NOW WE
PASS OUR HOUSING STE.
MEASURES.
AYE BUT AGAIN IT'S A MULTI
EFFORT MULTI YEAR EFFORT.
WITH MULTI.
APPROACHES ON ON HOW TO SOLVE
THIS ISSUE BUT I THINK THAT THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT PIECE BECAUSE
THERE IS DIGNITY THAT COMES WITH
HAVING A JOB. AND AGAIN YOU KNOW
YOU'RE GIVING PEOPLE AN
OPPORTUNITY THAT CAN WORK AS YOU
STATED MISTER GLORIA THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK AND I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE INCLUDE
THIS AS PART OF A PLANNED. TO
TRY TO HELP.
SOLVE THE HOMELESS ISSUES THAT
WE HAVE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND AND AGAIN THIS IS
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR. YOU KNOW
POTENTIALLY IF THERE ARE SOME
OPENINGS WITH IN SUPPORT OF
HOUSING YOU'RE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO CONNECT INDIVIDUAL SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING BECAUSE YOU KNOW IN
ORDER TO QUALIFY YOU GOTTA BE IN
THE SUPPORT OF HOUSING TO. TO TO
TO TO BE A TO BE IN LINE WITH
THE HOUSING FIRST.
REQUIREMENTS AND HOUSING FOR
SUPPORT PROGRAM AND AND SO YOU
KNOW I I I I I CAN'T IMAGINE
THAT THESE THESE EXTRA. A NON
PROFITS IN ORGANIZATIONS THAT
THE CITIES ARE PARTNERING
PARTNERING WHAT'S A HIT YET WE
CAN GET YOU KNOW SUPPORT HOUSING
PROGRAM THAT WE CAN GET YOU A
JOB AND. AND AND GET YOU BACK ON
YOUR FEET SO I THINK THAT THAT'S
AN IMPORTANT PART. OF THIS
PROGRAM AND.
NOT PREACHY AT THE SUPPORT OF
THE COMMITTEE APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS AND WHEN THERE'S A TIME
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
GREAT THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK.
ALRIGHT LET'S GO NOW TO MS COVER
EURO TO FILE ITEM FOURTEEN
THIRTY ONE FORTY SEVEN.
WELCOME.
IF YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO. PRESENT A. B.
THIRTY ONE FORTY SEVEN.
CALIFORNIA'S IN THE DEPTHS OF A
HOUSING CRISIS MARKED BY A
SEVERE LACK OF HOMES AND
APARTMENTS AFFORDABLE FOR VERY
LOW LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
FAMILIES. THERE'S MUCH TO DO TO
EXPEDITE THE PROCESS OF BUILDING
HOMES AND TO MAKE IT LESS
EXPENSIVE TO BUILD. ONE OF THE
BIGGEST BARRIERS TO INCREASING
SUPPLY AND AFFORDABILITY IS THE
IMPOSITION OF EXCESSIVE IMPACT
AND DEVELOPER FEES.
THAT WERE NOT REQUIRED BY THE
SENIOR COUNTY IN INITIAL
COMMUNICATIONS AND THAT ADD
SIGNIFICANTLY TO THE OVERALL
COST OF THE PROPOSED HOUSING
UNITS.
THAT IS WHY I AM PROUD TO
PRESENT A. B. THIRTY ONE FORTY
SEVEN TODAY WHICH WOULD PROHIBIT
CITIES AND COUNTIES FROM
CHARGING.
ADDING NEW IMPACT AND
DEVELOPMENT FEES TWO APPLICANTS
FOR HOUSING PROJECTS ONCE AN
APPLICATION IS DEEMED
SUBSTANTIALLY COMPLETE BY THE
JURISDICTION.
THESE NEW IMPACT OR DEVELOPMENT
FEES ARE USUALLY REQUIRED AS A
CONDITION FOR APPROVAL OF ANY
PROJECT. AND A DEVELOPER OR
BUILDER HAS NO RECOURSE BUT TO
AGREE TO THEM IF THEY WANT THE
PROJECT APPROVED. HOWEVER ALL
TOO OFTEN THESE FEES ARE
REVEALED LATE IN THE PROCESS
WELL AFTER THE DEVELOPER BUILDER
HAS BUDGETED FOR THE PROJECT AND
STARTED TO SPEND MONEY ON
PROPERTY ACQUISITION. AND
PROFESSIONALS BASED ON PUBLIC P.
FEE SCHEDULES. IN FACT ACCORDING
TO A RECENT UC BERKELEY TURNER
CENTER FOR HOUSING AND
INNOVATION STUDY. CERTAINTY FOR
DEVELOPER FEES IS A SIMPLE
POLICY CHANGE AND POLICY MAKERS
AT ALL LEVEL WORKING TO ADDRESS
THE HOUSING SHORTAGE SHOULD
BEGIN WITH.
IT HAS BECOME INCREASINGLY MORE
DIFFICULT AS A DEVELOPER BUILDER
TO BUDGET A PROJECT IN A BAD
ABOUT. A MISSED
THE UNCERTAINTIES AS TO WHAT
FEES REQUIREMENTS OR OTHER FEES
COULD COME INTO PLAY. AT ANY
STAGE OF THE PROCESS WHEN
DEVELOPMENT FEES ARE NOT
REVEALED NOT READILY ACCESSIBLE
REASONABLE AND PREDICTABLE IT IS
MUCH MORE DIFFICULT.
A PLAN BUDGET AND BUILD WHICH
ONLY EXACERBATES CALIFORNIA'S
HOUSING SHORTAGE I WISH TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF IN THE CHAIR
FOR ALL OF THEIR HARD WORK.
AND COMMIT TO TAKE THE COMMUNITY
THE HOUSING COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS WHICH ONE DEFINE THE
IMPACT AND DEVELOPMENT FEES
UNQUOTE. AND ADD THREE OFF RAMPS
THAT PROVIDE RELIEF FROM THESE
REQUIREMENTS SEQUEL HEALTH AND
SAFETY AND INFLATION COSTS
ESCALATORS.
I WILL TAKE THESE AMENDMENTS IN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE
SHOULD LOCAL GOVERNMENT AGREE TO
THEM.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND ONE WE
CANNOT IGNORE I AM COMMITTED TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE.
WITH ANY OPPOSITION THAT SHOULD
REMAIN I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. UP WITH ME IN
SUPPORT IS LA SUBSTANCE IN
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ACTUALLY IF WE COULD JUST FOR A
MOMENT DOCTOR WHAT. COULD WE
JUST A TAKE A QUORUM BEFORE YOU
HEAD OUT.
PERFECT EVEN BETTER SORRY SO I
STARTED ME TO CUT YOU OFF JUST
WANNA IS GOING TO GET THERE
COMMITTEE BUSINESS IN ORDER.
WANNA GRAB HIM WHILE HE'S HERE I
UNDERSTAND COMPLETELY.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IBOOK
GREAT THANK YOU AND.
WANT WE WANT WE CALL QUORUM
MADAM SECRETARY CHIU HERE
THROUGH HERE. MAIENSCHEIN. THEIR
MAIN CHIANG HERE CHAU.
CHOI. GLORIA GLORIA HERE LAMONT.
WHO WOULD?
WELL WE HAVE QUORUM THANK YOU.
WITHOUT TWO WITNESSES.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ASSISTANCE IN
HERE ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
THE SPONSORS OF AB THIRTY ONE
FORTY SEVEN.
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME I WOULD
LIKE TO KEEP MY COMMENTS BRIEF
AND SECOND WHAT THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CABALLERO SO EXPERTLY
STATED ABOUT THE NEED FOR THIS
BILL. BUT I'D ALSO LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT AGAIN THE NATURE OF
THIS HOUSING CRISIS AND HOW THIS
BILL WOULD HELP TAKE A STEP IN
ADDRESSING THAT.
WE ARE ALL WELL AWARE OF JUST
HOW DIRE THIS HOUSING CRISIS HAS
BEEN SINCE THE BOTTOM OF THE
GREAT RECESSION IN TWO THOUSAND
NINE THIS HAS BEEN THE SLOWEST
RECOVERY IN HISTORY AND WE ARE
STILL NOWHERE NEAR A HEALTHY
HOUSING MARKET.
EVERY DAY WE SEE CALIFORNIANS
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY WORSEN
WHILE THERE'S NO SILVER BULLET
WE CAN TAKE MEANINGFUL STEPS TO
ENSURING TRANSPARENCY IN
CONTAINING THE COSTS.
THIS BILL IS ONE OF THOSE
MEANINGFUL STEPS BY SEEKING TO
PROVIDE CERTAINTY AROUND THE
CONSTANT. AROUND THE CONSTANTLY
CHANGING FEES THAT ARE LEVIED ON
HOUSING PROJECTS.
WHILE WE HAVE GROWN ACCUSTOMED
TO PAYING THESE IMPACT FEES AS A
CONDITION OF APPROVAL THERE'S
ALSO GROWING CONCERN THAT THESE
EXACTIONS ARE REVEALED LATE IN
THE PROCESS CAUSING PROJECTS TO
BE RECONSIDERED. AND DRIVING UP
THE COST ON FUTURE HOME BUYERS.
CREATING THE SHIRT HE AROUND
THESE FEES INVOLVING.
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS ALLOWS A
PROJECT.
ALLOWS US TO PROVIDE HOUSING AT
LEVELS CITIZENS CAN ACTUALLY
AFFORD.
EACH LATE HATE CANNOT THOUSANDS
TO THE COSTS
AND IN CALIFORNIA EVERY TIME
THERE'S AN INCREASE OF A IN THE
COST OF A HOME BY A THOUSAND
DOLLARS IT PRICES ON OVER
FIFTEEN THOUSAND FAMILIES.
AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MENTIONED
THE UC BERKELEY TURNER CENTER
STUDY FOR HOUSING ERSTE TURNER
CENTER FOR HOUSING INNOVATION
RELEASED A STUDY LAST MONTH
REGARDING THE OVERALL COST OF
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT FEES. BY
DOING A CASE STUDY OF SEVEN
CALIFORNIA CITIES AMONG THE MAIN
FINDINGS THEY SUGGESTED THAT
CALIFORNIA ADOPT A FEE
TRANSPARENCY POLICY AND
IMPLEMENT BEST PRACTICES FOR
SETTING IN CHARGING FEES AND TO
DEFINE WHEN FEES CAN BE LEVIED.
AND CHANGED DURING THE
DEVELOPMENT PROCESS.
I WOULD LIKE TO AGAIN THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE.
I HAVE NICK CAMMARATA CBI
GENERAL COUNSEL HERE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS AND TECHNICAL
QUESTION ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE AND THINK YOU AGAIN
I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU THAT SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CORNELIUS BIRKA DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS FOR THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL REPRESENT THREE
HUNDRED THE LARGEST EMPLOYERS IN
THE THE BAY AREA. WE'RE PLEASED
TO SUPPORT A. B. THIRTY ONE
FORTY SEVEN.
AS YOU KNOW WE'RE IN A SEVERE
HOUSING CRISIS.
WE UNDER PRODUCE HOUSING UNITS
FOR FROM NUMEROUS YEARS NOW AND
ONE REASON FOR THAT IS THE HIGH
IN EXCESS OF BECAUSE OF FEES.
AB THIRTY ONE FORTY SEVEN WILL
BRING TRANSPARENCY AND FAIRNESS
TO THE FEE PROCESS.
IT WILL MAKE HIM.
MAJOR DAN AND SOLVING OUR
HOUSING CRISIS RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU LET'S GO TO OTHER
SUPPORTERS.
NONPROFIT.
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
YEAH I GOT IT WITH CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS IN
SUPPORT.
LOUIS MANDE WITH CALIFORNIANS
TRANSPORT.
DEBORAH CARL TO THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
MAUREEN HIGGINS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM IN
SUPPORT.
SOSA MAGNAT LIKE HOUSE PUBLIC
AFFAIRS HERE ON BEHALF OF
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIANS PART ABOUT THE
GIFT.
MOST ORDER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN SUPPORT.
LET'S GO NOW TO THE OPPOSITION
.
GOOD MORNING TRACY RIGHT FOR A
CAR REPRESENTS OF CALIFORNIA AND
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES.
WE BELIEVE THAT THE AMENDMENTS
THAT THE AUTHOR HAS A COMMITTED
TO TAKING DO.
HELP WITH THIS BILL WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS.
WE WOULD NEED TO SEE THE
LANGUAGE.
BEFORE THAT WE WOULD REMOVE
OPPOSITION BUT I THINK THAT THE
OVERALL ISSUE OF THE BILL BEING
PREMATURE STILL EXISTS. LAST
YEAR EIGHTY EIGHT SEVEN NINE WAS
PASSED.
BY THIS BODY AND PROVIDES A A
HOLISTIC AND COMPREHENSIVE
REVIEW OF THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
FEES LEVIED DURING DEVELOPMENT.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT WOULD BE A
BETTER WAY.
TO MAKE THIS DECISION BASED ON
DATA UP FROM THAT REPORT AND SO
WE WOULD ASK THAT THIS DECISION
IS IS LOOKED AT NEXT YEAR THANK
YOU.
SENATE GEORGE REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION.
WE DID WORK WITH THE STAFF OF
THE AUTHOR WE APPRECIATE THAT
AND ALSO COMMITTEE STAFF ON THIS
BILL. WE ACTUALLY SUPPORT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT ARE IN THAT
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE TAKEN. UP UNFORTUNATELY
HOWEVER WE THINK THAT THERE ARE
SOME THINGS THAT ARE STILL NOT
FIXED IN THE BILL THAT ARE HUGE
ISSUES FOR US.
WE CANNOT PASS ON IMPACTS FOR A
FIRE STATION OR WATER TREATMENT
FACILITY TO SOMEBODY ELSE.
IF WE GET REDEVELOPMENT BACK IN
THAT CAN BUY DOWN THOSE COSTS
WERE READY TO DO THAT HOPEFULLY
THAT WILL HAPPEN IN THE NEXT FEW
YEARS AS WELL. BUT WE CANNOT
AGREE TO JUST NOT IMPOSING THE
FEES.
.
WE DO NOT HAVE ENOUGH
INFORMATION AT THE APPLICATION
STAGE TO MAKE THE DETERMINATION
OF WHAT THE FEES WILL BE FOR THE
ENTIRE PROJECT AND WHAT HAPPENS
AFTER THAT. WE APPRECIATE SOME
OF THE OFF RAMPS BUT IT'S NOT
ENOUGH WE JUST ARE NOT GOING TO
BE ABLE TO DO THAT WE ARE MORE
THAN WILLING TO PUBLISH OUR FEES
SO THAT THE. DEVELOPER CAN
CALCULATE HIM OR HERSELF WHAT
THE FEES ARE WE WILL GIVE THEM
AN ESTIMATE AT THE TIME OF THE
APPLICATION CATION STAGE.
WE AGREED TO ADD ENTITLEMENT
FREEZING THE FEES FOR TWO YEARS
WE CAN'T DO UNLIMITED FREEZING
OF FEES.
WE ALSO ARE CONCERNED THAT IT
WOULD ENCOURAGE DEVELOPERS TO
NOT BUILD SOON AND WE ARE TRYING
TO GO IN THE OPPOSITE DIRECTION
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
DEVELOPMENTS ARE.
BUILT AS SOON AS WE POSSIBLY
CAN
SO UNFORTUNATELY OF THE WAY THE
BILL IS RIGHT NOW WE STILL VERY
MUCH OPPOSE THINKING.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER OPPOSITION.
CHILDREN OF COURSE ABOUT THE
URBAN CARRIES A CALIFORNIA ALSO
IN OPPOSITION.
CHRISSY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN OPPOSITION.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY DISCUSSION MISTER GLORIA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
THIS BILL.
BY ONE MAKE CLOTHES LARIFIED A
PRACTICABLE THINGS UP FOR STUFF
AND FORGIVE ME I'M IS COMING OR
DID YOU ACCEPT THE.
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
YES WE HAVE A WE HAVE
NEGOTIATED ON AMENDMENTS WHICH
WHICH ONES I JUST WANNA BE REAL
CLEAR THAT THAT YEAH I'M ASKING
THE.
.
ACTUALLY IF YOU WANT I CAN I CAN
ARTICULATE AND THAT WAS GREAT
DOUBLE CHECK SO. THAT WE IT'S
JUST OF THREE MOMENTS IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
WE WILL NOT BE TAKING THE FIRST
AMENDMENT AROUND THE PUBLICATION
A REQUIREMENT ON THE WEBSITE.
WE WILL TAKE THE SECOND
AMENDMENT OF A DEFINING IMPACT
AND DEVELOPMENT FEES AS THOSE
FEES ARE ESTABLISHED BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
AND THEN FOR THE THIRD.
WHAT WE AGREED TO WAS TO FREEZE
THE IMPACT OF DEVELOPMENT FEES
ARE WITHOUT INCLUDING COMMUNITY
BENEFIT AGREEMENTS AT THE POINT
THAT THE PROJECT OUT WHEN THAT
WHEN THE PROJECT APPLICATION IS
COMPLETE?
AND REQUIRE THOSE FEES TO BE
FROZEN FOR UP TO TWO YEARS SO
THAT'S WHAT. WE HAVE WORKED OUT.
YOU SO TO UNDERSTAND THAT FOR IT
THAT BANKING MISTREATMENT IN IN
YOU TAKING.
ONE IN THREE BUT NOT TO.
ACTUALLY TWO AND TWO AND THREE
SLIGHTLY AMENDED NOT ONE.
GOT IT OKAY YEAH I THINK IT WAS
HIGH LEVEL THAT IS REALLY HIGH
NUMBERS THAT I HAVE A HARD TIME
KEEPING UP WITH.
.
SO I THINK CERTAINTIES REALLY
IMPORTANT AND I AND I KNOW OUR
FRIENDS THE DEVELOPMENT INDUSTRY
FEEL THE SAME WAY IN ANOTHER OF
US WOULD BUY A BIG MAC IF WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE PRICE IT
WAS.
ON THE FRONT BY EVE SPEC THAT AS
A CONSUMER NOTHING SHOULD BE
DIFFERENT.
I THINK THAT JURISDICTION'S
SHOULD PUBLISH THESE I RECOMMEND
THIS DYNAMIC BUT ONCE THE.
PROJECT IS DEEMED COMPLETE THEN
THEY PURCHASE THE RIGHT THAT
THAT'S THAT'S HIDDEN THEY CAN
SHIFT LATER BUT YOU KNOW THAT
THE PIPELINE THING IN THAT
SHOULD BE HELD SEPARATELY.
I I I I GUESS THAT THAT THAT
THE QUESTIONS THAT I HAD BASS
NOW THAT I UNDERSTAND THE
CLARITY ON ON THE AMENDMENTS.
TO BE SUPER CLEAR COMMUNITY
BENEFITS SO YOU DID AS WAS
MENTIONED THAT'S NOT INCLUDED
THAT'S CORRECT I'M NIGHT IS ONE
OF THE DESPITE EXPAND ON THAT
JUST A LITTLE BIT YOU KNOW I
DIDN'T MISS COMEY ON AYE BOTH
SERVED IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT. I
THINK WE UNDERSTAND WHAT IT
SOMETIMES TAKES TO GET A
PROJECT.
APPROVED OF BY DECISION BODY
OUT AND THAT'S REALLY SEPARATE
FROM FEES NUMBER TO MAKE SURE
THAT WAS SUPER CLEAR IN TODAY'S
HEARING I KNOW IT'S IN THE BACK
UP. HERE NEAR TO IT SAYING YES.
BUT WE ARE THE END GOAL YOUR
OBJECTIVE IN THIS ACTUALLY BUILD
MORE HOUSING RIGHT AND TO REMOVE
A DECISION MAKING BODIES ABILITY
TO ACCESS A SIKH COMMUNITY
BENEFITS IN ORDER TO GET A
PROJECT TO PROVE. THAT WE WOULD
WANT TO GIVE UP THAT OPPORTUNITY
RIGHT RIGHT.
AND THEN BUSTED OUT WE THIS IS
NOT INCLUSIVE OF UTILITIES
THAT'S CORRECT IS A BOOK OF
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES AND PRIVATE
UTILITIES CRACKED SO THAT THE
WHOLE IDEA IS.
WE'RE NOT TRYING TO AFFECT THE
HOOK UPS ALL OF THAT SHOULD BE
VERY CLEAR FROM THE BEGINNING IN
ADDITION THERE THERE WAS A
COMMENT ABOUT FIRE STATION.
AND.
IF YOU KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO NEED
A FIRE STATION BECAUSE YOU'RE
BUILDING A WHOLE NEW DEVELOPMENT
THEN YOU BETTER START THE
PROCESS STERN GET UP TO GET A
FEE. AND BE ABLE TO ADD THAT IN
SO I'M NOT TRYING TO.
STOP THAT OR IF YOU'RE IN THE
MIDDLE OF THAT PROCESS TO SAY
YOU CAN'T GO THROUGH WITH THAT
PROCESS BECAUSE I JUMPED IN AND
I GOT MY. MY APPLICATION
COMPLETE WHAT IT REALLY IS A
STELLAR IS TO HIGHLIGHT HERE'S
WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE'S. HERE'S.
THE IMPACT IT COULD HAVE ON
YOUR ON YOUR PROJECT AND THAT
WAY YOU HAVE A PART AN
OPPORTUNITY PARTICIPATE AS PART
OF THE PUBLIC PROCESS AS WELL
SO.
GROUP BUT IS NOT INCLUSIVE OF
UTILITIES THAT'S CORRECT IT'S
NOT PRIVATE WHICH YOU
INCREASINGLY I HEAR FROM SOME OF
MY FOLKS IN SAN DIEGO THAT'S A
PROBLEM AS WELL YOU KNOW THAT
THAT'S A BIG TICKET. INVOICE IT
SENT TO THEM IT IS.
AND SO YOU KNOW I I DID PARTY
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THIS BILL
CONTINUE TO TRY AND LOOK AT THAT
PARTICULAR ISSUE BECAUSE I HEAR
THAT'S A CONCERN PROVOKES ARE
TRYING TO BUILD HOUSING BUT.
I LIVED LEADS WHAT I'M THIS IS
REALLY A WORKING PROXY PROGRESS
IN PART OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO IS THAT THE ONES THAT ARE.
THAT ARE REQUIRED BY LAW
ALREADY WE'RE NOT TRYING TO
CHANGE THOSE WERE JUST TRYING TO
SAY YOU'VE GOT TO TELL.
YOU GOT IT PARTICULATE THEM AND
THEN.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO INCREASE
THEM FOR ANY REASON YOU GOTTA GO
TO THE REGULAR PUBLIC PROCESS
AND.
AND THAT THAT THOSE ARE NOT THE
ONES WERE CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT
CONCERNED ABOUT THE ONCE GET
ADDED ON.
WITHOUT ANY NEXUS OR CONNECTION
TO ANYTHING.
WHO LASSOED TO SAY THAT THE
PROVISION FOR A THIS BEING GOOD
FOR TWO YEARS I THINK IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO KEEP COMMUNITIES
HOLE RIGHT I MEAN IF? IF
SOMEONE'S A SLOW WALK IN OR ARE
YOU JUST TRYING TO GET IN ON A
BARGAIN BASEMENT PRICE E. YOUR
BILL DOES NOT SPEAK TO THAT SO.
HE THIS IS GOOD FOR TWO YEARS
BUILD OR YOU LOSE THAT OR YOU
LOSE THE FREEZING OF THE FEET
STRIKE I THINK THAT'S EMILY
REASONABLE I'M HAPPY TO MOVE THE
BILL MISTER CHAIRMAN
APPRECIATION TO BE OUT THERE FOR
WORKING SO HARD TO USE.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
I DON'T THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
YOUR VERY DEEP ENGAGEMENT ON
THIS ISSUE I THINK YOU AND I HAD
MORE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS
BILL THAN ANY OTHER BILL THAT I
HAVEN'T FOR ME TODAY.
AND I ALSO WERE VERY MUCH I
THINK WE ALL SHARE THE GOAL OF
CERTAINTY AND TRANSPARENCY OF
WHAT DEVELOPERS HAVE TO PAY. IN
ORDER MOVE THINGS FORWARD VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR WORK WITH
US ON THE AMENDMENTS AND. AGAIN
TO ALSO JUST CLARIFY.
IT WE WOULD BE FREE SEEN IMPACT
AND DEVELOPMENT FEES ONE THE
APPLICATION'S COMPLETE NOT
INCLUDING. COMMUNITY BENEFIT
AGREEMENTS UTILITY FEES ETCETERA
SO.
I ALSO WILL JUST CLARIFY THAT
THESE AMENDMENTS.
THAT WOULD BE TAKEN UP BY THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE TODAY
ALONG WITH OTHERS THAT THEY MAY
THINK ABOUT AS IT MOVES THROUGH
COMMITTEE.
.
BUT I JUST THINK IF YOUR WORK I
I DO YOU LOOK FOR TO ADDITIONAL
FEEDBACK ON THIS AS WE MOVE
THROUGH THE PROCESS AND IF THERE
ARE OTHER IDEAS ON HOW WE CAN
HANDLE. SOME THESE THORNY ISSUES
BUT I THINK THE GOAL IS ONE THAT
THAT I SUPPORT AND I THINK MANY
THIS COMMITTEE WANNA SUPPORTS WE
LOOK FOR TO THE CONTINUE
CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE SHOULD
MISTER CHAIR I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE ALL YOUR TIME AND
ATTENTION TO THIS GREAT ANY
OTHER FILE CULTS.
ACTUALLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
OKAY A WE DO A QUORUM SO THERE'S
BEEN A MOTION BY MISTER GLORIOUS
OUR SECOND.
SECOND BY DOCTOR WOULD.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MOTIONLESS TO PASS REFERRED TO.
A COMMITTEE ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
CHIU PIPE CHIU AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN NIGHT CHAO.
CHOI GLORIA.
GLORIA IDLING LONG.
WHO WOULD?
WOULD I.
RIGHT.
VERY MUCH IF FOR VOTES YOUR BILL
IS OUT AND WILL KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS LET'S
NOW GO TO MISS FRIEDMAN.
S. FREEMAN HAS
TWO ITEMS TODAY.
FILE ITEM THREE AB TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY THREE AND FILE ITEM FOR A.
B.. TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY THREE MY
UNDERSTANDING IS ARE YOU LIKE
FOR FILE AND THREE FOR US TO
BRING THAT UP FOR DISCUSSION
ONLY. IDEA TO TALK ABOUT THAT
FIRST OR CALLING FOR WE'RE GONNA
START WITH TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY
THREE OKAY LET'S GET THE
BUSINESS OUT OF THE WAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FIRST I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE AND THE CHAIR FOR
THE DEDICATED WORK ON THIS
MEASURE. AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY
THREE. IS TRYING TO.
CREATE UNIFORM AND MORE
TRANSPARENCY WHEN IT COMES TO
LOCALS PROCESSING A DENSITY
BONUS APPLICATION IN A MORE
CONSISTENT TIMELY WAY. THE
DENSITY BONUS APPLICATION
PROCESS HAS BECOME LONG AND
ARDUOUS IN MANY AREAS AND CAN
DELAY PROJECTS AND ULTIMATELY
CATALYZE A PROJECTS DEMISE.
AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY THREE
GIVES MORE ASSURANCE TO
DEVELOPERS ABOUT THE STATUS OF
THEIR DENSITY BONUS APPLICATION
BY REQUIRING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO REPORT BACK TO DEVELOPERS AT
THE TIME OF THEIR APPLICATION IS
DEEMED COMPLETE. THE INCENTIVES
THAT THEY'RE ELIGIBLE FOR A CITY
COUNTY CITY OR. A CITY COUNTY
OR.
I MUST INFORM THE DEVELOPER OF
THEIR ELIGIBILITY FOR THE AMOUNT
OF AFFORDABLE UNITS PARKING
RATIO INCENTIVES CONCESSIONS ARE
WAIVERS ARE REDUCTIONS IN
DEVELOPMENT STANDARDS WHETHER
THE APPLICANT PROVIDE ADEQUATE
INFORMATION TO MAKE A
DETERMINATION.
SHOULD THE PROJECT DRASTICALLY
CHANGE AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY
THREE ALLOWS FLEXIBILITY IS FOR
THE LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES TO
ADJUST THE AMOUNT OF THE DENSITY
BONUS THE PARKING RATIOS WAIVERS
AGAIN SOFT CONCESSIONS DEEMED
ELIGIBLE. BASED ON THOSE CHANGES
DURING THE COURSE OF THE
DEVELOPMENT.
THIS BILL BUILDS ON RICHARD
BLOOM SPILL AB TWENTY FIVE OH
ONE WHICH REQUIRES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO NOTIFY A DENSITY
BONUS APPLICANT IF THEIR
APPLICATION IS COMPLETE WITHIN
THIRTY DAYS. THIS BILL ALLOWS
FOR CERTAINTY FOR THE DEVELOPER
AND FLEXIBILITY FOR THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WHEN PROCESSING THE
APPLICATIONS.
THE BILL ALSO DECLARES A
LEGISLATURE'S INTENT BY
ESTABLISHING A UNIFORM PROCESS
FOR THE REVIEW OF DENSITY BONUS
APPLICATIONS. INCLUDING THE
REQUEST FOR AN SENATE'S
CONCESSIONS WAIVERS ON
REDUCTIONS OF DEVELOPMENT
STANDARDS IN A MATTER OF
STATEWIDE CONCERN AND APPLIES TO
ALL CITIES INCLUDING CHARTER
CITIES.
THE LEGISLATURE HAS DECIDED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AS A PRIORITY
AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY THREE
GIVES DEVELOPERS THE CERTAINTY
INSURANCE.
ABOUT INCENTIVE TO DO THAT THIS
BILL HAS NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION WITH ME TODAY I HAVE
MICHAEL CUSUMANO A LOCAL
DEVELOPMENT IN MY DISTRICT IN
BURBANK. TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MICHAEL
CUSUMANO.
AS WE ALL KNOW OUR STATE IS IN A
HOUSING CRISIS AND WE ARE
ESPECIALLY DEFICIENT IN THE
AVAILABILITY OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN OUR STATE.
THIS IS NOT NEWS HERE IN
SACRAMENTO.
IN RESPONSE TO THE CRISIS YOU'VE
ENACTED LAWS OVER THE PAST YEARS
IN THE PAST DECADE SUCH AS THE
DENSITY BONUS LAW. THE PROVIDE A
PATHWAY FOR THE DEVELOPMENT
COMMUNITY TO CREATE MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AT NO
ADDITIONAL COST THE PUBLIC.
MANY CITIES HOWEVER ESPECIALLY
THOSE CITIES THAT HAVE NOT MET
THEIR HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
OBLIGATIONS
FREQUENTLY DELAY OR SIMPLY TO
RIFF REFUSED TO PROCESS. HOUSING
PROJECTS.
BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT YOU
HOUSING BUILT IN THEIR CITIES
AND THEY CERTAINLY DON'T WANT
SACRAMENTO DICTATING TO THEM.
THAT THEY MUST ALLOW FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
TAKE THE CITY OF BURBANK FOR
EXAMPLE.
THE CITY OF BURBANK IS ADDED
OVER THIRTEEN THOUSAND NEW JOBS
OVER THE PAST FIVE YEARS.
BUT ONLY FIFTY FIVE UNITS OF NEW
HOUSING.
THIS RESULT HAS RESULTED IN AN
ACUTE HOUSING CRISIS IN THAT
CITY.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS
CREATED LAW SPECIFICALLY TO
ALLOW FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF
HOUSING PROJECTS THE PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
COMMUNITIES LIKE BURBANK. THAT
FALL SHORT OF MEETING THE
REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ASSESSMENT ALLOCATIONS.
BUT CURRENT LAW DOES NOT PROVIDE
FOR DEFIED SUBMISSION
REQUIREMENTS OR TIME FRAMES. FOR
CITIES TO PROCESSES
APPLICATIONS.
IN REAL ESTATE DEVELOPMENT THE
EASIEST WAY TO STOP A PROJECT IS
NOT TO DENY IT.
BUT JUST TO DO DELAY IT UNTIL IT
DIES ON ITS OWN.
AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY THREE WILL
PROVIDE FOR SPECIFIC GUIDELINES
IN A REASONABLE TIME FRAMES FOR
CITIES TO REVIEW DENSITY BONUS
APPLICATIONS. NOTE THAT THIS
BILL ONLY APPLIES TO PROJECT
BEING SUBMITTED AS DENSITY BONUS
APPLICATIONS WHICH QUALIFY UNDER
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
GUIDELINES IT DOES NOT APPLY TO
YOU LUXURY HOUSING PROJECTS OR
OFFICE BUILDING PROJECTS OR
OTHER PROJECTS THAT DON'T HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT COMPONENT OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WITHIN THEM.
IN ALL OF THESE DENSITY PRIZE OF
DENSITY BONUS PROJECTS
OF REMAIN SUBJECT TO FULL
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW UNDER
SEAQUEST.
IF THE LEGISLATURE IS SERIOUS
ABOUT HAVING A POSITIVE IMPACT
ON THE HOUSING A BALANCE THAT IS
EVIDENT IN OUR STATE.
IT MUST TAKE FURTHER ACTION TO
PROVIDE THE MEANS FOR PRINT THE
PRIVATE SECTOR.
PLAYED A ROLE IN CREATING A
SOLUTION AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY
THREE IS AN IMPORTANT STEP IN
THAT DIRECTION. THANK YOU.
THE KILLERS GOT OTHER
SUPPORTERS.
CITY GEORGE REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION.
ASSESSMENT STEPPED.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF AND WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT.
AS AMENDED WERE NOW IN FULL
SUPPORT.
SO WE JUST WENT EXPRESS THAT
THINKS.
THANK YOU NEXT.
PORTER SHAWN TO PICK IT UP WE
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
REBECCA MARKETS REPRESENTING
LEADING H. CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
AARON CAREER ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
OTHER SUPPORTERS.
ANY OPPOSITION.
CASEY NOW LET'S BRING THIS.
OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SYLVIA
SO LEASE SHAUN BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SANTA MONICA APOLOGIES
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN FOR
THE LATE. AND OPPOSITION ARE THE
SPELL WE JUST TOOK A POSITION
YESTERDAY EYES SO I APOLOGIZE
I'M THE CITY HAS ANALYZE THE
BILL MAY DETERMINE THAT THE BILL
PLACES OWNER ES ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDENS ON CITIES TO COMPILE
THIS INFORMATION FOR EACH
DENSITY BONUS PROJECT. THE CITY
IS DEFINITELY IN SUPPORT OF
THESE TYPES OF PROJECTS SO WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN ON.
CLARIFYING SOME OF THE LANGUAGE
IN THE BILL.
OUR OTHER CONCERN IS FISCAL
THAT THE SKIN AT ADDED COST TO
THE PROPER AND TO THIS REVIEW
AND IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT'S
GOING TO BE REIMBURSED BY THE
STATE SO THAT'S ANOTHER ISSUE
WE'D LIKE TO ADDRESS BUT. AM
THOSE ARE CONCERNS THINKING.
ANY OTHER OPPOSITION.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE I
WAS ABOUT TO COMPLEMENT YOU FOR
MOVING FOR THE DENSITY BONUS
BILL THAT WE WERE ABLE TO AVOID
OPPOSITION ON BUT THIS IS A
DENSELY MONA'S BILL.
BUT.
BUT YOU'VE DONE A LOT OF HARD
WORK TO ADDRESS ISSUES AND I
KNOW THAT YOU TOOK AMENDMENTS
EARLIER IN THE PROCESS THAT DID
REMOVE. THE OPPOSITION AT THE
TIME.
I AND I DO HAVE A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION TO THE NEXT
COMMITTEE BUT. LET ME SEE IF
THERE'S ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
BY THE COMMITTEE.
CA NINETY OF ANY FINAL COMMENTS
YOU LIKE TO MAKE JUST THIS IS
WHAT A REAL ISSUE MY COMMUNITY
WE HAVE DEVELOPERS WHO WANT TO
COME INTO THESE PROJECTS AND WE
DO DESPERATELY NEEDED AND IN THE
COMMUNITY. AND THEN TO SEE THE
PROJECTS TO STALLED INTO
OBLIVION IS BEEN VERY VERY
FRUSTRATING AND I WAS VERY HAPPY
THAT.
THE LOCAL DEVELOPMENT COMMUNITY
AND MR BECAUSE SOMEONE ELSE WAS
WILLING TO WORK WITH ME ON THIS
AND I AGAIN THANK YOU AND I URGE
MY VOTE.
RIGHT IS OUR MOTION TO MOVE THIS
FORWARD.
MOTION BY DOCTOR WOULD SECOND BY
MISTER GLORIA. MADAM SECRETARY.
MOTION TO PASS AND REFERRED TO
THE COMEDIAN LOCAL GOVERNMENT
CHU. CHU AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE CHILD.
CHOI. GLORIA. GLORIA AYE LEE
MONTH. WOULD.
WOULD I.
YOUR BILLS OUT WE WILL ADD ON.
OTHERS HANDLED ONE WE NOW GO TO
FILE ITEM THREE AB TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY THREE I JUST REITERATE
THIS IS FOR DISCUSSION ONLY.
MISTREATMENT.
THANK YOU.
.
THIS BILL IS SOMETHING THAT I
FIND EXTREMELY INTRIGUING AND
WANTED TO BRING IT TO YOU AND.
TODAY BECAUSE I'M GOING TO
PURSUE IN THE FUTURE WE FEEL
THAT WE DO NEED WORK ON IT.
I WANT TO THANK MISTER CHAIR
AND HIS COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
HIS STAFF FOR HELPING US I GET
THIS FAR WITH THE BILL.
THE IDEA BEHIND THIS BILL IS TO
TRY TO BRING MUCH NEEDED HOUSING
INTO OUR URBAN AREAS AND TO EAT
THE TO ENCOURAGE VERTICAL HEIGHT
AS A WAY OF NOT ONLY ADDING MORE
UNITS BUT A PERVERT PRESERVING
OPEN SPACE. AND BE MORE
EFFICIENT AND HOW WE BUILD
BECAUSE OF THE ECONOMICS OF
BUILDING LARGER BUILDINGS THAT
REQUIRE STEEL FRAME THESE
BUILDINGS HAVE BEEN ARE REAL
RARITY IN THE AREAS WHERE WE
NEED THE MOST HOUSING. I'LL GIVE
YOU AN EXAMPLE OF MY OWN HOME
CITY OF GLENDALE WHERE WE DID A
PROGRAMMATIC  I OUR FOR OUR
DOWNTOWN TO REALLY TRY TO
ENCOURAGE HOUSING. AND WE GOT
SEVERAL APARTMENT BUILDINGS IN
PROBABLY EIGHT OR NINE BUILDINGS
AND EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THOSE
BUILDINGS. EVEN THOUGH THAT THE
LOTS WERE ZONED FOR TWENTY
STORIES.
ALL OF THOSE BUILDINGS ARE UNDER
SIX STORIES BECAUSE OF THE
ECONOMICS OF BUILDING THOSE
LARGER BUILDINGS WHICH IN MY
MIND WAS A REAL MISSED
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE NOT ONLY
MORE HOUSING AND MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BUT LARGER UNITS FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE MOVING IN
BECAUSE TO MAKE THOSE PRO.
FORMAS WORK ON THE SHORTER
BUILDINGS THEY REALLY HAVE TO
CRAM THE UNITS AND AND THEY END
UP WITH VERY SMALL UNITS WHICH
AFFECTS BUT RESIDENTS QUALITY OF
LIFE. AND WHAT WE END UP WITH
LESS BE ABLE TO HOUSE LESS
PEOPLE IN A COMMUNITY WHERE WE
HAVE ALMOST A HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE A DAY. DRIVING INTO THAT
VERY AREA TO WORK SO WE HAVE THE
GOAL IN THE STATE OF HAVING MORE
DANCE HOUSING NEAR OUR JOB
CENTERS AND THE PLACES HERE
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO A
RECREATION.
AND YET WE HAVE THIS ECONOMIC
HURDLE THAT IS VERY DIFFICULT
FOR DEVELOPERS TO OVERCOME TO
FULLY UTILIZE THE LAND THAT'S
THERE IN THOSE AREAS. SO OUR
SPONSOR BROUGHT A VERY
INTERESTING CONCEPT FOR THAT I'D
LIKE HIM TO A TO TALK ABOUT AND
I'LL TELL YOU WHY. WE FEEL THAT
WE NEED TO WORK ON THIS BILL
WHEN WHEN HE'S FINISHED.
BUT HIS FAMILY MEMBER AYE IT
THANK YOU I CHAIR CHAIRMAN CHIU.
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS MIKE KING
CELL
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF UP FOR
GROWTH CALIFORNIA THE FIRST
STATE PROJECT OF THE UP FOR
GROWTH NATIONAL COALITION. UP
FOR GROWTH IS A DIVERSE AND
GROWING COALITION OF HOUSING
PRODUCERS MAJOR EMPLOYERS AND
OTHER PUBLIC INTEREST GROUPS
HAVE JOINED TOGETHER TO PROMOTE
POLICIES THAT ENCOURAGE AND
ENABLE MORE HOUSING ACCESS AND
AFFORDABILITY. ACCESSIBLE TO
JOBS IN TRANSPORTATIONS HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AS PROPOSED BY AB TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY THREE THE VERTICAL HOUSING
PROGRAM IS AN EXAMPLE OF A
PROVEN STRATEGY LAUDED BY ON THE
OBAMA WHITE HOUSE AND IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN AND AND
MANY OTHER ORGANIZATIONS AND IS
USED ACTUALLY IN TWELVE STATES
AROUND THE U. S.. TO REDUCE AND
INNATE BARRIERS AND ENABLE DENSE
WALKABLE HOUSING PRODUCTION NEAR
TRANSIT.
BY INDUCING INVESTMENTS TO
CREATE PROJECTS THAT MAXIMIZE
SEVEN CAPACITY NEAR TRANSIT
STATIONS THE VERTICAL HOUSING
PROGRAM PROVIDES THE MISSING
FINANCING TO PRODUCE SCORES OF
AFFORDABLE AND MARKET RATE
UNITS.
WITHIN  GIVEN PROJECT THAT
WOULD NOT OTHERWISE BE BUILT
WITHOUT THIS TOOL WHILE BRINGING
AT THE SAME TIME THE PER UNIT
COST DOWN SIGNIFICANTLY AND AT
LEAST DOUBLING THE VALUE OF THE
PROPERTY AYE IN UNDERLYING TAX
BASIS COMPARED TO SIMILAR.
SIMILAR DEVELOPMENT.
THERE WOULD BE THAT WOULD BE
PRODUCED UNDER THE STATUS QUO.
THIS PROVISION RIVER REFLECTS
BOTH A HIGHER LEVEL OF
AFFORDABLE UNITS SET ASIDE
WITHIN A GIVEN PROJECT.
THAN WOULD OTHERWISE BE
GENERATED AND DEEPER LEVEL OF
AFFORDABILITY THAT IS REQUIRED
UNDER CALIFORNIA'S STATEWIDE
DENSITY BONUS LAW AND THE BILL
WOULD PRODUCE AFFORDABLE UNITS
AT AROUND HALF OF THE COST OF
WHAT THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS COULD
DEVELOP ON THEIR OWN.
THE PROGRAM PAYS FOR THE COST OF
THE INCREASED DENSITY IS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MENTIONED IN
DOES NOT ACCRUE TO DEVELOPER
PROFIT.
ALLOW ME TO EXPLAIN A HIGHER
DENSITY PROJECT COSTS ROUGHLY
THIRTY PERCENT MORE PER SQUARE
FOOT ON AVERAGE.
THEN TO BUILD A LOWER DENSITY I
HOUSING PROJECT YET RENTS IN
MANY PLACES EVEN AROUND TRANSIT
ARE NOT THIRTY PERCENT HIGHER.
TO PROVIDE FOR THAT DENSER
PROJECT TO MAKE.
FINANCIAL.
SENSE
ESPECIALLY WHEN AFFORDABLE UNITS
ARE CONTEMPLATED AS PART OF THE
PROJECT
IN OTHER WORDS IS FAR MORE
ECONOMICALLY RATIONAL TO BUILD
LOW DENSITY PROJECTS RATHER THAN
HIGH DENSITY PROJECTS. NOW WHICH
ULTIMATELY COST LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS MUCH NEEDED OUR
PROPERTY TAX REVENUE.
CONTACT DEVELOPMENT HOUSING
UNITS IN FOR GOES THE PROP
POSSIBILITY OF DEVELOPMENT OF
AFFORDABLE UNITS ALTOGETHER.
IN FACT RIGHT NOW IN CALIFORNIA
WITHIN IN MANY AREAS AROUND THE
STATE. WITHIN A HALF MILE RING
AROUND TRANSIT WHO DID THAT THE
PRODUCERS OF MID RISE LOWER
DENSITY APARTMENT BUILDINGS ARE
ABLE TO PAY MORE FOR LAND AND.
THEN THE DEVELOPERS OF HIGH RISE
MORE UNIT.
LARGER APARTMENT BUILDINGS.
IT'S OF THIS THIS VEHICLE THIS
TOOL PROVIDES A WAY FOR HIGH
DENSITY PROJECTS TO PENCIL OUT.
I LIKELY PROVIDING THE SAME
RETURNS TO THE HOUSING PRODUCER
AS WITH THE LESS EXPENSIVE LOWER
DENSITY PROJECT THAT DOESN'T
OFFER THE SAME PUBLIC BENEFITS
AS THIS INCREASED DENSITY WOULD.
ESSENTIALLY THIS VEHICLE BRIDGES
THE DELTA IN CREATES AN ECONOMIC
RATIONALE FOR DEVELOPERS TO
BUILD A HIGH DENSITY WALKABLE
PROJECT TO REALIZE THE FULL
SUITE. OF PUBLIC BENEFITS
INCLUDING IN ADDITION TO THE
QUANTITY QUALITY AND
AFFORDABILITY BENEFITS ARE
CREATING ADDITIONAL AYE JOB
CREATION AND EMPLOYMENT INCOME.
CAUSING DRAMATIC REDUCTIONS IN
VEHICLE TAILPIPE EMISSIONS
BECAUSE THE PROJECTS WOULD BE
LOCATED NEAR TRANSIT STATIONS
AND SERVING INCOMING POPULATIONS
THROUGH ACCOMMODATE OF WHAT WE
CALL IN PLACEMENT RATHER THAN
THE DISRUPTIVE DISPLACEMENT. OF
EXISTING POPULATIONS AND ON THAT
LAST POINT THIS LEGISLATION ALSO
INCORPORATES IDENTICAL
DISPLACEMENT LANGUAGE FROM LAST
YEAR'S S. B. THIRTY FIVE BARRING
DISPLACEMENT THROUGH DEMOLITION
AND REDEVELOPMENT. WOULD ALSO
HELP IMPROVE I INVESTMENT IN
ECONOMICALLY DIVESTED
COMMUNITIES.
THIS PROGRAM WOULD MAKE
INCLUSIONARY HOUSING POLICIES
MORE WORKABLE ACROSS THE STATE
MANDATES UNTETHERED FROM
ECONOMIC REALITY REQUIRING THE
PRODUCTION OF A CERTAIN KIND OF
HOUSING QUICKLY BECOME JUST
ANOTHER BARRIER. TO PRODUCING
ANY KIND OF HOUSING AT ALL.
THE VERTICAL HOUSING PROGRAM
PROVIDES OF A VIABLE FINANCING
MODEL TO ACTUALLY PRODUCE ENABLE
MORE UNITS THROUGH INCLUSIONARY
HOUSING POLICIES THAT THAT THAT
THOSE POLICIES WOULD OTHERWISE
SEEK TO MANDATE.
INTO REALITY AND FINALLY THE
PROGRAM IS THE MOST EFFICIENT
USE OF RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO ACHIEVE
AFFORDABILITY GOALS AND
ACCOMPLISHES WHAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WOULD TYPICALLY
REQUIRE. DOUBLE THE CAPITAL TO
ACHIEVE EITHER BY DELIVERING
PROJECTS THEMSELVES WERE BY
BUYING DOWN RENTS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
APPRECIATE THE TIME.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ANYMORE
REPRESENTING BRIDGE HOUSING A
BRIDGE HOUSING IS A NONPROFIT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPER I
THAT DOES THAT ACTUALLY THAT
MOST OF THE LARC. MANY OF THE
LARGEST AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
PROJECTS IN THE STATE PRIMARILY
INFILL AND IN URBAN AREAS.
WE APPRECIATE.
YET THE OFF THAT WE SUPPORT THE
BILL WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
BRINGING THE CONVERSATION
FORWARD ABOUT HAVING ANOTHER
TOOL IN THE TOOL KIT.
POST REDEVELOPMENT.
HAVING HOUSING INCREMENTS
FINANCE AYE IS AN IMPORTANT.
MECHANISM FOR BRINGING LARGE
PROJECTS FORWARD. ARE AND WE
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSIONS
MOVING FORWARD THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
CORNELIUS BURKE WITH THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL.
WE SUPPORT THE BILL WE THINK
THE AUTHOR FOR LEADERSHIP THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AS WELL. ON THIS BILL
INCREASES HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES.
PROVIDES ELEGANT DENSITY AND
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
LOOK FOR TO WORKING ON THIS BILL
IN THE FUTURE.
LIMITS OF THEIR OTHER SUPPORTERS
OF THE BILL AS IT IS AGAIN THIS
IS FOR DISCUSSION PURPOSES ONLY.
SHOT OF TAKING WITH CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING JUSTIN FANS ALL BE
HAVE A TECHNET IN SUPPORT.
LOUIS Y. DIFFERENT CALIFORNIAN
BE IN SUPPORT.
AND LET ME ASK IS THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AS IT IS
.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOOD
MORNING DAVID WOLFE THE HOWARD
JARVIS TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION AND
OBVIOUSLY UNDERSTANDING THIS IS
FOR DISCUSSION ONLY.
MEMBERS WERE I THINK REALLY
INTRIGUED BY THE CONCEPT OF
VERTICAL HOUSING. WITH OIL AND
GROWING IN EXPENSIVE AND DOWN
THE STATE.
EXPLORING VERTICAL HOUSING
ESPECIALLY IN HIGH TRANSIT AREAS
I THINK MAKES A HIGH DEGREE OF
SENSE.
HOWEVER WORK CONCERNED WITH THIS
SPELL AS YOU'VE BEEN CONCERNED
WITH OTHER BILLS REGARDING
BRINGING BACK SOME FORM OR
ANOTHER OF REDEVELOPMENT.
REGARDING THE TWO THIRDS VOTER
APPROVAL THRESHOLD.
IN ORDER TO ENGAGE IN EITHER
TAX INCREMENT FINANCING OR
APPROVING BONDS AGAIN THIS IS
NOT A FOREIGN POSITION FOR US WE
TESTIFIED HERE LAST WEEK AGAINST
AB THIRTY THIRTY SEVEN AS WELL.
ON THAT FRONT.
I THINK ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU'RE
DEALING WITH TAX INCREMENT
FINANCING AND MONEY BEING TAKEN
FROM CITIES AND COUNTIES
AND SPECIAL DISTRICTS IN BEING
DIVERTED FOR SOME OTHER CAUSE.
HAVING THAT VOTER APPROVAL WHICH
LASTS FAR BEYOND.
THE DEBT THAT WAS APPROVED
EITHER BY THE CITY COUNCIL AND
THE OTHER LOCAL ENTITY. AND NOT
JUST MAKES AUDIT SENDS SPECIAL
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT PROJECTS
THAT COULD LAST THIRTY TO FORTY
YEARS LONG AFTER THIS GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS ARE OUT OFF OUT OF
OFFICE.
IN ADDITION MEMBERS IT'S WORTHY
TO NOTE HERE TO THAT AB TWENTY
FIVE FIFTY THREE ALSO INCLUDES
AN ELEMENT OF INCLUSIONARY
ZONING.
WHERE BEFORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND YOU DEVELOPMENT NEEDS TO BE
SUBSIDIZED BY THE BUILDER? IT'S
WORTH NOTING THAT A RECENT STUDY
ON INCLUSIONARY ZONING SHOWED
THAT ONLY ELEVEN HUNDRED UNITS
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING WERE
PRODUCED OVER THIRTY FIVE YEAR
PERIOD. AND AT THAT RATE IT
WOULD TAKE AT LEAST A HUNDRED
YEARS TO GENERATE SUFFICIENT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND WE WERE
JUST ARGUE THAT.
WE LISTEN WE DO NEED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WE NEED TO BE BUILDING A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY THOUSAND
UNITS OF NEW HOUSING YEAR WERE
ONLY BUILDING HALF THAT. AGAIN
THIS PROPOSAL IS INTRIGUING BUT
INCLUDING AN INCLUSIONARY ZONING
PIECE JUST DOESN'T SEEM LIKE THE
BEST WAY TO ACCOMPLISH THAT.
THANKS.
ANY OTHER OPPOSITION.
IT'S GOING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY COMMENTS.
I WILL FIRST THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING FORTH THE BIG IDEA.
THAT IS WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING
AT THIS TIME DURING THE WORST
HOUSING CRISIS IN OUR STATE'S
HISTORY. I THINK THIS IS A VERY
INTRIGUING IDEA IT'S A NEW IDEA
FOR FOR MANY OF US.
AND I'LL JUST SAY CASE FOLKS
ARE WONDERING OF THE AUTHOR
KNIGHT HAD GOOD CONVERSATIONS
AND HAD AGREED IN CONCEPT ON A
NUMBER OF. POTENTIAL AMENDMENTS
BUT GIVEN THAT THIS BILL WOULD
OF HAD TO THREAD NOT JUSTICE
COMMITTEE BUT ALSO COMMITTEE
STARTING AT ONE THIRTY THIS
AFTERNOON WITH. AMENDMENTS THAT.
WOULD HAVE HAD MORE STAFF.
WORKING THROUGH THE NIGHT AND
LIKELY UNABLE TO PULL TOGETHER
BY THEN.
I THINK WE DECIDED TO START THE
CONVERSATION ARE AND HOPEFULLY
CONTINUE THIS YEAR TO
POTENTIALLY.
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION NEXT
YEAR WITH THE AUTHOR ALDOUS LAY
OUT A COUPLE OF ISSUES THAT WERE
LAID OUT IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS AND. SINCE IS THE FIRST
TIME I'VE HAD TO ENGAGE WITH THE
SPONSOR.
NO I THINK FIRST OF WE ARE VERY
SCARCE.
PUBLIC DOLLARS TO INVEST IN
HOUSING.
AND.
I THINK THE IDEA THAT SOME OF
THESE DOLLARS MIGHT GO TO
SUPPORT MARKET RATE HOUSING IT'S
INTRIGUING BUT VERY MUCH A NEW
CONCEPT.
GIVEN HOW FEW DOLLARS WE HAVE
THAT WE WOULD DEVOTE TO A
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SO THAT IS AN
ISSUE THAT.
THE AUTHOR AND I HAD DISCUSSED.
.
SECONDLY THE THIRTY FIVE YEAR
SUBSIDY HOW THAT.
AND THE FACT THAT WE WOULD
POTENTIALLY BE DOING THIS FOR
THREE AND A HALF DECADES WAS
ALSO A DIFFERENT ISSUE RELATED
TO THAT TEN. OF LOVE TO GET SOME
UNDERSTANDING OF THAT AND THEN
THIRDLY.
THERE ARE PARTS OF THE STATE
WHERE THE SUBSIDIES WOULDN'T BE
NECESSARY I WOULD SUGGEST THAT
DOWNTOWN SAN FRANCISCO DOWNTOWN
LA DOWNTOWN SAN DIEGO. ARE
OAKLAND SAN JOSE YOU WOULDN'T
NEED THE SUBSIDIES
AND AND THERE WASN'T ANYTHING IN
THE BILL AS DRAFTED THAT CREATED
THAT DISTINCTION SO.
UNDERSTANDING OF WHEN YOU WOULD
WANT TO AND SENT HOUSING.
CREATION THAT OTHERWISE WOULDN'T
BE INCENTIVE
FIGURED OUT THAT FINE BALANCES.
IS A CONCEPT I THINK WE NEED TO
TO WRAP AROUND SO IF YOU HAVE
ANY INITIAL THOUGHTS ON THAT
LOVE THEM BUT OTHERWISE. OUTLOOK
FOR TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION.
ON THIS INNOVATIVE IDEA.
ABSOLUTELY.
AND AND ACTUALLY IF YOU HAVE ANY
THOUGHTS ON THAT RIGHT NOW
THOUGH AS WE GO MISTER CLARE.
I JUST WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
MISTER CHAIRMAN I YOU KNOW I
RECOGNIZE ROB VOTING ON THIS
TODAY THIS IS A CONCEPT I THAT I
HEARD SOMETHING ABOUT AND I I
JUST WANNA OFFER ENCOURAGEMENT
ON THIS. IT WE HAVE SUCH A
PROBLEM SUCH A MASSIVE SCALE AS
MY COLLEAGUE POINT OUT HER
COMMENTS A REQUIRE SOME
ADDITIONAL EFFORTS SINCE NEW
TOOLS ITS NEW EFFORTS. WERE
PARTNERING ON AN EFFORT TO TRY
AND OF EXAMINED OF REDEVELOPMENT
AND AND PROVIDE ANOTHER TOOL
BUT.
GIVEN THE ENORMITY OF THE
PROBLEM ALONG WITH THE FACT THAT
THIS IS WHAT I'M ASKED ABOUT
MORE THAN ANY OTHER ISSUE IN THE
STATE. I THINK IT'S INCUMBENT
UPON US TO TRY BUT FOR ITS NEW
SOLUTIONS AGAIN ONE LIKE OUR
CHAIRMAN COMMEND YOU FOR
THINKING BIG AND TRY TO BRING US
SOME DOES SOMETHING TO REACT TO.
I'M SORRY WE CAN'T MISS A TAKE
ACTION TODAY.
BUT I'M HOPEFUL THIS IS SORT OF
FLUSH OUR DISCUSSION I THINK THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONING. OUR THE
COMMENTS IN THE IN THE ANALYSIS
OR ARE ON POINT.
ENCOURAGE YOU CAN HE LOOK AT
THAT AND HOPEFULLY RETURN.
IN THE NOT TOO DISTANT FUTURE A
WAS A NEW POTENTIALLY COULD VOTE
ON SUGGESTS AT GAMEWORKS
ENCOURAGEMENT WITH APPRECIATION
OF THE AUTHOR.
MR VENTURE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN JUST
TO ECHO A MUCH MORE A LITTLE BIT
FOR STUFF THANKS FOR THEM THE
WAY YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT IT ON
WHAT I'M INTRIGUED BY AND IN
ADDITION TO THE OTHER. COMMENTS
HAVE BEEN MADE IS YOU'RE YOU'RE
ACTUALLY CONCERNING THE QUALITY
OF THE UNITS TO WHEN I WAS THAT
WAS GOOD TO HEAR THAT. WOULD
TIGHTEN THAT TECHNO BUILDING
MORE BUT I I LIKE WHAT YOU SAID
ABOUT INSTEAD OF BECAUSE WE'RE
BILLING SHORTER WE'RE BUILDING
THE SMALLER CRAMMING PEOPLE IN
THERE. YOU'RE GIVING THOUGHT TO
ACTUALLY THE QUALITY OF WHAT'S
BEEN CREATED TO SO I AM I DON'T
THINK WE WANT THESE YOU KNOW
KIND OF STARTING KANSEN IS
PACKING PEOPLE INTO. VERY SMALL
UNITS THAT REALLY AREN'T AS
PLEASANT PLACES TO LIVE.
IF WE ARE GONNA HAVE HIGHER
DENSITY.
THERE'S THERE'S THINGS THAT GO
WITH THAT AND AND I THINK THAT
ALSO S. BECAUSE ON THE OTHER
SIDE TO WRITE WHAT'S
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S IN PLACE
TO SUPPORT THAT. ARM IN WHAT
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO ABOUT
PARKING WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO
ABOUT. THESE OTHER IN A. SEWER
AND WATER HOOKUPS ALL THOSE
THINGS THAT HAVE TO HAPPEN IS
YOU HAVE MORE UNITS IN MORE
IMPACT ON AN AREA IN EVEN IN
AREAS. YOU KNOW LET IT IT IN
OTHER THE CHAIRMAN BROUGHT UP
SAN FRANCISCO LA SAN DIEGO. SORT
OF BIGGER CITIES THAT HAVE MAYBE
LARGER DOWNTOWNS BUT EVEN THERE.
KNOW THERE IS THERE IS EIGHT A
MAXIMUM RIGHT THERE IS A TIPPING
POINT THERE FOR SO CURRENT
INFRASTRUCTURE EVEN IN THOSE
PLACES LET ALONE SMITH'S OCEAN
OUR CITIES BUT I I REALLY WANNA
CREDIT YOU MISS FRIEDMAN I
THINK.
I LIKE TO. DO THAT THAT YOU'RE
TAKING ON SOMETHING THAT'S BIG
BUT SECONDLY.
THAT WAS JUST KIND OF UNIQUE TAG
HERE AND A NUMBER OF THESE
HOUSING. ITEMS WE HERE WE DON'T
AND HER TALK ABOUT WHAT THE
ACTUAL QUALITY OF THE UNIT ISN'T
SO HATS OFF TO YOU FOR DOING
THAT. THANKS.
YEAH I MEAN I IF YOU DON'T MIND
AUTISTIC ONE SECOND HER TO
RECYCLING HOUSE WHEN ISN'T TURN
IT OVER TO YOU HOWEVER YOU WANT
TO RESPOND SO I FEEL LIKE WE
HAVE A AND FIRST OF ALL I
REPRESENT ONE OF THE GROUND
ZEROES OF THE HOUSING CRISIS
BEING LOS. ANGELES.
AND THE IMMEDIATE NEIGHBORHOODS
ARE AROUND IT. AND SEE EVERY
SINGLE DAY THE IMPACT OF NOT
JUST WHAT'S HAPPENED WHEN CITIES
REFUSE TO BUILD BUT ALSO THE
RESULT OF MANY YEARS OF POLICIES
BUT THE LOCAL ON THE STATE LEVEL
AND WHAT THEY RESULT IN THE TYPE
OF HOUSING THE RESULTS IN AND.
SO IN A LOT OF WAYS I FEEL LIKE
WE'VE GONE BACKWARDS WHAT WE
REALLY SHOULD BE DOING IS
LOOKING AT WHAT WE WANT WE WANT
LARGER. TALLER INFILL NEAR
TRANSIT IN NEAR JOBS AND A LOT
OF THESE COMMUNITIES SO HOW DO
WE GET THERE AND THIS BILL IS
DESIGNED TO ACTUALLY GET US THAT
TYPE OF HOUSING AS OPPOSED TO
PUTTING IN. A BUNCH OF
STIPULATIONS AND JUST SEEING
WHAT WE GET I THINK WE NEED TO
WORK FROM OUTSIDE AND WORK
BACKWARDS AND TO YOUR QUESTION
IS HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THESE ARE
IN THE AREAS WE WANT THEM. I
THINK THAT WE DO THE SAME THING
WE ASK OUR MUNICIPALITIES AND WE
CAN YOU KNOW TALK ABOUT HOW TO
DO THIS IN THE BILL BUT WE ASK
MUNICIPALITIES WHO WANT TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THIS. TO IDENTIFY
THOSE AREAS THAT COULD BOOST
BENEFIT FOR THIS TYPE OF GROWTH
LET THE PLANNERS DO THEIR WORK
WHERE THEY REALLY TRYING TO
ENCOURAGE THIS AND WHERE IS THE
MARKET UNABLE TO PROVIDE THAT
HOUSING BEAT BECAUSE OF. THE THE
REALITIES OF THE AREA THE
FINANCING THE TYPE OF AREA THAT
IT CURRENTLY IS SO THAT THEY CAN
ENVISIONED A DIFFERENT FUTURE
FOR THOSE TRANSIT HEAVY BUT
HOUSING POOR AREAS AND IDENTIFY
THOSE AND LET THIS WORK IN THOSE
AREAS. BUT EXCLUDING AREAS WHERE
THE MARKET HAS SHOWN THAT IT'S
ALREADY ABLE TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN
AND AT WHATEVER POINT WHERE THE
MARKET TAKES OVER AND BECAUSE
NOW YOU'VE CREATED A NEW
NEIGHBORHOOD THAT'S DESIRABLE
WITH THESE PROJECTS. YOU CAN
PULL THE PROJECT BACK AND LET
THE FREE MARKET TAKE EFFECT BUT
THERE'S A LOT OF TECHNICAL WORK
THAT'S GOING TO NEED TO GO INTO
THIS BETWEEN NOW AND WHEN.
YOU'RE ALL COMFORTABLE IN VOTING
ON A TO MAKE EVERYBODY
COMFORTABLE HAT THIS ARE
PROJECTS THAT COULDN'T HAVE
HAPPENED WITHOUT THIS KIND OF
HELP THAT THERE ARE AREAS WHERE
IT'SNECESSARY WERE. WHERE THE
COMMUNITIES HAVE THE VISION TO
WANT TO CREATE THIS TYPE OF
HOUSING AND TO CREATE THOSE
WALKABLE BIKE
ALL NEIGHBORHOODS WHERE PEOPLE
CAN? ALREADY HAVE THE TRANSIT
ALREADY HAVE THE JOBS BUT I'M
VERY VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT THIS
CONCEPT THIS IS A TOOL THAT I
CAN IDENTIFY MANY AREAS IN MY
DISTRICT IN ADJACENT TO MY
DISTRICT. WHERE THIS IF THIS
WERE IN PLACE WE COULD START
CREATING HOUSING YOU KNOW ALMOST
IMMEDIATELY SO I'M PASSIONATE
NIGHT I PROMISE YOU'LL BE SEEING
THIS BILL AGAIN IN THE NEAR
FUTURE?
BUT I THINK THANK YOU AND AND
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
AGAIN FOR ON BEHALF OF UP FOR
GROW THINGS OFF HER FOR HER
LEADERSHIP IN AND THINK THE
CHAIR.
VERY VERY MUCH FOR YOUR FOR
YOUR INSIGHT AND INTO THE HOUSES
ON THE ON THE BILL WE VERY MUCH
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING THROUGH
A PROCESS OVER THE COMING
MONTHS.
ONTO BETTER FLESH OUT AND REFINE
THE BILL RE IN IN REACTION I TO
THE ANALYSIS.
IN SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSING THIS
NOTION OF CREATING THE GUARD THE
APPROPRIATE GUARD RAILS TO THAT
THIS TOOL CAN BE FOCUSED ON THE
AREAS THAT REALLY NEED THE
BENEFIT OF THIS TOOLS THAT WE DO
NOT HAVE. PARCELS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA HIGH OPPORTUNITY
AREAS THAT ARE SUB OPTIMIZED
THAT HAVE FEWER UNITS THAT ARE
POSSIBLE AND IN AND GENERATE
SUBOPTIMAL OUTCOMES FROM THAT
STANDPOINT SO PRE APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION. AND THE FEEDBACK WE
WILL LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU ALL.
IN THE COMING MONTHS.
GREAT THANK YOU AND AGAIN THANKS
TO ALL OF YOU FOR FOR FOR MOVING
FOR BIG IDEAS THIS IS WHAT WE
NEED RIGHT NOW DURING THIS
CRISIS AND LOOK FOR TO WORKING
WITH YOU TO TO REFINE THIS IN
THE COMING MONTHS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANKS
FOR ALL YOUR HELP OF COURSE
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR.
.
MR GRAY.
IF THAT'S OKAY NOT APPRECIATE
YOUR PATIENCE AND MISTER MULLINS
INDULGENCE I THINK YOU'VE GOT A
QUICK.
NOT CONTROVERSIAL ITEM I HOPE.
MR GRAY.
THANK YOU ARE MUCH AND BY THE
WAY THIS IS FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB
TWENTY NINE SEVEN THREE.
SAME AS CHAIRMAN.
MEMBERS I DO HAVE REAL TO THE
QUICK THOUGH THIS.
IS A FOLLOW UP TO BILL I DIDN'T
WRITE FIFTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR
MONTHS.
EXTENSION AYE ON MAPS IS ONLY
AREAS OF THE STATE THE ABSENCE
OF SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC.
DEPRESSION HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT
RATES HIGH RATES OF POVERTY IN
THE IT'S A SIMPLE CONCEPT OF
ALLOWING WHILE ELIMINATING
ADDITIONAL RED TAPE DELAY IT
CENTER AND COST FOR HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS SPECIFICALLY AIMED
AT ADDRESSING THE SAME HOUSING
CRISIS ROLE SPEAKING OF YOU ALL
KNOW THAT. THE CENTRAL VALLEY
AND OTHER REAL PARTS THE STATE
HAVE HAD THE HOUSING CRISIS KIND
OF PUSHED OUT UPON US FROM THE
URBAN AREAS.
DUE THE LACK OF HOUSING STOCK
IN CALIFORNIA AND THIS IS A
SIMPLE MATER STEP TO HELP.
ALLEVIATE THAT ISSUE OR DO SOME
APART TO BE AT THAT ISSUE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR OF. THANK
YOU ARE THERE ANY.
SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL.
ANY OPPOSITION.
ANY DISCUSSION.
TOM I APPRECIATE YOU COMING FOR
WITH THIS.
AND.
AND I ALSO APPRECIATE THAT
YOU'VE LIMITED THIS JUST TO
THESE MAPS TO THE ELEVEN
COUNTIES I THINK OVER A BIT
BROADER WE PROLLY HAVE A LONGER
DISCUSSION BUT. I THINK WHAT YOU
DID WAS.
WELL TAILORED AND.
WITH THAT THERE'S A MOTION TO
MOVE THE BILL IS OUR SECOND.
ANY FINAL COMMENTS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
MEN SECRETARY.
MOTION TO PASS IN REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
TO BUY CHIU AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE CHAO. SHALL I
CHOI. GLORIA AYE GLORIA AYE
LAMONT. FREMONT I WOULD.
WHAT I THINK THAT WAS THE
QUICKEST PRESENTATION TODAY'S
APPRECIATE THAT FAMOUS SHARED
THANK YOU MISTER GRAY MISTER
MONTAGUE TO MISTER MILLER?
MISTER MULLIN FILE ITEM SIX AB
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY TWO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS.
PRESENTING AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY
TWO.
FEDERAL LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX
CREDITS ARE THE BACKBONE OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FINANCE IN
OUR STATE.
AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY TWO GRANTS
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT AUTHORITY
TO ADJUST THE INTEREST RATE ON
LOANS COUPLED WITH AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS UTILIZING.
FEDERAL LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX
CREDITS WE NEEDED TO MAKE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS
FEASIBLE.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS
UTILIZING THESE TAX CREDITS CAN
BECOME IN FEASIBLE OR AT RISK
WHEN THEY HAVE TOO MUCH INTEREST
ACCRUING ON LOANS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT. AND OTHER PUBLIC
LENDERS
WHEN THESE LOANS ACCRUE MORE
INTERESTING COMMITTEE
ACCOMMODATED IN A PROJECTS
CAPITAL ACCOUNT.
THIS CAN MAKE THE PROJECT IN
FEASIBLE ALTOGETHER.
IN OTHER CASES AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS FACE ADVERSE
THREE THAT ADVERSITY WHEN IT
READS SYNDICATING YES THAT IS A
WORD WE SYNDICATING. A TAX
CREDIT PROPERTY AND MUST
MATERIALLY MODIFY AN EXISTING
BELOW MARKET RATE EACH CD LOAN.
FOR EXAMPLE EXTENDING THE LOAN
BY MORE THAN FIVE YEARS
QUALIFIES AS A MATERIAL
MODIFICATION OF ALONE UNDER IRS
RULES. THIS CHANGES THE TAX
TREATMENT OF THE LOAN IN A WAY.
WHICH THE PROJECTS ACCESS TO
FOUR PERCENT TAX CREDIT EQUITY
IS REDUCED IN THESE CASES S.
ADJUSTMENT IS SUBSTANTIAL AND
JEOPARDIZES THE PROJECT'S
FEASIBILITY.
WHILE H. CITY CURRENTLY HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO REDUCE THE INTEREST
RATE ON SOME LOANS AND TO
INCREASE THE RATE ON CERTAIN
OTHERS THIS BILL WOULD GIVE AGE
CD BROAD AUTHORITY TO INCREASE
OR DECREASE THE INTEREST RATE ON
ANY HCV LOAN WHEN NEEDED. TO
HELP PROJECTS PENCIL OUT.
LOCAL PUBLIC AGENCIES HAVE BEEN
ADJUSTING THEIR INTEREST RATES
IN THE SITUATIONS FOR YEARS. AND
THIS FLEXIBILITY IS NEEDED AT
THE STATE LEVEL AS WELL. I'M
VERY HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES PROPOSED AMENDMENT
NOTED ON PAGE FOUR OF THE
ANALYSIS I HAVE HERE WITH ME TO
EXPLAIN ALL OF THIS.
IS KEVIN KNUTSON HE IS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF COMMUNITY ECONOMICS
AND TOM COLLISHAW PRESIDENT CEO
OF SELF HELP ENTERPRISES TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. AND ANSWER ANY
OF YOUR HIGHLY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS ON WHAT IS A HIGHLY
TECHNICAL BUILT. THANK YOU
MISTER IS SAYING WE SHOULD BE
ASKING YOU THOSE HIGHLY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
BOB I'M SORRY WILL HAD JUST
GIVING UP WITH THAT RIGHT TURN
IT OVER TO SPONSOR MY HEARING
IMPAIRMENT ACTUALLY COMES IN
HANDY ON THESE HIGHLY TECHNICAL
BILLS.
THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU.
YOUR WITNESSES.
HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KEVIN
CONNEXXION AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF COMMUNICANT X. SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX.
HE ECONOMIC HAS PROVIDED
FINANCING TAX CREDIT CONSULTING
SERVICES TO NONPROFIT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS TRACK
CALIFORNIA.
INCLUDING THOSE USING STE HCD
PROGRAMS. THIS BILL IS A VERY
SHORT BILL BUT IT'S IT IS
COMPLEX AND SO IF YOU'LL BEAR
WITH ME FOR JUST A MINUTE. A TRY
TO EXPLAIN SOME OF THESE
UNDERLYING ISSUES.
IN RECENT YEARS WE WORKED VERY
CLOSELY WITH A TD TO CRAFT OTHER
LEGISLATION SIMILAR TO THIS TO
ENABLE A CD.
STAY NIMBLE AND KEEP PACE WITH A
CONSTANTLY EVOLVING WORLD OF TAX
CREDIT FINANCE.
AND TO DO SO IN A WAY THAT
LEVERAGES THE MOST PRIVATE
EQUITY CAPITAL FROM LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDITS.
AND THE MOST CLOSELY ALIGNED
WITH THE STATE'S GOALS FOR
SERVING THE MODERN INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS.
AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY TWO WOULD
ALLOW EACH CD IN ITS FIRST PART.
TO REDUCE THE INTEREST RATE ON
ANY OF ITS LOANS FROM THE
TYPICAL THREE PERCENT SIMPLE
ANNUAL INTERESTS.
EFFORT BUT ACCRUING CHARGE A
MOST HCD LOANS WHY IS THIS
IMPORTANT.
IT CITY LONG PROVIDE FIFTY FIVE
YEAR LOANS AT THREE PERCENT
SIMPLE INTEREST WITH INTEREST
AND PRINCIPAL PAYMENTS DEFERRED
AT THE END OF THE TERM. IN
EXCHANGE FOR RESTRICTIONS WHICH
LIMIT IRAN'S TERROR LEVELS
AFFORDABLE TO LOW AND MODERATE
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
THE CURRENT ANNUAL THREE PERCENT
SIMPLE INTEREST ON THESE LOANS
IS IN THE ANNUAL DEDUCTION. TO
THE OWNERS OF THIS HOUSING
BECAUSE IT'S BEEN ENCOURAGED BY
THE OWNER REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
OR NOT IT'S PAID.
OWNERS OF TAX CREDIT PROPERTIES
MUST FILE WITH THE IRS EVERY
YEAR AS PART OF THEIR TEN SIXTY
FIVE FEDERAL TAX RETURN. AND
ANNUAL ACCOUNTING OF EACH PART
PARTNERS CAPITAL ACCOUNT.
PUT VERY SIMPLY A CAPITAL
ACCOUNT IS AN ANNUAL TALLY. OF
PARTNERS CUMULATIVE EQUITY
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE PROJECT.
REDUCED BY THE CUMULATIVE AMOUNT
OF TAX DEDUCTIONS.
AND OUR CASH FLOW TAKEN FROM THE
PROJECT.
FOR NEARLY ALL LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDIT PROJECTS THE
CAPITAL ACCOUNT STARTS VERY
HIGH.
AS THE TAX CREDIT INVESTOR
LIMITED PARTNER MAKES ITS
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE FIRST YEAR
TO. AND SLOPES DOWNWARD OVER
TIME AS THE PARTNER TAKES
INTEREST DEPRECIATION
DEDUCTIONS.
REMEMBER THAT THE ACCRUING
INTEREST ON EACH CD LOAN IS
INCLUDED IN THE ANNUAL
DEDUCTIONS REDUCES THE CAPITAL
COUNTS.
IN MOST THE PROJECT TO WORK ON
OUR STATE CAPITOL COUNTS ARE NOT
AN OBSTACLE.
BUT FOR SMALL AND I WANT TO SEE
A GROWING NUMBER OF PROJECTS
THEY APPEAR TO BE.
IF ANY POINT IN A TAX CREDIT
PARTNERS CAPITAL CAN'T REACHES
ZERO DURING THE FIFTEEN YEAR TAX
CREDIT WE CAPTURE PERIOD. ONE OF
TWO THINGS MUST GENERALLY
HAPPENS.
THE FIRST IS AT THE PARTNER MUST
STOP TAKING ANYMORE THE PROMISED
TAX CREDITS OR DEDUCTIONS.
AND LESSEN UNTIL THEIR CAPITAL
COUNTY COMES POSITIVE AGAIN.
IF THIS OCCURS DURING ELEVEN
YEAR PERIOD DURING WHICH THE LOW
INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDIT IS
EXPECTED TO BE DELIVERED.
IT'S LIKELY BE CATASTROPHIC FOR
THE PROJECT.
THE SECOND POSSIBILITY IS THAT
THE PROJECT IS GENERATED WAS
CALLED MINIMUM GAIN WHICH IS A
POSITIVE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
PROJECTS TAX BASIS. AT
OUTSTANDING DEBT.
YOU'RE CONTINUE TAKING THE LOW
INCOME HOUSING CREDITS AND
DEDUCTIONS EVEN THOUGH DOING SO
MAKES THE CAPITAL ACCOUNT GO
NEGATIVE.
NOW THE WORDS THE BENEFITS
INVESTOR HAS TAKEN OUT OF THE
PROJECT EXCEED WHAT THEY'VE
CONTRIBUTED.
THE SECOND OUTCOMES CERTAINLY
BETTER THAN THE FIRST HOWEVER IT
HAS ANOTHER QUITE NEGATIVE
OUTCOME.
BEFORE THE TAX CREDIT INVESTOR
CAN EXIT THE PROJECT THE PROJECT
CAN BE RETURNED TO THE SPONSOR.
TAXES MUST BE PAID ON THE
NEGATIVE CAPITAL ACCOUNT THE
EXTRA BENEFITS.
AT THE END OF FIFTEEN YEARS.
WHEN THE OPERATION OF THE
NONPROFIT SPONSOR TYPICALLY HAS
THE OPTION TO REPURCHASE THE
PROJECT FROM A TAX CREDIT
PARTNERSHIP. INSECT BITE OF THE
TAX CREDIT INVESTOR.
THE GENERALLY REQUIRED TO PAY.
TAXES
ON BEHALF OF A TAX CREDIT
INVESTOR ON THE NEGATIVE CAPITAL
COUNT.
THOSE ACCOUNTS ARE GONE NEGATIVE
BY TWO TO THREE MILLION DOLLARS
WHICH IS NOT BE DIFFICULT TO
SPONSOR. USUALLY NONPROFIT
NONPROFIT MIGHT HAVE TO COME OUT
OF POCKET I HAVE MILLION TO
MILLION DOLLARS.
REAL CASH
TO REPURCHASE THE PROJECT IN THE
TAX CODE PARTNERSHIP.
OBVIOUSLY ON BOTH OF THESE
OUTCOMES AS CONSULTANTS
ADVOCATES WE DO OUR BEST TO
STRUCTURE PROJECT TO MINIMIZE.
THIS PROBLEM AND PRESERVE THE
LONG TERM AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THIS ISN'T A NEW ISSUE FOR US
RESTRUCTURED HUNDREDS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS OVER
THE YEARS. WITH GOOD SUCCESS AT
AVOIDING OR LEAST MINIMIZING
THESE PROBLEMS.
WE DO COLLABORATE WITH MANY
LOCAL PUBLIC AGENCIES WHO
STRUCTURE UPFRONT THE TERMS OF
THEIR SOFT LOANS. IN WAYS THAT
MAINTAIN CAPITAL ACCOUNTS AND
AVOID THE PROBLEMS ARE
DESCRIBED.
PACIFIC LEAVE THESE AGENCIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA BEEN
WILLING TO SET INTEREST RATE ON
THEIR LOANS. AT OR NEAR ZERO
PERCENT IN ORDER TO REDUCE THE
ANNUAL TAX DEDUCTIONS.
THE PROJECT WAS TAKEN MAINTAIN
THE CAPITAL COUNTS IN THE
POSITIVE SIDE.
THE ONLY PUBLIC FOR THE HOUSING
LENDER WE WORK WITH YOU LACKS
THE AUTHORITY. TO ADJUST
INTEREST RATES IN THESE
SITUATIONS IS A TWO CD.
GIVING IT TO YOU THE AUTHORITIES
ARE JUST AS INTEREST RATES ON
LOANS WILL MAKE A VERY BIG
DIFFERENCE FOR NEW AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROJECTS.
I WANT TO POINT OUT THAT WHILE
THIS IS NOT A NEW ISSUE IT'S
GREATLY EXACERBATED BY RECENT
EVENTS.
FIRST IS FEDERAL TAX REFORM.
BY REDUCING THE CORPORATE TAX
RATE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
REDUCE THE VALUE OF OUR LOW
INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDITS. AND
THE TAX LOSSES TO INVESTORS
RESULTING LOWER TAX CREDIT
PRICING.
LOWER PRICING MAKES CAPITAL
CAMPERVANS WORSE.
TAX REFORM ALSO EFFECTIVELY TOOK
AWAY SEVERAL OPTIONS WE USED TO
HAVE FOR SLOWING DOWN THE FLOW
OF TAX BENEFITS GIVING US FEWER
OPTIONS.
TO FIX THESE PROBLEMS.
SECOND MAKE MAJOR CHANGES COST
INCREASES AS YOU KNOW
CONSTRUCTION COSTS IN OPERATING
COSTS. CONTINUE TO INCREASE AND
EXERT NEGATIVE PRESSURE AND
CAPITAL ACCOUNTS.
HIGHER COSTS MEANS DEVELOPERS
ALSO GENERALLY A BIGGER FUNDING
GAPS
WHICH MEANS WE NEED MORE MONEY
FROM EIGHT CD.
MORE MONEY FOR MAKE CITY OUGHT
THREE PERCENT OCCURRING
INTEREST.
ALSO HURTS THE CAPITAL ACCOUNTS.
ESPECIALLY IN THE CURRENT POST
TAX REFORM ENVIRONMENT OUR
OFFICE TO SING A NUMBER OF
PROPOSED AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS.
WHICH DESPITE HAVING FINANCING
COMMITMENTS IN HAND SUFFICIENT
TO COVER ALL THE COSTS.
OR SIMPLY INFEASIBLE ATTACKS
BASIS.
DUE TO CAPITAL COUNTY ISSUES.
IN SOME CASES PROJECTS CAN BE
MADE FEASIBLE ON A TAX BASIS
BUT THE FIX A SUBSTANTIALLY
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF PRIVATE TAX
TAX CREDIT LEVERAGE EQUITY THEY
CAN RAISE.
RESULTING IN A BIGGER GAP IN THE
NEED FOR MORE STATE OR LOCAL
PUBLIC SUBSIDY.
AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY ONSITE
SECOND PART AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY
TO MAKE IT ASK YOU TO WRAP IT
UP.
OKAY YOU'RE ABLE TO LOCATE WE'VE
GOT A NUMBER OF ITEMS LAKE WOULD
CERTAINLY HELP US UPDATE TO.
IT TO THE HOME PROGRAMS AND
WORK IN TODAY'S FINANCIAL
MARKETS WHICH IS A SPORT BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I'M TOM COLLEGE SHOWED PRESIDENT
CEO OF SELF HELP ENTERPRISES
WERENONPROFIT SERVING THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY DOING HOUSING.
DEVELOPMENT FOR FARMWORKERS AND
OTHER.
WORKING FAMILIES AND WE
EXPERIENCED THAT THIS PROBLEM
FIRST HAND LAST YEAR WE HAD
ACTUALLY TWO PROJECTS IN.
TULARE COUNTY.
WILL BOTH SUPPORTED BY THE CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAM AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
ONE GOT HELD UP BECAUSE OF THIS
VERY PROBLEM SO IT IS A VERY
REAL PROBLEM. WE ARE SUPPORTIVE
OF THIS EFFORT TO CREATE MORE
FLEXIBILITY FOR H. CD TO BE ABLE
TO FIX. THESE THINGS UNDER A
NUFF BARRIERS AND CREATING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WITHOUT TO.
ADDING ADDING THIS BARRIER WITH
THAT FOR INVESTORS THANK YOU
GREAT THANK YOU OTHER
SUPPORTERS.
REBEKAH MARCUS REPRESENTING
LEADING AGE CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
ROB WIENER CALIFORNIA COALITION
FOR RURAL HOUSING IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
MICHAEL LEHMAN THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION OTHER
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER SUPPORTERS ANY
OPPOSITION.
SEEN ON BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE MISTER MULLIN YOU'RE
CORRECT THIS IS A HIGHLY
TECHNICAL AND I'D. ISSUE BUT I
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON THIS
AND.
I THINK WE. ARE CERTAINLY
SPEAKING FOR MYSELF DEFTLY
SUPPORT YOUR EFFORTS TO PROVIDE
SOME FLEXIBILITY IN LOAN
REPAYMENTS FOR OUR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MISTER CHAU.
I JUST WANTED TO GET THE
SIMPLIFICATION SO SO THIS BILL
ALLOWS SOCIAL ALLOW HCV TO SET
THE YEAR OF THE INTEREST RATE.
SO WOULD THE POINT FOUR FOUR TWO
AS THE DID THE FLOOR IS THAT IS
IS THAT WHAT IT IS OR. HOW WE
GIVING THEM ARE COMPLETE
DISCRETION AND IF SO THEN OF IF
OF FOUR POINT TWO FOUR POINT TWO
PERCENT IS TO THE FLOOR THEN?
WHAT IS SO MAGICAL ABOUT DATA I
DIDN'T QUITE FOLLOW THAT
EXPLANATION?
THAT THE IDEA IS TO GET THE
FLOOR WOULD BE POINT FOUR POINT
FOUR TWO PERCENT THAT'S I FIGURE
THAT'S ESTABLISHED BY EIGHT CD
THAT'S REPRESENT OF THEIR.
ADMINISTRATIVE COST OF
ADMINISTERING THE LONG.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
OKAY BACK TO THE AUTHOR.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR ENTERTAINING THE BILL.
WERE WORKING WITH HCV GOING
FORWARD ABOUT ADDITIONAL AYE
ISSUES WE'VE BEEN ENGAGING.
THE GOAL HERE CSUS ADDITIONAL
FLEXIBILITY TO MAKE PROJECTS
FEASIBLE IN THE REAL WORLD AND
THAT'S WHY I'M DOING THIS SO I
APPRECIATE. THAT THE.
PRESENTATION.
AND YOU'RE LISTENING TO IT AND
I ASK YOU ABOUT.
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE IS
OUR MOTION.
MOTION BY MISTER GLORIA SECOND
BY MISTER CHAO MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CHU LAI AYE. MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE CHAO.
SHALL I CHOI.
GLORIA.
GLORIA I LIMON. LEE MONTH I
WOULD.
WHAT I?
YOUR BILLS OUT THANK YOU MISTER
MULLIN.
HER NEXT PRESENTATION WILL BE BY
MISTER TING FILE ITEM EIGHT A.
B. TWENTY EIGHT NINETY ON
ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF FIRST
LET ME JUST THINK.
BICU OR CONSULTANT TEAM AND
YOURSELF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL WE REALLY VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THEM.
AND THEIR.
THEIR SIGNIFICANT HELP ON THIS
LEGISLATION ABOUT THE BILL'S
BEEN DOUBLE REFER TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE LATER THIS
AFTERNOON SO PROCEDURALLY. I
CANNOT ADOPT ANY AMENDMENTS IN
THIS COMMITTEE BUT I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE NEXT COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THAT ADDRESSED ISSUES
REYES IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
AND APPRECIATE BOTH CONSULTANTS
FOR WORKING. TOGETHER ON THIS IN
THE INTEREST OF TIME I'M GONNA
FOCUS MY COMMENTS ON THE
PROVISIONS THAT REFLECT PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS.
I'M SO THE BILL REMOVES BARRIERS
TO WIDESPREAD ADOPTION OF EIGHTY
USES LOW COST ENERGY EFFICIENT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. ACCEPTS RING
DWELLING UNITS IN JUNIOR EXCEPT
FOR DAHLE UNITS ARE KEY TO HELP
SOLVE OUR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CRISIS THESE UNITS CAN BE BUILT
FAIRLY QUICKLY AND AT A FAIRLY.
AT A SIGNIFICANTLY CHEAPER I
RATE THE NEW CONSTRUCTION A FACT
A STUDY FROM THE UC BERKELEY
TURNER CENTER FOR HOUSING
INNOVATION. DOCUMENTED THAT
DESPITE NUMEROUS EIGHTY YOU LOTS
BEING ENACTED IN THE PAST FEW
YEARS. UNFORCED IN MANY CITIES
AND COUNTIES CONTINUE TO IMPOSE
BARRIERS TO I EIGHTY USE.
FOR EXAMPLE ARTESIA HAS A LOCAL
ORDINANCE NOW THAT ONLY ALLOWS
LOTS THAT ARE TEN THOUSAND
SQUARE FEET OR GREATER TO BUILD
IN EIGHTY YOU. WHICH EFFECTIVELY
ADVANCE THEM I THIS IS.
AS YOU KNOW THE REASON THAT WE
ARE ALL BECOMING MUCH MORE
HEAVILY INVOLVED THE STATE LEVEL
YOURSELF THIS COMMITTEE. ON MANY
OF OUR COLLEAGUES ARE ARE
FOCUSED ON LAWS THAT WILL HELP
STREAMLINED THE CONSTRUCTION OF
HOUSING.
I'M PROUD TO.
.
TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE SUCCESSES
THANKS TO GET OUR CHAIR AND HIS
LEADERSHIP DURING HIS TIME ON
THE BOARD OF CITY COUNCIL
FRANCISCO. OUR APPLICATION TO
SAN FRANCISCO OR UP FROM FORTY
ONE AND TWENTY FIFTEEN TO ONE
THOUSAND FORTY SIX AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN.
SETS A NUMBER COUNTY AND SANTA
BARBARA ALSO ENCOURAGING THE
BUILDINGS OF EIGHTY USE IN
JUNIOR EIGHTY YEARS UP WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON A. B..
TWENTY EIGHT NINETY AND I HAVE
FOR THE TWO WITNESSES.
YOUR WITNESSES MISSPENT.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS DENISE
PING STAN I'M HERE TODAY TO SAY.
CURRENT GO LOCAL ZONING BOARD
ADMINISTRATOR OF MEMBER A FORMER
CURRENT PLANNING CHIEF AND A
MEMBER ABOUT A DOZEN HOUSING
COMMITTEE SAID THE BAY AREA.
AS A VOLUNTEER.
AND THE FOLKS WHO WERE IN THE
EIGHTY YOU ADVOCACY GROUP IN
CALIFORNIA ARE ALL VOLUNTEERING
OUR TIME BECAUSE THERE IS NO
PAID LOBBYIST YOU CAN COME HERE
AND REPRESENT HOMEOWNERS. WHO
TAKE THEIR BUILDING PERMIT TO
THE COUNTER AND TRY TO GET IT
APPROVED TO ADD A HOUSE OR AT
HOMES IT OUT WITHIN THEIR
BUILDING ENVELOPE TO HOUSE
PEOPLE WHO WHO DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
HOUSING AND HOUSE THAT MAYBE US
OVER SERVING THEM?
THIS BILL WAS DRAFTED BY
EXPERTS AT UCLA'S CITY ALLOWED.
WHO HAVE BEEN WORKING ON EIGHTY
YOU POLICY FOR A DECADE IN LOS
ANGELES AND WHO OF DIRECTLY
WITNESSED
A CONTINUING BARRIERS THAT
REMAIN TO ACCESSORY DWELLING
UNITS THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA? I'M HERE TODAY WITH
ONE OF THEIR COLLEAGUES AT THE
TURNER CENTER AT UC BERKELEY WHO
AGAIN HAS BEEN STUDYING THE
EFFECT OF CALIFORNIA'S RECENT
EIGHTY YOU LAWS. AND ALTHOUGH
THERE'S SOME VERY ENCOURAGING
OUTCOMES IT'S ALSO QUITE CLEAR
THAT WE WHEN WE THOUGHT WE WERE
DONE A COUPLE YEARS AGO. THERE
WERE JUST BERRIES THAT WERE
UNFORESEEABLE VENDOR THAT WE
DIDN'T SEE AND SO THIS SET OF
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS AND THESE
THIS BILL. TAKES CARE OF THE
REMAINING ZONING BARRIERS THAT
CONTINUE TO PREVENT HOMEOWNERS
FROM PULLING THAT BUILDING
PERMIT WHEN THEY GO TO THE
ZONING COUNTER IN SPITE OF STATE
LAW THAT SAYS CITY SHOULD ISSUE
MINISTERIAL PERMITS FOR
ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS.
.
DID THE BILL REMOVES MAJOR
BARRIERS THAT CONTINUE IN
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING LARGE
MINIMUM LOT SIZES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TING POINTED OUT. A
PARKING RESTRICTIONS IF YOU IF
YOU PULL IT I'M.
AND.
FEES AND CODES WHICH I
UNDERSTAND ARE BEING REMOVED
FROM THE BILL.
.
THE BILL ALSO HAS GOT PROVISIONS
IN IT THAT WERE DRAFTED BY
PLANNERS IN THE FIRE RECOVERY
ZONES IN THE NORTH COUNTY WHO
HAVE IDENTIFIED EIGHTY USE AS
THE ONLY FEASIBLE MEANS OF
PROVIDING HOUSING QUICKLY. IN
RESPONSE TO THE MAJOR
CATASTROPHIC FIRES THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS FACED AND WHO
THEMSELVES REVIEWED EARLY DRAFTS
OF THIS BILL TO MAKE SURE THAT
INCLUDED ALL THE COMPONENTS THAT
WERE NECESSARY. FOR NOT ONLY THE
KEEP THE FIRE COUNTIES TO
PROVIDE HOUSING QUICKLY BUT FOR
EVERYONE ELSE TO EQUALLY SHARE.
THE PROVISION OF HOUSING
TODAY IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE SOME
CITIES THAT ARE STELLAR ACTORS
INNER I ADOPTING REALLY GOOD
BEST PRACTICES LIKE SAN
FRANCISCO. THAT IS ADOPTING
MULTI FAMILY BUILDINGS IN THE
BUILDING ENVELOPE THAT MIGHT
HAVE A BASEMENT OR SOMEONE YOU
SPACE AND LETTING EIGHTY USE BE
BUILT AND THEIR. MOTHER SOME
REALLY GOOD GOOD ACTORS THERE'S
A LOT OF CITIES THAT ARE STILL
TRYING TO AVOID COMPLYING WITH
STATE LAW AND AS IT RELATES TO
EIGHTY USE.
SO THIS BILL.
BY REMOVING THOSE REMAINING
ZONING BARRIERS ALLOWS
HOMEOWNERS TO BUILD SAFE LEGAL
BUILDING PERMITTED HOUSING.
ON THEIR PROPERTY AND AND TO
GET YES WITH THE CITY WHEN THEY
SHOW UP WITH THAT BUILDING
PERMIT APPLICATION AND SAID ARE
BEING TOLD. THEY CAN'T THEY
CAN'T GET IN A BUILDING PERMIT
BECAUSE THEY DON'T MEET A
MINIMUM LOT SIZE OR SOME OTHER
STANDARD THAT FRANKLY CITY
SHOULD HAVE BEEN WORKING OVER
THE LAST FEW YEARS. TO
ELIMINATE.
THANK YOU YOUR NEXT WITNESS.
A GOOD MORNING AND I THINK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING ENDEAVORS
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DAVID
GARCIA. I'M THE POLICY DIRECTOR
AT THE UC BERKELEY TURNER CENTER
FOR HOUSING INNOVATION AND TO
DATE WE HAVE UNDERTAKEN A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF RESEARCH
ON ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS. AND
BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL AND AND
SEVERAL OF OUR EVIDENCE BASED
RECOMMENDATIONS TO.
INCREASE THE PRODUCTION OF
EXCESS WRIGGLING UNITS TO THE
TURNER CENTER CONSIDERS EIGHTY
USED TO BE IN A SOCIAL A PIECE
OF A BROADER. A SOLUTION TO THE
STATE'S HOUSING CRISIS OZZIE'S
UNITS REPRESENT A PARTICULARLY
EFFICIENT AND AFFORDABLE A FORM
OF HOUSING AND SPECIFICALLY
EIGHTY USE REQUIRE NO SUBSIDY.
ARE GENERALLY RENDER THAT BELOW
MARKET RATE ANTS INDIVIDUALS WHO
OFTENTIMES HAVE AN EXISTING
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE WITH THE
OWNER SUCH AS A FAMILY MEMBER OR
CARETAKER. AND MORE OVER.
EIGHTY USE CAN INCREASE HOUSING
OPTION USING AREAS WERE LARGER
SCALE DEVELOPMENT IS NOT
PHYSICAL FEASIBLE WHICH IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT GIVEN
THAT.
MAJORITY OF THE STATE IS.
ZONE FOR SINGLE FAMILY DETACHED
HOUSING SO GIVEN THESE BENEFITS
TERMS CENTER BELIEVES THAT
REMOVING BARRIERS TO THE VELVET
EIGHTY YOU SHOULD BE A PRIORITY.
AND THIS BILL THERE'S A
CONSIDERABLE AMOUNTS TO ACHIEVE
HIS GOALS ARE WORK HAS SHOWN
SCALING BACK OWNERS DESIGN
REQUIREMENTS.
WILL SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE
INTEREST AND PRODUCTION IN THIS
FORM OF HOUSING OUT MORE OVER
THE CREATION OF A SPECIFIC SMALL
STRUCTURES BUILDING CODE. SHE
ALSO MEANINGFULLY REDUCE THE
COST AND COMPLEXITY OF EIGHTY
USE AND AS WE SEE WITH OTHER
RECENT LEGISLATION ELIMINATING
OBSTACLES. FOR HOMEOWNERS
INTERESTED IN EIGHTY USE IS AN
EFFECTIVE WAY TO CREATE MORE.
INTEREST IN IN HOUSING.
AND TO ALSO OF GREAT UNITS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY.
BUILT ILLEGALLY.
SO THIS SERVICE BECAUSE
POTENTIAL TO CONTINUE MOMENTUM
THAT WE'VE SEEN IN RECENT
LEGISLATION AND THAT WE BELIEVE
THAT IT REFLECTS SEVERAL OF OUR
EVIDENCE BASED RECOMMENDATIONS.
THANK YOU OTHER SUPPORTERS.
I SHOULD MENTION WE BROUGHT WITH
US TODAY SOMEONE YOU ACTUALLY IS
HELPING HOMEOWNERS BUILD EIGHTY
USER TRYING TO JOE SERRANO THE
CBO TENT MAKERS. WHO'S BEEN
ACTIVE PARTICULARLY AND LOWER
INCOME COMMUNITIES IN THE BAY
AREA TO HELP HOMEOWNERS WHO NEED
AN EIGHTY YOU TO PAY THEIR
MORTGAGE OR ANOTHER WHY STAY IN
THEIR HOME.
AND TO LEGALIZE EXISTING
ILLEGALLY SO HE'S HERE IF YOU
WANT TO ASK QUESTIONS OF HIM
GREAT THANK YOU WELCOME.
ARE THERE SUPPORTERS OF THE
BILL.
GOOD MORNING DEBORAH CARL'S WITH
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
PARANORMAL REPRESENTING BRIDGE
HOUSING ALSO IN SUPPORT.
MICHAEL AIM AT THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT.
SO SEND MATT NOT LIGHTHOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS HERE ON BEHALF OF
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIANS FOR THE BILL.
LOSE MONDAY FOR CALIFORNIA MEANS
FOR THE BILL.
I'M AB VETERANS YEAH I WAS
WORKING PARTNERSHIPS USA
REPRESENTING A HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY ARE
ALONG WITH AYE AYE YIN AYE UNITE
HERE LOCAL MAIN SEEM AN ABC
LOCAL SEVEN. I IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL AS AMENDED TO RESTRICT
SHORT TERM RENTALS
THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
A GOOD MORNING I AM MICROBES IN
HERE ON BEHALF THE COW FREE
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
WE HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
PURPOSE A POSITION ON THE BILL
ON AND AS I UNDERSTAND.
I'M FROM CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
STAFF AND AND AS INDICATED BY
THE AUTHOR. AND AMENDMENTS TO BE
TAKEN IN THE COMMITTEE I IN THE
NEXT COMMITTEE WILL PRESERVE.
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES RIGHT
ABILITY TO COLLECT FEES FOR
SERVICES THEY'RE PROVIDING
INTERNET FOR FOR WATER IF WATER
ELECTRICITY HOOKUPS AND SO WHEN
THAT MEN INSIDE TAKEN WILL
REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION THANKS.
THANK YOU WHAT WE HEAR FROM THE
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS NANCY CHINA'S HAS BEEN
US ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION WHICH
REPRESENTS OVER A THOUSAND
SCHOOL BOARDS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE GOING TO LIMIT OUR
COMMENTS TO THE FEE PROVISIONS
OF THE BILL AND A BUT FIRST OFF
I WANT TO ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH
THE BROADER GOALS OF THE BILL
AND I AGREE WITH PROPONENTS THAT
EIGHTY USE ARE THE CENTRAL
COMPONENT OF. RESOLVING THE
HOUSING CRISIS.
WE IN THE EDUCATION COMMUNITY
LIVE THE HOUSING CRISIS EVERY
DAY WE KNOW DEFECTS OUR STUDENTS
AND POSE A SERIOUS DIFFICULTIES
TO US FOR RECRUITMENT RETENTION
OF STAFF.
THAT SAID.
EXACERBATING THE CRISIS OF
SCHOOL FACILITIES IS NOT THE
ANSWER SO WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE.
FIRST
YES SIR.
UP FIRST OFF I WNT TO MENTION
THAT PROP FIFTY ONE WHICH WAS
PASSED BY THE VOTERS IN NOVEMBER
TWENTY SIXTEEN ACTUALLY
PROHIBITS THE.
THE AMENDMENT THAT EXCUSE ME IT
LOCKED IN THE GOVERNMENT FEET
THE GOVERNMENT CODE SECTION THAT
AUTHORIZES LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES TO ASSESS DEVELOPMENT
FEES IT PROPOSES CAPS AND IT
REQUIRES JUSTIFICATION STUDIES.
AND THAT CAN ONLY BE AMENDED BY
AN ACT OF THE VOTERS.
AND ALSO I WANT TO SAY THAT.
THE OVERCROWDING.
THAT WE'RE EXPERIENCING IN THE
GROWTH THAT WE'RE EXPERIENCING
WE STILL HAVEN'T CAUGHT UP FROM
THE TWO THOUSAND HOUSING BOOM
THESE NEED THESE FUNDS ARE ARE
VERY MUCH NEEDED. THAT WE
ACTUALLY NEED TO RAISE OUR OUR
IMPACT FEES OR TO QUALIFY FOR
STATE UNDING WHICH IS VERY MUCH
LACKING. AND.
I I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT.
WE ALSO THINK WE SHOULD WAIT
FOR THE TWO THOUSAND NINE
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT STUDY WHICH WILL
SHED SOME MORE LIGHT ON HOW
IMPACT FEES. ARE WORKING IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND.
DISPEL THE MYTH THAT PEOPLE WHO
LIVE AN ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS
DO NOT HAVE CHILDREN BECAUSE WE
KNOW FROM OUR DAILY INTERACTION
WITH OUR STUDENTS THAT THAT IS
NOT TRUE AND ACCESSORY DWELLING
UNITS ARE ARE FINE. HOUSING FOR
A LOT OF FAMILIES ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU KNOW
THE.
AND IF I COULD JUST TO THE
AUTHOR I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU
WILL BE TAKEN THE FEES SECTION
OUT WORK IN IRAQ THAT ACCIDENT
YET JUST A GREATER CLARIFY. ON
CLIMATE AND MOST THE OPPONENTS
HERE AROUND THE FEE PROVISIONAL
WE ARE STRIKING. THE FREE
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL OUT
I APPRECIATE THAT IT WASN'T
CLEAR TO US THANK YOU GREAT
THANK YOU.
I THINK WE ALSO APPRECIATE THAT
BE AMENDMENT AND IT'S DIFFICULT
BECAUSE THERE'S TWO OTHER BILLS
AMENDING THE SAME SECTION OF THE
GOVERNMENT CODE RIGHT NOW ON
THIS ON TOPIC. I DID JUST
BECAUSE WHEN THE HOUSING AT
UNIVAR MAKE COMMITTEE WANNA
POINT OUT THAT OFTEN WHEN LOCAL
AGENCIES DE FOR OR WAVE IMPACT
FEES WERE GETTING SOME LEVEL OF
AFFORDABILITY AND I THINK THAT'S
A CONCEPT THAT HASN'T REALLY
BEEN DISCUSSED IN THE CONTEXT.
OF EIGHTY USE AND I DO WANT TO
TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE LAND USE
RELATED PROVISIONS IN THE BILL
AS EVERYONE KNOWS IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN WE PASSED TWO MAJOR LAWS
OVERHAULING EXCESS REDRAWING
UNIT LAW.
IT'S JUST BECAME EFFECTIVE IN
JUNE I'M SORRY JANUARY TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SO LOCAL AGENCIES ARE
NOW AT THE TAIL END OF UPDATING
THEIR ORDINANCES AND HERE WE ARE
AGAIN. REWRITING THE CODE IN A
VERY SIGNIFICANT WAY I'M I WANT
TO TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
IMPACT SPECIFICALLY ON COUNTIES
WHERE I THINK SOME OF THIS BILL.
IS REALLY FOCUSED ON URBAN AREAS
AND NOT THE UNINCORPORATED AREAS
WHERE THERE MIGHT BE REASONS FOR
A SORT OF A DIFFERENT APPROACH
THAT ONE OF THOSE THINGS IS
THAT.
THE SIZE OF THESE UNITS IN
UNINCORPORATED AREAS IS GONNA
TEND TO BE MUCH LARGER AND SO
THE IMPACTS ON INFRASTRUCTURE
OTHER THINGS ARE GOING TO BE
GREATER FOR INSTANCE PLASTER
COUNTY RIGHT UP THE HILL FROM
US.
ALLOWS TWO THOUSAND SQUARE FEET
OF EXCESS THREE RESIDENTIAL USES
SO THAT COULD INCLUDING EIGHTY
YOU ARE GARAGE AT CETERA AND
THAT'S THE MINIMUM SIZE ALLOWED.
IT GOES ALL THE WAY UP TO NO
RESTRICTIONS ON SIZE FOR
ACCESSORY RESIDENTIAL USES
IF YOU HAVE A LARGER PARCEL.
ONE OTHER ISSUE FOR US IN TERMS
OF THE LIMITATIONS ON
RESTRICTIONS ON PARCEL SIZE IS
AN UNINCORPORATED AREAS YOU HAVE
A LOT OF PLACES THAT DON'T HAVE
SEWER AND WATER SERVICE. SO BY
JUST
STRIKING THE ABILITY TO USE
PARCEL SIZE IS A SCREENING
CRITERIA FOR WHETHER AND EIGHTY
YOU CAN STATE ON A PARCEL OR
NOT.
YOU'RE GOING TO FORCE PEOPLE
INTO A SITUATION WHERE THEY GET
ALL THE WAY THROUGH THE
DEVELOPMENT PROCESS AND THEN
WHEN THEY GO TO TRY TO PULL
THEIR WELL OR SEPTIC PERMIT.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
GET THE UNIT APPROVED SO I DON'T
THINK THAT'S A POLICY OUTCOME
THAT THE COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE.
FINALLY I JUST WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT THERE'S A VERY
FUNDAMENTAL SHIFT IN THE
BEGINNING OF THE BILL WHICH IS
TO REQUIRE INSTEAD OF AS THE
TWENTY SIXTEEN LIES DEAD. TO
IDENTIFY THE AREAS WHERE EIGHTY
USE ARE PERMITTED THE LAW WOULD
NOW CHANGED TO REQUIRE THE
OPPOSITE SO BASICALLY THE
ORDINANCE WOULD HAVE TO BE
COMPLETELY RE WRITTEN TO SAY
WHERE THEY ARE EXCLUDED AND SO
WE DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS.
ESPECIALLY WITH THE PROVISIONS
THAT WOULD SEEK TO LIMIT THE
ABILITY TO PRECLUDE EIGHTY USE
IN AREAS THAT MIGHT HAVE HIGH
FIRE HAZARD SEVERITY OR OTHER
ISSUES LIKE THAT BY IMPOSING A
STANDARD. THAT IS NOT CONSISTENT
WITH OTHER PARTS OF LAND USE LAW
WHICH IS THE PREPONDERANCE OF
EVIDENCE VERSUS THE SUBSTANTIAL
EVIDENCE STANDARD SERVER THESE
REASONS AND MANY MORE OUTLINES
ARE LETTERS AYE WE REMAIN
OPPOSED TO THE BILL.
THANK YOU OTHER OPPOSITION
YESTERDAY MORNING THAT MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS JASON RYAN LEE
CALIFORNIA CITIES AND WE ARE NOT
OPPOSED TO EIGHTY USE I MEAN
THAT'S EXISTING LAW AND WE
CERTAINLY SHARE THE CONCERNS.
WHETHER COLLEAGUES OVERSEE SACK.
FAIR I JUST WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION SCHOOL BUSINESS
OFFICIALS AND CONTINUES
OPPOSITION.
FOR HIM TO DEAL WITH THE
COALITION FOR ADEQUATE SCHOOL
HOUSING CONTINUED OPPOSITION.
JOHN OF COURSE ABOUT THE URBAN
KINDS OF CALIFORNIAN OPPOSITION.
TRACY RAN ROLL COUNTY REPRESENTS
A CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION.
OR ENABLE NC REPRESENT THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION
OPPOSITION JUST ONE AT THAT WE
WERE ACTUALLY JUST AN US SENATE
GOVERNANCE OF FINANCE FOR A VERY
DIFFERENT SET OF AMENDMENTS WERE
TAKEN ON. ONE OF THE TWO BILLS
UP SO WE ARE CONCERNED WE
APPRECIATE YOUR AMENDMENTS HOW
THESE BILLS ARE GOING TO
INTERACT AS A CONTINUE TO MALES.
I THINK YOU BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY DISCUSSION.
WAS A MONTH SO I HAVE A QUESTION
FOR THE SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION.
WITH THE STRIKING OF THE FEE
PROVISION AND HOW WILL THAT.
IMPACT THE LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
I ANTICIPATE THE THAT WHEN THE
AMENDMENTS ARE IN PRINT THAT WE
WILL REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION AND
I'VE ALSO JUST INFORMED.
THE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER STAFF
THAT WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THEM BEING PART OF THAT
CONVERSATION AS THEY. FURTHER
WORK ON THIS FEE PROVISION ISSUE
RIGHT THANK YOU AND I DO
APPRECIATE YOUR RAISING THAT
ONLY BECAUSE.
VERY OFTEN THIS IS ONE OF THE
ELEMENTS THAT DOESN'T GET
CONSIDERED AN AS A FORMER SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBER. AT LEAST IN THE
COMMUNITY I REPRESENT THERE'S
DEFINITELY CHILDREN LIVING AND
SOME OF THESE UNITS.
AND SO THAT NEEDS TO BE
CONSIDERED AS WELL SO THINK YOU.
ANY OTHER DISCUSSION.
ME JUST SAY TO US TO THE AUTHOR
AS YOU KNOW WE'VE DISCUSSED
THIS.
THESE EIGHTY USE AND MAKING
SURE WE CAN.
TRADE AS MANY THEM AS POSSIBLE
IS VERY IMPORTANT.
AND I APPRECIATE TO YOU TRY TO
TAKE ON THIS TASK OF HELPING TO
REWRITE THE CODE THAT. IS
CURRENTLY.
HAS A LOT OF CONFUSION TO IT TO
MAKE IT MORE EFFECTIVE.
ARE SAN FRANCISCO EXPERIENCES
YOU KNOW WE HAD A MANY DECADES
DEBATE ABOUT WHETHER LEGALIZING
LAWS.
ME SIX YEARS TO PASS A LOCAL
ORDINANCE TO DO THAT.
AND WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO MAKE
SOME HEADWAY BUT NOW THERE'S
DISCUSSION NOW THAT EVERYONE
UNDERSTANDS HOW IMPORTANT EIGHTY
USE OUR.
THERE'S DISCUSSION OF HOW WE
CLEAN UP THE LEGISLATION I ROLL
LOCALLY TO DO THAT AND I
APPRECIATE YOU ARE TRYING TO DO
THAT AT THE STATE LEVEL. OF THE
ONLY THING I VAST AND I WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT THIS IS THAT YOU
AND YOUR SENATE AUTHORS ARE ABLE
TO GET ON THE SAME PAGE
HOPEFULLY.
WE'VE CERTAINLY RELATE THAT TO
OUR COUNTERPARTS IN VERY MUCH
HOPE THROUGH THE PROCESS YOU'LL
BE ABLE TO GET TO A GOOD PLACE
AND. AGREED TO A REALLY A ONE.
ONE SET OF UP PROVISIONS THAT
HELP TO. GIVE US A CLEAR SENSE
OF WHERE WE WANT TO GO ON EIGHTY
USE BUT GIVEN THAT.
WITH THE AMENDMENTS THAT YOU
AGREE TO TAKE IN THE NEXT
COMMITTEE.
.
I'M HAPPY TO.
TO ASK OUR COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT
THIS AND MOVED ON SO WITHOUT
DELAY FINAL COMMENTS
JUST THAT THAT WE WE TOTALLY
AGREE WITH I BELIEVE YOUR
FEEDBACK THEIR CONSULTANTS
FEEDBACK.
WE ARE VERY MUCH THE THREE
AUTHORS ARE VERY MUCH WORKING
VERY VERY CLOSELY TOGETHER AND
COMMUNICATING THAT THE HOPE IS
TO COME OUT WITH ON. A UNIFIED
APPROACH
ABSOLUTELY AND I WOULD JUST SAY
GOOD LUCK.
I HAD WITH THAT EASIER SAID THAN
DONE HERE WITH THAT.
IS THERE A MOTION TO MOVE THIS
TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
MOVED BY MISTER CHALLEN THINK
SECONDED BY MISTER GLORIA.
IT DOESN'T OTHER FEET WELL WON'T
HAVE THE FEE PROVISIONS AND
THAT'S THE COMMITMENT THAT IS
MAKING.
I TOOK OUT THE FEE PROVISION.
WITH THAT.
MADAM SECRETARY THE ROLE.
CHU I'D I MAIENSCHEIN. MAIN
CHIANG NO CHILD.
CHAO AYE CHOI.
CHOI AYE. GLORIA AYE GLORIA AYE
LEE MONTH.
WE MONTH I WOULD.
WHAT I? YOUR BILLS OUT LIKE YOU
THANK YOU.
MISTER EDUARDO GARCIA FILE ITEM
ONE AB TWENTY FIVE.
SIX THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
IT WAS CHAIR COLLEAGUES.
IT'S REPRESENTS YOU AB TWENTY
FIFTY SIX OUR MOBILE HOME PARK
REHABILITATION BILL. THAT AIMS
PRIMARILY TO ALLOW PARTICULAR
LOAN FUNDS TO BE USED FOR WE
HAVE IRRITATION A MOBILE HOME
PARKS.
BEGINNING NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE
THE MOBILE HOME PARK
REHABILITATION RESIDENT
OWNERSHIP FUND WAS CREATED IN
ORDER TO PROVIDE LOANS TO ASSIST
WITH. CONVERSION OF SIX SIX
MOBILE HOME PARKS TO BE OWNED BY
ITS RESIDENTS.
HOWEVER THE FUND HAS BEEN UNDER
UTILIZED IN JANUARY TOSSING
SEEM.
THE MOST RECENT NOTICE OF
FUNDING AVAILABILITY FOR
PROGRAMS ALTERED IN ZERO
APPLICATIONS RECEIVED.
A BECAUSE OF THIS WE PROPOSE A
FEW CHANGES THAT WILL
SIGNIFICANT IMPROVE THE ABILITY
FOR PARK CONVERSIONS TO OCCUR.
THE BILL FOCUSES IN ON TWO
THINGS IT ALLOWS DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING COMMITTEE DEVELOPMENT TO
MAKE LOANS IN ORDER
REHABILITATED MOBILE HOME PARK.
PROVIDED THAT NO LESS THAN
THIRTY PERCENT OF THE RESIDENTS
ARE LOW INCOME. IN ALSO REQUIRES
THE PROGRAM LOANS.
MUST SUPPORT IN ACQUISITION
REHABILITATION THAT A CD
DETERMINES WILL SUBSTANTIALLY
BENEFIT LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
HOMEOWNERS. AND THAT RENT WILL
REMAIN AT AN AFFORDABLE LEVEL.
MEMBERS OF PARTING OR EVEN
REHABILITATE OUR MOBILE PARKS
CAN BE EXPENSIVE COMPLEX AND
BURN SOME. HIS BILL HOPES TO
MAKE A SERIES OF CHANGES THAT
WILL LESSEN THE FINANCIAL BURDEN
FOR THESE RESIDENTS WHILE
ALLOWING THESE FUNDS TO GO
TOWARDS REHABILITATING HIS
MOBILE PARKS.
AND IT'S INFRASTRUCTURE TODAY
PROTEST WARNING OF BUYING ACOSTA
AND INFERIOR FOR FROM THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE CORPORATION FUND.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS BY A
GUEST ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR RURAL
HOUSING CO SPONSORS OF THIS
BILL.
JUST BRIEFLY AS THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SAID WE HAVE THIS SURPLUS
AND IMPROPER FUND. WE'VE BEEN
DOING A LOT OF WORK IN RECENT
YEARS AGO.
.
DO TO IMPROVE THE PROGRAM TO
MAKE IT MORE USABLE. WE THINK
THIS BILL ADDS TO. TO THAT IN A
WAY THAT WILL I THINK. IN A
FINALLY TIP THAT BALANCE WE HAVE
BEEN TALKING.
TO AFFORDABLE DEVELOPERS WHO
HAVE.
ATTEMPTED ACCESS THE PROGRAM.
AND LOOKED AT.
ACQUIRING A PARK AND GOT AS FAR
AS REALLY PLANET TRYING TO. RUN
THE NUMBERS AND PUT ME DOWN
PROPOSAL TOGETHER. AND ONE OF
THE CHIEF IMPROVEMENTS OF THIS
BILL ARE IS ALL IT WAS ALSO HAS
BEEN IMPEDIMENT WHICH IS HOW DO
YOU MAKE THESE PROJECTS PENCIL
IN A WAY. THAT PRESERVES THE
AFFORDABLE RENTS.
IN ADDITION WE SEE A NEED TO
HAVE FUNDING THAT WILL ASSIST IN
THE REHABILITATION OF PARKS EVEN
IF THEY AREN'T REQUIRED WITH
IMPROPER FUNDS. THIS BILL DOES
THOSE TWO THINGS AND UP. WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVE THE
PRESERVATION OF EXISTING MOBILE
HOME PARKS FOR LOWER INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS.
AND FOR THAT REASON WE WOULD ASK
WHEN I VOTE.
I DAY FERRIER I'M THE HOUSING
DIRECTOR FOR RURAL COMMUNITIES
ASSISTANCE CORPORATION THE LAST
TWO MONTHS PRIOR TO THAT LAST
THIRTY FIVE YEARS I WAS THE
DIRECTORATE CHIP. A COMMUNITY
HOUSING IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM
WHICH IS A NONPROFIT DEVELOPER
BASED IN CHICO WOULD DEVELOPED
OVER TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED HOUSING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS IN THE.
OF SACRAMENTO VALLEY.
SO.
MOBILE HOME PARKS ARE DEATHLY
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THE
INVENTORY OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND RURAL COMMUNITIES AND SO
IT'S SUPER IMPORTANT THAT WE.
BOTH PRESERVE AND IMPROVE THOSE
COMMUNITIES AND.
ONE OF THE MECHANISMS FOR A
PRETTY MUCH EVERY AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROGRAM IS DEFERRED
PAYMENT FINANCING WHICH.
IS A WAY OF SUBSIDIZING SIMPLE
OF ELEGANT WAY OF FINANCING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND OF THIS
PROGRAM HAS NOT HAD THAT ACCESS
TO THOSE THAT THAT TERM MOVE OF
FINANCING AND SO.
MANY RIGHT RENTAL HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS AS WELL AS SINGLE
FAMILY DEVELOPMENTS HAVE OF SUCH
LIES FINANCING THROUGH A
DEFERRED PAYMENT LOANS.
MORTGAGE SUBSIDY ALLOWANCES
THAT IS A GOOD EXAMPLE OF THAT
MANY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS USE THOSE
SO I WOULD URGE YOU TO TO PASS
THIS BILL AND IN SUPPORT THAT
FINANCING.
THANK YOU ARE THE SUPPORTERS.
MICHAEL AIM WITH THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION OTHER
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
BECAUSE CHVEZ ON BEHALF THE
GOLDEN STATE MANUFACTURED
HOMEOWNERS LEAGUE AND ARE KNOWN
AS JUST WHILE VISITING SENIORS
VETERANS IMMIGRANTS AND.
FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS ON LOW
MODERATE FIXED INCOMES AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LUIS PARTY WITH CALIFORNIA ME IN
SUPPORT.
FINALLY WITH THE LESSONS ARE
AMONG POVERTY AND SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY DISCUSSION MISTER CHUCK.
ARTS WHAT I THINK THE AUTHOR
FOR.
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I KNOW A
FEW YEARS AGO I TRIED IT TWEAK.
THE LAW MYSELF AND HASN'T
REALLY.
WORK TOO MUCH SO I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR TRYING IT AGAIN
AND THIS IS A HOPEFULLY THIS
WILL WORK. THANKS I WOULD THAT I
WANT TO LOOK WILL.
ONE OF THE BILL IS ABOUT MOVE
AFFORD IS OUR SECOND SECOND AYE
MR GLORIA ANY DISCUSSION.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR HELPING TO PROPOSE MAKING IT
EASIER FOR.
DIFFERENT ORGANIZATIONS TO
ACCESS OF THESE MOBILE HOME.
REHABILITATION AND OWNERSHIP
PROGRAM FUNDS.
I THINK WE ALL MANY OF US
BELIEVE THIS IS A VERY WORTHY
GOAL GIVEN THE MONEY THAT IS.
IN THE FUND AND THE CHALLENGES
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE HAD ACCESS
AND IT. WILL BE ASKING THE
AUTHOR IF YOU HAVE ANY FINAL
COMMENTS LIKE TO MAKE THAT HE
WAS CHAIR COLLEAGUES. IN OUR
DISTRICT WE'VE SEEN SOME REAL
SITUATIONS WHERE EITHER MOBILE
HOME PARKS HAVE BEEN PURCHASED.
AND DUBBED YELLED MOVED IN A
DIFFERENT DIRECTION DISPLACING
TO A WHOLE LOT OF FAMILIES WE'VE
ALSO SEEN. CIRCUMSTANCES AND ARM
THE EASTERN COACHELLA VALLEY
WHERE FARMWORKERS ARE LIVING IN.
REALLY.
.
CONDITIONS THAT REALLY NO ONE
SHOULD BE.
AFFORDED AND SO WE THINK THAT
THIS IS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS IN OUR. HOUSING CRISIS
AND.
ROLL PARTS OF THE STATE AND
RESPECT MASS RIVAL GREAT OTHERS
MOTION AND A SECOND MADAM
SECRETARY.
MOTION TO PENSION REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS CHIU
AYE CHIU AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
CHOW. CHOW AYE CHOI. SHOWING NO
GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE LAMONT.
THE MONTH I WOULD.
YOU BILLS UP WILL TAKE LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR OTHER AUTHORS.
OUR SECOND LAST BILL TODAY IS BY
MISTER BLOOM. FILE ITEM FIVE A.
B. TWENTY THREE SIXTY FOUR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS REALLY
PERMITTED.
PLEASE.
THANK YOU AND AND GOOD MORNING
THE ALICE ACT TO WAS CREATED TO
MANY YEARS AGO IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY FIVE.
I HARDLY REMEMBER NINETEEN
EIGHTY FIVE MYSELF.
BUT IT WAS CREATED TO ADDRESS A
VERY SPECIFIC ISSUE AND RENT
CONTROL JURISDICTIONS TO ALLOW
LANDLORDS TO ALL TENANTS IN THE
BUILDING. TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT.
HOWEVER OVER THE YEARS SOME
LANDLORDS HAVE EXPLOITED THE ACT
AND USE IT AS A TOOL TO AVOID
COMPLIANCE WITH LOCAL RENT
CONTROL LAWS.
THE ELLIS ACT EXPRESSLY
PROHIBITS WITHDRAWING LESS THAN
ALL THE UNITS IN THE BUILDING
FROM THE RENTAL MARKET.
AND THE LAW INDICATES THAT THERE
IS ONLY ONE WITHDRAWAL DATE FOR
THE PURPOSE OF CALCULATING
RENTAL AMOUNTS
WHEN UNITS. ARE RE OFFERED FOR
RENT
THIS ALL GETS VERY TECHNICAL BUT
THERE IS ALSO LANGUAGE GOVERNING
THE TENTH LEAST TERMINATION
DATE.
THAT SOME LANDLORDS HAVE
INTERPRETED AS ALLOWING MULTIPLE
WITHDRAWAL DATES IN ADDITION
THERE IS NO PROVISION THAT
SPECIFIES THAT THERE IS ONLY ONE
DAY. THAT APPLIES IF THE
PROPERTY IS PUT BACK ON THE
RENTAL MARKET.
SOMETHING THAT WAS INTENDED BY
THE ORIGINAL LAW.
SOME LANDLORDS HAVE TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF THIS CONFUSION BY
REMOVING UNITS FROM THE RENTAL
MARKET. AND RETURNING THEM IN A
PIECEMEAL FASHION AS
UNCONTROLLED UNITS TO AVOID THE
ACT'S RESTRICTIONS AND EVADE
RENT CONTROL GOING FORWARD.
SOME OF APPLY DIFFERENT
WITHDRAWAL DATES TO DIFFERENT
UNITS AND CLAIMED THAT RETURNING
ONE UNIT TO THE MARKET. DOES NOT
OBLIGATE THE LANDLORD TO RE
OFFER ANY OTHER UNITS TO FORMER
TENANTS AGAIN AS THE ACTOR OF OF
OF REQUIRES.
THIS ALLOWS LANDLORDS TO
EFFECTIVELY WITHDRAW LESS THAN
ALL OF THE UNITS FROM THE RENTAL
MARKET.
AND IN EFFECT NEVER ACTUALLY
LEAVE THE RENTAL MARKET AT ALL.
OF WHICH IS THE PURPOSE OF THREE
OF THE ALICE ACT WHILE AT THE
SAME TIME SUCCESSFULLY AFFECTING
OUR AFFECTING ALL OF THE.
EXISTING TENETS AND INCREASING
THE ROUTES TO MARKET.
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY FOUR
ADDRESSES THESE ISSUES BY AMONG
OTHER THINGS CLARIFYING THAT
THERE IS ONE EXIT DATE AND BY
ENHANCING FINES FOR VIOLATIONS
IN MY WITNESSES CAN GO INTO.
GREATER DETAIL OF ABOUT WHAT
THESE CLARIFICATIONS ARE AND HOW
THEY WILL.
EFFECTIVELY CHANGE THINGS
MOVING FORWARD.
I'VE HAD PRODUCTIVE MEETINGS
WITH CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION AND HAVE LISTENED
CLOSELY TO THE COMMENTS THAT
MANY OF YOU YOUR STAFFS AND
COMMITTEE STAFF HAS PROVIDED
AND.
BASED ON THAT INPUT THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF AMENDMENTS THAT I WILL
BE TAKING IN THE ASSEMBLY
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE I CAN
HONESTLY SAY THAT.
THESE DISCUSSIONS ARE
PARTICULARLY WITH THE APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION. OF HOW FOR A.
CONTINUED UP UNTIL THE CURRENT
MOMENT AND WILL CONTINUE TO
HAVE.
DISCUSSIONS GOING FORWARD.
AS NEEDED.
I END AND TO WILL NEGOTIATE TO
AS MANY POINTS AS POSSIBLE GOING
FORWARD BUT I THINK THAT WE HAVE
REACHED A A VERY IMPORTANT.
POINT IN OUR NEGOTIATIONS AND
WE'VE AGREED TO DO THE FOLLOWING
THINGS A EXTEND THE FOR THE A
TWO YEAR TIME PERIOD TO FIVE
YEARS AND LEAVE ALL OTHER TIME
PERIODS. AS THEY ARE CURRENTLY.
ELIMINATE THE CAP ON PENALTIES
FOR VIOLATING THE ACTOR. WHO WE
WILL PROHIBIT PIECEMEAL RETURN
TO THE RENTAL MARKET BY CREATING
ONE EXIT DAY? AND CLARIFY THAT
THE CHANGES TO THE LAW IN THIS
BILL ARE ALL PROSPECTIVE AND NOT
RETROACTIVE IN ADDITION.
WE'RE GONNA BE DELETING
PROVISIONS IN THE BILL THAT
RELATE TO AS I MENTIONED
EXTENDING THE FIVE YEAR TIME
PERIOD. TO TEN YEARS.
WILL DELETE THE A PROVISION
THAT APPLIED TO LAST LAW FOR
RENT TWO VACANT UNITS AND
EXTEND.
OF THE.
NOTICES THERE WAS PROVISION
EXTENDING NOTICES FROM A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY DAYS TO ONE YEAR. AND
TO WE ARE GOING TO DELETE THAT
PROVISION.
AND SO I I COME TO YOU SAYING
THAT I THINK WE'VE DONE WHAT THE
COMMITTEE ASKED OF.
OF OF MYSELF AND AND THE
ADVOCATES AND IT WAS TO TRY AND
REACH A COMPROMISE AND I'M.
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND WITH
APPLICANTS ON ALL SIDES OF THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE.
A IF AS I HOPE THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD FROM THIS COMMITTEE I
HAVE WITH ME OUT AT TWO
WITNESSES HERE. A TODAY ALISON
REGAN WITH THE CITY OF WEST
HOLLYWOOD AND BRIAN ACOSTA WHO
IS REPRESENTING THE SANTA MONICA
RENT CONTROL BOARD.
WHAT IS AND IS NOW DECIDING
WHO'S GOING TO GO AND? I THINK A
MINUTE OFFERS ARE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS BRIAN
AUGUSTA ON BEHALF OF THE TEN
MARK WENT ABOARD AND ALSO.
CALVET RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION BOTH IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE.
.
YEAH THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
DISCUSSION ABOUT THIS BILL AND
SO I DO I DO I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT WHAT MISTER BLOOM JUST
EMPHASIZED.
ABOUT THE CHANGES THAT WE ARE
AGREEING TO I'M HOPEFULLY COMING
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE.
BECAUSE MANY YEARS AGO WHEN WHEN
THE LANDLORDS AND REAL ESTATE
COMMUNITY CAME TO THIS
LEGISLATURE. THEN THEY SAID WITH
THE ALICE ACT ITEM WE NEED
RELIEF WE NEED PROTECTION.
FROM. I OF LOCAL ORDINANCE AT
THAT WE PERCEIVE MAY. FORCE US
TO REMAIN IN THE RENTAL HOUSING
BUSINESS AND WE NEED REALLY FROM
THIS NASH CASE THAT WE THINK
WILL MAKE A STATE AND AROUND
HOUSING BUSINESS AND IN THAT
RESPECT. THE ELLIS ACT WAS A
SHIELD A SHIELD.
FOR LANDLORDS TO.
WHO MAY AS I SAY BE FORCED TO
STAY IN THE RENTAL HOUSING
BUSINESS TO DO?
THE OPERATION OF THE LOCAL
ORDINANCES WAS A SHIELD NOW MANY
YEARS LATER. EMPHATICALLY WITH
THE ADDITION OF COSTA HAWKINS.
TO OUR SET OF LAWS REGULATING
LOCAL RENT CONTROL AT THE STATE
LEVEL. WE ARE SEEING A DIFFERENT
TREND AND THAT TREND IS THAT THE
SHIELD HAS BEEN TURNED IN SOME
CASES INTO A SWORD. A SWORD THAT
CAN BE USED TO EVADE.
A CLEAR REQUIREMENTS OF THE
LOCAL ORDINANCE WITH RESPECT TO
BOTH GOOD BECAUSE REQUIREMENTS
AND INSURING. BOTTOM THE
PRESERVATION OF RENT CONTROL
UNITS AND SO THAT PARTICULAR
WITH THESE AMENDMENTS TODAY IS
WHAT THIS BILL IS ALL ABOUT IT'S
ABOUT.
IF YOU AGREE WITH THE PREMISE OF
THE ALICE ACT WHICH IS THE HOT.
IT PROVIDES A MECHANISM FOR A
CLAMOR TO GO OUT OF THE RENTAL
HOUSING BUSINESS.
NOTHING WE'RE DOING IN THIS BILL
AFFECTS ANY LANDLORD DESIRING TO
DO THAT BUT WHAT WE ARE.
ATTEMPTING TO DO HERE IS TIGHTEN
UP THE RULES FOR THOSE ARE USING
ALICE ACT. IN IN A WAY THAT IT'S
GAMESMANSHIP TO AVOID THE
APPLICATION OF THE LOCAL
ORDINANCE AND.
AND IN SO DOING WE ARE I THINK
CONSISTENT WITH THE ORIGINAL
INTENT OF THE ACT. UPDATING IT
IN RESPONSE TO WHAT WE ARE
SEEING AS ARE THE TRENDS BY SOME
UNSCRUPULOUS LANDLORDS WHO WERE
USING ALICE ACT NO WAY THAT WAS
NEVER INTENDED.
I THINK WITH THE AMENDMENTS
TODAY AND WITH THE WORK THAT
WE'VE DONE WITH CA WE HAVE A
BILL THAT'S VERY NARROWLY
TAILORED TO THAT OBJECTIVE. AND
FOR THOSE REASONS WE WOULD URGE
AND I ABOUT.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ALLISON REGAN I'M A
STAFF ATTORNEY FOR THE CITY OF
WEST HOLLYWOOD OF COURSE ONE
ECHO WHAT MY COLLEAGUE MISTER
OSTROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM HAS
SAID I ALSO JUST WANT TO POINT
OUT. THIS BILL IS REALLY IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BILL IT'S
MEANT TO ADDRESS WHAT WE'RE
SEEING IS A CURRENT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CRISIS. BECAUSE IT SEEKS
TO CURB THE MOST EGREGIOUS
ABUSES THAT WE'RE SEEING ON THE
GROUND WHERE SOME UNSCRUPULOUS
LANDLORDS WILL TARGET THE MOST
VULNERABLE FAMILIES WHO ARE AT
RISK FOR DISPLACEMENT.
SO THIS CLOSE OF SOME OF THOSE
LOOPHOLES AND GETS BACK TO WHAT
THE ORIGINAL INTENT OF THE BILL
WAS WHICH WAS TO ALLOW LANDLORDS
TO COMPLETELY LEAVE THE RENTAL
MARKET. AND SO AS AS BRIAN SAID
WE'RE SEEING IT BEING USED NOW
IS A SWORD INSIDE OF THE SHIELD
THEM THAT IT WAS DESIGNED TO BE
USED AS THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR
IF I COULD JUST AT.
ONE CLARIFICATION BECAUSE I
KNOW THIS IS A THIS WAS A POINT
OF FOR.
OUR CONTENTION AND NOW AGREEMENT
BETWEEN THE APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION AND ALSO OF INTEREST
TO US SOME MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE.
THERE'S AN ISSUE.
RELATING CA VACANT UNITS OF AND
I WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT TO A WE
HAVE AGREED TO IT AFTERWARD
RENTAL TO THE WORD UNIT. IN
SECTION SEVEN OF SIX OH POINT
FOR OF OF THE LAW.
AND AND THAT IS BROUGHT US
TOGETHER AROUND THAT VACANT UNIT
ISSUE.
THANK YOU. OTHER SUPPORTERS.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SILVIUS
ELITES JOHN BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF SANTA MONICA IN SUPPORT OF
THAT TEN A PROTECTIONS IN THIS
MEASURE THINKING.
ANYA LAWLER ON BEHALF OF THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
AT LUIS WERE ON DAY WITH
CALIFORNIA MADE SPLIT.
NOW TO THE OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SHAUN TO TAKE IN ON THE
UP CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION WE ARE OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED.
WANT THINK DIESEL NUMBER FOR
WORKING WITH US DILIGENTLY LATE
INTO THE NIGHT YESTERDAY AND
TODAY I THINK WE'VE MADE
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS A WITH
REGARD TO THE AMENDMENTS AND WE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THAT AND
THAT. I THINK HAS MOVED FORWARD
ONCE YOU SEE THE LANGUAGE I
THINK ORGANIZATION WILL REASSESS
THEIR POSITION TO YOU A COUPLE
THINGS I JUST WANNA POINT OUT
REGARDING THE ALSO ACT AS. IT
REALLY WAS BIPARTISAN
LEGISLATION PASSED IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT A PROPERTY OWNER
COULD EXIT THE MARKET AND IT'S
IMPORTANT PUT THIS INTO CONTEXT
THAT THE VAST MAJORITY OF PEOPLE
TO USE. THE OUTSIDE WHETHER IT'S
IN SAN FRANCISCO WEST HOLLYWOOD
OR SANTA MONICA THEY ARE VERY
SMALL RENTAL PROPERTY OWNERS
ACCORDING TO DATA FROM EACH OF
THOSE CITIES THE AVERAGE UNIT
SIZE IS LESS THAN FOUR CITIES
ARE SMALL MOM AND POPS. WHO ARE
USING THE ELLIS ACT?
AN OWNER WHO HAS A LARGE
BUILDING DOES NOT TYPICALLY DO
THIS IT DOESN'T MAKE FINANCIAL
SENSE THEY'RE IN THE BUSINESS OF
STAYING IN THE RENTAL MARKET. SO
I THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT NOTICE
ALSO WHEN THE OUTSIDE IS USED
IT'S ALWAYS USED AS A LAST
RESORT IT IS INCREDIBLY COMPLEX
AND DIFFICULT TO GO TO AN
OUTSIDE PROCEEDING.
IT COSTS UPWARDS OF HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS TO BE ABLE
TO GO THROUGH THIS PROCESS
SOLDIERS DO USE IT AS A LAST
RESORT.
THAT BEING SAID I THINK OUR
OBJECTIVES WITH THIS LEGISLATION
WAS TO ENSURE THAT THERE WAS
BALANCE. AND THAT LITTLE UNITS
COULD BE RETURNED TO THE RENTAL
MARKET AFTER A APPEARED OF TIME
THAT WAS REASONABLE AND I THINK
WE'VE GONE TO THAT WE'RE GETTING
TO THAT POINT IN. YOU KNOW WE
ALL KNOW THAT WE FACE A
SIGNIFICANT HOUSING CRISIS SO
WE WOULD LIMIT THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR PEOPLE TO RETURN UNITS TO
THEM RENTAL MARKET. HOT SO I
THINK THAT'S WHAT WE'RE LOOKING
FOR WE APPRECIATE THESE ON
NUMBER WORKING TOWARDS THAT GOAL
AND I THINK WERE.
WE'VE GONE THERE BUT ONCE YOU
SEE THE LANGUAGE I THINK WE'LL
BE ABLE TO.
ASSESS OUR POSITION THINKING.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ARE CREAM GREASY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS.
HERE TODAY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY FOUR.
AS WAS PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED OF
THE ELLIS ACT WAS A BIPARTISAN
COMPROMISE THE THAT WAS REACHED
BY THE LEGISLATURE TO ALLOW
RENTAL PROPERTY OWNERS TO GO OUT
OF BUSINESS. IDEA TO BURDENSOME
ECONOMIC CIRCUMSTANCES ARE ALSO
WAS OF AS WAS PREVIOUSLY NOTED
PRIOR TO THE ELLIS ACT UNLIKE
ANY OTHER BUSINESS A RENTAL
PROPERTY OWNERS WERE FORCED. TO
STAY IN BUSINESS EVEN WHEN
SUBJECTED TO EXTREME FINANCIAL
CONDITIONS.
THE L. SAT DOES PROVIDE A
REASONABLE SOLUTION TO GIVE
CERTAINTY TO BOTH PROPERTY
OWNERS A AND TENANTS ALIKE.
SEE OR OPPOSES AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY FOUR.
BECAUSE AMONG OTHER THINGS.
IT SEEKS TO WEAKEN THIS
BIPARTISAN COMPROMISE BY
DISCOURAGING RENTAL PROPERTY
OWNERS FROM RETURNING RENTAL
UNITS A TO THE MARKET IF
ECONOMIC CONDITIONS IMPROVE.
SEE OUR CONTINUES OF COURSE.
TO ACTIVELY SUPPORT A HOUSING
LEGISLATION THAT INCREASES
SUPPLY.
AND WE DO.
LOOK FORWARD TO OF REVIEWING
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
MENTIONED.
BY SIMPLY MEMBER BLOOM HOWEVER
AT THIS TIME WE MUST OPPOSE AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY FOUR AS IT IS
IN PRINT.
BECAUSE IT WILL EXACERBATE THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS BY
KEEPING MUCH NEEDED RENTAL UNITS
OFF THE MARKET EVEN LONGER.
SEER LOOKS FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THIS COMMITTEE ANOTHER
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR NO
VOTE ON AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
FOUR THANK YOU.
EXCUSE ME MEMBERS OF RANKINGS
AND I REPRESENT FOR REGIONAL
APARTMENT ASSOCIATIONS.
I IN THE DAY TWO OF US WROTE
THAT ELLIS ACT.
.
ENDOWMENTS WHEN I HAD MORE HERE
AND I WASN'T QUITE AS GREAT.
THE.
.
I'M TO SPEAK TO THE BILL.
THAT MISTER BLOOM HAS OUTLINED
IS PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED AT
SOME FUTURE DATE PROBABLY BY.
THE NEXT COMMITTEE HEARING.
LOG THIS IS.
AND I JUST WANT A.
EMPHASIZE A COUPLE POINTS.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT STILL HAVE
TREMENDOUS CONTROL OVER AND
ELLIS ACTION.
THEY CAN REGULATED IF YOU WANTED
DEMOLISH IT THEY CAN REGULATE IT
IF YOU WANT TO CREATE IT A
HOMEOWNERSHIP PART OF
OPPORTUNITY OR A CONDOMINIUM. IF
YOU WELL THEY CAN REGULATE IT IN
TERMS OF WHO OCCUPIES IT EVEN IF
IT'S A OWNER OCCUPIED UNITS.
THEY CAN DECIDE.
IF YOU WANNA CHANGES LAND USE
THE ONLY TWO THINGS THEY CAN'T
DO TODAY.
IS
TO.
LEAVE IT A.
TOTALLY UNOCCUPIED UNIT OR
EVENTUALLY.
GET TO AN OWNER OCCUPIED UNIT.
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND THE CONSTRUCT OF HOW
IDEALISTS ACTION OR THE ELLIS
ACT DOES NOW MISTER BROOM HAS A
PRICKLY POINTED OUT IF THERE ARE
FRAUDULENT IF YOU WILL.
ACTIVITIES ARE ACTIONS BY A
PROPERTY OWNER.
TO GO OUT OF BUSINESS
TEMPORARILY COME BACK.
WE DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
THAT AS LONG AS WE RECENTLY
ADDRESS IT AND MISTER BLOOM I
THINK IS ADEQUATELY.
PRESENTED AN OUTLINE FOR A
DISCUSSION AN AMENDMENT TO THE
ELVES.
SO PROBABLY. A SUBJECT TO AS WE
ALWAYS SAY. LET.
TO US WHEN WE SEE THE LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD BE OF GREAT BENEFIT
TO BRING ALL THE PARTIES
TOGETHER SECOND.
IF WE REGULATE.
ELLIS ACTIVITY SO HARD BIKE SAN
FRANCISCO HOUSE AND. LANDLORD
ACTIVITY.
IT IS BEEN DOCUMENTED BY
INDEPENDENT THINK TANKS THAT
THIRTY THOUSAND UNITS ARE OFF
THE MARKET IN JUST IN THE CITY
AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO WE
KNOW WHAT IT'S DOCUMENTED. OUR
AND IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT THE
PROPERTY OWNER COMMUNITY REALTOR
COMMUNITY.
AT DOCUMENTED AND STUDY THIS IS
AN INDEPENDENT STUDY.
THIRD AND FINAL POINT.
DOUBTS YOU WHAT.
MISTER BLOOM OUTLINED.
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T
CREATE SUCH A CONSTRUCT.
THAT.
WE PERMANENTLY MAKE SURE THAT
THE PROPERTY OWNER THAT DOES
WANT TO GO OUT OF BUSINESS
LEGITIMATELY WANT TO GO OUT OF
BUSINESS.
NEVER COMES BACK AGAIN BECAUSE
THAT WAS THE BILL COMING INTO
COMMITTEE.
AND I'D I TRUST THAT IS NOT MR
BLOOM'S OBJECTIVE IS TO ASSURE
THAT IF THE PROPERTY OWNER IS
GOING TO GO OUT. TEMPORARILY GO
OUT AND THEY WANT TO IMPROVE THE
PROPERTY THEY GO WINNING
RENOVATE THE PROPERTY.
THAT THAT PROPERTY OWNER HAS
THAT OPPORTUNITY.
TO DO THAT LEGITIMATELY DO THAT
AND THEN GO BACK IN THE RENTAL
HOUSING BUSINESS IF THEY SO
CHOOSE.
OR HAVE THEIR FAMILY OWNER
OCCUPY THAT VERY UNIT.
AND.
WITHOUT THIS THIS PUTS US IN A
THAT A DIFFICULT POSITION.
OTHER OPPONENTS HAVE EXPRESSED
AS THE BILL. IS CAME TO
COMMITTEE. ALL OF US ARE OPPOSED
TO IT WE'RE GLAD THAT MR PEROT.
HAS.
HAS REACHED SOME.
DISCUSSION DECISION POINTS HERE
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH MR BLOOM AND PROPONENTS
THANK YOU.
OTHER OPPONENTS MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS STEEP CARLSON FOR THE
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION OF GREATER
LOS ANGELES AND SANTA BARBARA
RENTAL PROPERTY ASSOCIATION.
BUT WE TOO ARE OPPOSED TO THE
BILL WE'RE INTERESTED IN AND
LOOKING AT THE AMENDMENTS COUPLE
OF POINTS TO ADD ON.
ENOUGH THE REPETITIVE.
THE NUMBER OF BALLOTS THAT
DEPICTIONS.
IN COMMUNITIES.
IS.
BASICALLY INFINITESIMAL
COMPARED TO THE NUMBER OF UNITS
IN THESE COMMUNITIES TO SUGGEST
THAT IT'S GONE UP LIKE THIRTY
PERCENT OR FORTY PERCENT GAP TO
LOOK AT THE GROSSMAN'S DANCES
AND THAT. WAS ONE OF OUR MAJOR
CONCERNS.
WITH THE THE REQUIREMENT OF A
OF AN ENTIRE YEAR FOR EVERYBODY
UNDER THE ELLIS ACT.
AND WE APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
MR BLOOM IS LOOKING TO. LOOKING
TO CHANGE THAT.
YOU KNOW SOMEBODY HAD A.
IT WAS SIGNIFICANT ISSUE IN
THEIR FAMILY.
THAT DEATH HAD TO YOU KNOW HAD
TO MOVE THE UNIT.
THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO DO AN
OCTAVE AT SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
READING THE AMENDMENTS TAKING A
LOOK AT THEM WE DO APPRECIATE.
A BIT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOMS
CONSIDERATION OF OF SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT BEEN RAISED IN
DIRE AND. WE WILL REASSESS OUR
POSITION ONCE WE TAKE A LOOK AT
THE AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT OPPONENT.
I MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS PET RIGHT
WITH THEIR AND READING
ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION WE TOO ARE OPPOSED
TO THE BILL AND I WON'T BE
REPETITIVE.
WERE POSTED BILL FOR SIMILAR
REASONS THAT YOU'VE ALL HEARD WE
DO APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLOOMS WILLINGNESS. IT TO AMEND
THE BILL AND WE WILL REASSESS
OUR POSITION WHAT WE SEE THE
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU.
CURRENT LET'S SERVE BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
DISCUSSION.
SURE MISTER CHOI.
THANK YOU AUTHOR AWESOME AND
WHEN NOT BLOOM OUT FOR YOUR.
.
BEALL. ESSENTIALLY TRYING TO.
TIGHTEN UP.
AND MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT TO
FOUR GUNMEN.
A TO STAY OR INTERESTED IN
OFFERING THEIR RENTAL UNITS ARE.
BY INCREASING OUT.
THE EARS OF FROM FIVE YEARS OF
TO TENURE HERSELF FROM. A TWO
YEAR STUFF TO FIVE YEARS
EXTENDING THE AMOUNT WAS NOTICES
SIDE THAT THEY HAVE TO PROVIDE
AND THEN ALSO TEN ON SO. RIGHT
TO COME BACK.
NOT AT THE SAME RATE.
ALL OF THESE SO TO ME.
DO YOU OWN SHORTLY BELIEVE I
DISAPPEARED CLEAN UP THAT THIS
LANGUAGE ELECT IS.
WE INCREASE OUR FUTURE
AFFORDABLE RENTAL UNITS.
WHAT WILL IT DISCOURAGE?
THE ARE LANDLORDS ALL PROPERTY
OWNERS SET TO ENTER. CARPENTER
MARKETS.
MY ANSWER TO THAT. IF HOUSE A
INTERESTED IN INVESTING AWESOME
RIGHT TO UNITS.
OUR DO MY BEST TO STAY AWAY
FROM.
SUCH CITIES. WITH FIAT WITH
PROVINCIAL.
BECAUSE OUT FAR MORE MY HANDS
ARE TIED UP.
HOW WOULD YOU IN ENCOURAGE ME?
TO ENTER FOUGHT FOR EXAMPLE.
THE CURRENT BUILDING.
IS A DILAPIDATED DOT OWNER
IMPROVE.
AND IT ACOSTA YOU KNOW.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
SO WHAT YOU EVEN REBUILDING MAY
COST MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
AND THEN I HAVE THOUGHT.
ALL FOUR THAT THAT'S A NEW NEED
THAT THE SAME SAME SAME PRIZE.
HOW HOW CAN I RECOUP BY THE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AFTER
INVESTING?
BECAUSE OF THE DISCOURAGE MONEY.
THAN I WOULD HAVE TO GIVE IT UP.
AND THEN THE UNICELLULAR WATER
YOU KNOW. BECOME.
IS SO BAD THE INHABITABLE AND
THEN THE YOU'RE GO AFTER HIM.
CALL NOT THE.
A MAINTAINING THE UNIT THAT THIS
ASIDE LIKE A CATCH TWENTY TWO IS
SOMEONE. NEGATIVITY AND THAT
DISCOURAGE MONTH OF WOODLAND ALL
DONE. TO PROVIDE AFFORDABLE
HOMES.
WHAT I THINK I THINK HER THE
QUESTION?
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI.
AND THE.
ALL RENT CONTROL ORDINANCES
HAVE VISIONS
OF THAT ALLOW THE LOCAL.
.
AND STABILIZATION BOARD TO MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS IN RENT THAT TAKE
INTO CONSIDERATION THE NEED FOR
UPKEEP AND IMPROVEMENTS.
AND I TOOK A AND PROPERTIES.
A BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS BILL
IS ABOUT THIS BILL.
IS.
TRYING TO SEEK A BALANCE.
FOR THOSE LANDLORDS WHO
LEGITIMATELY NEED OR DESIRE TO
GO OUT OF THE RENTAL BUSINESS
AND THEY WERE.
SOME COMMENT STUFF FROM THE.
OPPONENTS OF THE BILL ABOUT
TARA.
LANDLORDS WHO MAY WANT TO.
I HAVE A UNIT TO A VACANT AND
ARE MAKING IN A VACANT ORDER TO
LOCATE. A PARENT OR. SOMEONE WHO
NEEDS TO MOVE INTO THE BUILDING
AND THAT'S COMPLETELY
UNDERSTOOD.
AND WE LEAVE THAT UNTOUCHED BUT
THIS.
LOG.
SEEKS TO DRAW BALANCE
THAT IS A LITTLE BIT MORE NOT
MUCH BUT A LITTLE BIT MORE
FAVORABLE TO TENANTS WHO ARE
ALSO IN THE CURRENT HOUSING
MARKET. FACING A CRISIS
WHEN THEY ARE FORCED TO LEAVE
THROUGH AN INFECTION AND
AFFORDABLE THROUGH NO FAULT OF
THEIR OWN.
WHO ARE FORCED TO LEAVE AND
AFFORDABLE UNIT? AND ALL OF THE
PROPERTIES AROUND THEM ARE
UNAFFORDABLE.
AND THAT IS ALSO A CRISIS IN AN
ISSUE THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED.
I THINK WE TALK A LOT ABOUT THAT
ISSUE BUT. OF IN THIS PARTICULAR
CASE.
WE ARE NOT TO.
REPEALING THE LAW AND NOT
SEEKING TO REPEAL LAW WERE
SIMPLY SEEKING TO MAKE IT MORE
FAIR FOR ATTENDANCE. AND TO
PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL CLARITY
FOR LANDLORDS.
HE HAS HAD THEIR THE COMMENTS
MISTER GLORIA.
THANK YOU SHERMAN I THINK MISTER
BLOOM OF FOR YOUR.
.
YOUR COMMENTS IN THE
PRESENTATION AND AND FORGIVE ASH
TROUBLE LITTLE WITH THIS ISSUE
IN PART BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
RENT CONTROL IN SAN DIEGO AND SO
SOME OF IT IS UNFAMILIAR TO ME.
UNDERSTANDING HOW FOLKS WOULD
NAVIGATE.
.
YOU'VE EXISTING PROVISIONS ARE
ALICE OR WHAT IS PROPOSED.
IS ALL DIFFICULT ME SO PLEASE
GO EASY ON ME IF YOU WOULD BUT
BASED ON THE AMENDMENTS THAT YOU
HAVE COMMITTED TO DIED THIS
MORNING CAN YOU GIVE ME A SENSE
OF THE MAJOR PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL. AT THIS TIME.
I'M ASKED MS REGAN TO DO CAPITA
BECAUSE SHE'LL DO WITH MORE
CLARITY THAT I. NASCAR GO EASY
ON THE.
ABSOLUTELY SO AS WE MENTIONED
BEFORE THIS THIS DOESN'T DO
ANYTHING TO. CHANGE.
BUT THE LANDLORD'S ABILITY TO
LEAVE THE RENTAL MARKET WHAT IT
DOES IS IT.
BALANCES OUT.
THE IT VIENT INCENTIVE NOW TO
EMPTY THE BUILDING IN ORDER TO
PUT IT BACK ON THE MARKET TO
CHARGE MARKET RATES ESSENTIALLY
SO. WHO'S AT RISK HERE ARE THE
CURRENT TENANTS WHO ARE WHO ARE
PROBABLY LONG TERM LOW RENT
TENANTS AND SO THAT'S WHAT THE
RESTRICTIONS THAT WE. IT BECAUSE
IF SOMEONE HAS IT HAS USED THE
ALICE BILL PROPERLY THEY WILL
HAVE LEFT THE RENTAL MARKET
ENTIRELY. AND SO THE CONCERN WAS
FOR THOSE PROPERTY OWNERS THAT
ARE ONLY SEEKING TO USE IT AS A
TEMPORARY MEASURE IN ORDER TO
EMPTY THE BUILDING AND SO WHAT
THE MEASURES ARE.
OUR TO OUR INCREASE RIGHT NOW
THERE'S A RESTRICTION.
THERE ARE RESTRICTIONS IN PLACE
OF SOMEONE RE ENTERS THE MARKET
IN TWO YEARS WE'VE INCREASED
THOSE TO FIVE YEARS OF THE SAME
RESTRICTIONS ARE PLACED BUT THE
TIME LIMIT IS TWO TO FIVE OKAY.
FOR EVERY INSTANCE OF THERE'S
TWO YEARS AND NOW GOES TO FIVE
YEARS ARACHNIDS FOR OKAY.
THE SECOND PROVISION IS A FIVE
YEAR RESTRICTION PROVISION THAT
REMAINS AS IT IS WE ORIGINALLY
WERE UPPING THAT TEN WE'VE
WITHDRAWN THAT AT THE REQUEST OF
THE APARTMENT ASSOCIATION.
THE OTHER THING THAT WE'VE DONE
IS WE'VE ELIMINATED THERE'S
THERE WAS A CAP ON DAMAGES FOR
SOME OF THE PROVISIONS WE'VE
TAKEN THAT OUT.
AND THEN.
THE OTHER THING IS WE'VE
CLARIFIED IT'S A IT'S A
CLARIFICATION. WHICH WAS THE
ORIGINAL INTENT OF THE BILL TO
HAVE ONLY ONE WITHDRAWAL DATE
FOR THE PROPERTY WHERE IT
CONCERNS OF THE TIMELINES FOR
THESE RESTRICTIONS AND WE'VE
CLARIFIED THAT. IN VARIOUS
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL TO MAKE
IT CONSISTENT THAT THERE IS ONE
WITHDRAWAL DATE FOR THE PROPERTY
AND ALSO THAT.
BECAUSE YOU CAN YOU CAN ONLY
WITHDRAW ALL OF THE UNITS FROM
THE FROM THE RENTAL MARKET YOU
CAN'T THEN. RETURN THEM TO THE
RENTAL MARKET IN A PIECEMEAL
FASHION IN THE PROPERTIES OF
THEIR ON THE RENTAL MARKET ARTS
OFF.
OKAY SO I UNDERSTAND THE FOUR
MAJOR PROVISIONS OF THE BILL AS
IT'S CURRENTLY CSUS AGREED TO
WITH SOME OF THE STAKEHOLDERS
HER HERE.
IS THAT THAT THE TWO YEAR.
TIME LIMIT NOW GOES TO FIVE
YEARS EVE NOT YOU'VE OUT REMOVE
THE TEN YEAR EXTENSION KEEPING
AT THE EXISTING FIVE WHICH IS
CURRENT LAW.
THAT THERE'S NO CAP ON DAMAGES
FOR PROPERTY OWNERS WHO VIOLATE
THE TERMS OF ALICE.
TIME AND THAT THERE IS A UNIFORM
WITHDRAWAL DATE NOT A PEACE
MILLON SO THAT'S BASICALLY WHAT
THE BILL THAT WERE FACED WITH.
THEIR TWO PROVISIONS THAT I
WOULD BEEN CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
I WANNA MAKE SURE WITH FIVE
POINT ONE IS A DIVERT PIPELINE
PROVISION I RECOGNIZE THE PEOPLE
COULD BE IN A RAIN DALLAS
PROCESS TODAY. I'M I THINK
PREVIOUSLY THERE WAS A CONCERN
THAT THIS BILL WOULD AFFECT
THOSE WHO ARE TRYING TO EXERCISE
THEIR RIGHTS NOW IN ADVANCE OF
THIS BECOMING LAW A WHAT IS THE
STATUS OF THAT IN THIS BILL SO
WE'VE AGREED WE'VE AGREED TO
THAT IN PRINCIPLE EMERGES.
FIRING UP THE LANGUAGE.
THE RESULT OF.
OKAY.
SOME HERE AND THAT AND THAT WILL
BE CLEAR IN THAT YOU DON'T.
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS A NEED
FOR OUR DESIRE TO DO SOME
ADDITIONAL ACTION YOU KNOW I
THINK WE HAVE TO TREAT PEOPLE.
WHO FOLLOWING THE RULES
CURRENTLY? IN THAT WAY HIM AS
MUCH AS WE WANT TO CHANGE IT YOU
KNOW.
DIDN'T SPY SAFE YOUR INTERNET
TODAY YOU PLAY BY TODAY'S RULES
IF THE LAW CHANGES SUBSEQUENTLY.
THEN THE THAT THOSE RULES WILL
APPLY OKAY.
AND THEN THE THE LAST QUESTION
IS WITH CARTED TO THE VACANT
UNITS.
ISSUE I AND MR BUT I THINK YOU
WERE SAYING THAT THERE'S A.
A TERM WHICH I DON'T MAYBE THE
SIGNIFICANCE IS LOST ON ME BUT
VENTED.
UNIT YOU CAN EXPLAIN THAT A
LITTLE BIT MORE BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT'S ALSO SIGNIFICANT.
SURE THERE THERE WAS A REQUEST
US A SEVENTY SIXTY POINT FOUR
WE'VE CHANGED THE WORD
ACCOMMODATIONS TO UNIT. BECAUSE
WE WILL AGAIN THAT'S CONSISTENT
WITH THE POSITION THAT THERE'S
ONLY ONE WITHDRAWAL DATE AND
SOME COURTS HAVE BEEN CONFUSED
BY THE USE OF THE WORD
ACCOMMODATIONS BECAUSE IT SEEMS
TO ME IN ONE THING AND ONE
SECTION ANOTHER THING AND
SOMETHING ELSE.
SO WE CHANGE THE WORD TO UNIT.
DEPARTMENT SUSPICION ASKED US
TO ADD THE WORD RENTAL IN FRONT
OF THAT UNIT THERE WERE SOME
CONCERNS THAT IT MIGHT SOMEHOW
CHANGED THE MEANING OF THE
SECTION OTHERWISE.
OKAY.
IN TURN OF.
SO KNOW JUST FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE THAN WE APPRECIATE
THAT I THINK CLARIFYING IT SAY
RENTAL UNIT IS INTERPRETED A LOT
OF ME OR SOMEBODY WAS ACTUALLY
IN THE UNIT AND IT WAS OCCUPIED.
AS OPPOSED TO A UNIT THAT MAYBE.
THAT'S WHAT WE WERE TRYING TO
CLARIFY. THAT I COULD LEADING TO
LAW SCHOOL SO I THAT THAT'D AYE
SIGNIFICANCE IS LOST UPON ME BUT
I I.
I I I IF YOU GUYS ARE SAFE
QUESTION IS THIS BASICALLY WHAT
THE CURRENT FORM OF THE BLL YES
I JUST WANTED TO MENTION TO
MEMBERS WE CIRCULATED COPY THE
MOST RECENT SET OF AMENDMENTS I
ACTUALLY. WANT TO THANK ALL THE
PARTIES FOR ENGAGING AS
INTENSELY AS YOU'VE HAD AN AND
RECENT DAYS ARE TO TO TO TRY TO
TAKE TO CREATE A LITTLE MORE
CLARITY ON THIS. SO I JUST IF I
CAN SUM UP BY I LIKE HUMANS CHEN
I THINK THAT'S ADMIRABLE I'D
OFTEN IN THIS BUSINESS PEOPLE
SAID NEVER SPECTER CORNERS AND
JUST HOLLER NOTHING GETS DONE.
I'M INTIMATELY THERE'S SOMETHING
GOING ON HERE ANYWAY THIS IS
REALLY THE BAR CONTEXT OF
HOUSING CRISIS UNDERSTAND MISTER
BLOOM IS TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH.
AND I APPRECIATE PARTY'S GETTING
TO THE TABLE AND I HEAR FOLKS
ARE WILLING TO WORK.
AYE I CAN I WILL LIMIT LOOK AT
THIS AND WHILE MY COLLEAGUES AT
RESPOND BUT.
I IN THAT SPIRIT OF COOPERATION
YOU KNOW I I I CAN SEE THIS
CONVERSATION CONTINUING AYE SIR
THE RESERVE.
EIGHTY FIVE SIR FINAL DECISION
BASED ON THE OUTCOME OF THESE
DISCUSSIONS.
AGAIN I SORT OF STRUGGLE WITH
THIS ISSUE AYE AYE GENERAL
SENSE.
BUT YOU KNOW IF I IF BOTH
PARTIES CAN COME TO AGREEMENT
WHO AM I TO SAY NO RIGHT.
BUT AYE AYES ARE LOOK FOR THIS
CONTINUING DISCUSSION AND A GET
DEEP APPRECIATION TO THE AUTHOR
WHO.
AYE AYE LIKES HIS MY HOUSING
GURU OF I LOOKED HIM ON THESE
ISSUES BECAUSE I KNOW HE CARES
ABOUT HIS PASSION AS I DO.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM FIRST
PERSON AT THIS TABLE TRYING TO
WORK ON THIS AS WELL AS THE
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO ON DIDN'T
HAVE TO SET THE TABLE BUT ARE
WORKING HARD TO TRY TO GET TO.
GET TO THE SOMETIME LEVEL
CONSENSUS.
MISS A MONTH THANK YOU.
I THINK YOU. ARE EVERYONE FOR
WORKING SO MUCH ON THIS AND HOPE
OVER THE LAST TO AM YOU KNOW TWO
DAYS THERE'S BEEN A FLURRY OF
INFORMATION BACK AND FORTH AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE IT. I GUESS I
SHOULD START OFF BY JUST SAYING
THAT AND YOU KNOW MY LENDS FOR
THIS WAS A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT
THAN A MINUTE MIGHT OF BEEN LAST
YEAR. I'M DUE TO A COUPLE THINGS
ONE TO THE FACT THAT AND NOW
WHEN I THINK ABOUT RENT CONTROL
I DON'T JUST THINK ABOUT IT YOU
KNOW STAINED IN ONE PARTICULAR
JURISDICTION. BUT AS A TRUE
REALITY THAT.
WE MAY HAVE A BALLOT INITIATIVE
WHERE THIS MAY BE A STATEWIDE
ISSUE SO I THINK OF IT IN THE
CONTEXT OF LIKE WHAT WOULD THIS
MEAN NOT JUST FOR MUNICIPALITIES
THAT HAVE YEARS. OF WORKING ON
THIS BUT SHOULD THIS TIME AND
THAT HAPPENING AND THROUGH A
STATEWIDE BALLOT INITIATIVE ON
WHAT KIND OF IMPACT HAS AND THE
SECOND PIECE IS.
BUT I'VE NEVER SEEN SUCH.
OBSCURE CREATIVE.
SCARY KIND OF HOUSING SITUATION
IN MY DISTRICT LIKE I DO NOW
WITH THE NATURAL DISASTERS.
AND I HAVE.
SO MANY EXAMPLES NOW OF THINGS
THAT ARE HAPPENING OUT OF THE
BOX.
AND AND IN THINGS THAT.
I.
I COULDN'T HAVE NECESSARILY
THOUGHT OF.
BUT BEFORE THIS BUT THAT ALSO
WORRY ME BECAUSE.
I DID THERE'S A LOT OF HOUSING
THAT NEEDS TO BE REBUILT AND BUT
THERE'S ALSO I MEAN THERE WAS A
PERIOD IN INVENTOR OF WHERE WE
WERE WE WE CAN FAN FIND
VACANCIES ANYWHERE AND WE NEEDED
TO PUT PEOPLE AND.
ANY SEE MY COLLEAGUE WHOSE
EXPERIENCES I MEAN WE'RE SO.
IT'S JUST DIFFERENT AND I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE SOLUTION IS.
BUT THOSE TO THOSE TWO THINGS I
THINK AND HAVE ME LOOKING AT
THIS BILL I'M IN A DIFFERENT WAY
THAT I MAY HAVE OTHERWISE LOOKED
AT IT. AND AND I KNOW.
THAT I'VE.
WE'VE GONE BACK AND FORTH WITH
ASK QUESTIONS.
HAD THEY WENT THROUGH THE IN
ALLEGANY OUNCES AND YOU KNOW
POINT OUT SOME SOME AREAS THAT
WERE HOW.
THAT WERE OF CONCERN AND I AM
OPTIMISTIC ABOUT.
THE LEVEL OF ENGAGEMENT ON
MULTIPLE SITES.
BY I THINK THE CLARIFICATION ON
AND IN A DEFINED DEFINING THE
WITHDRAWAL DATE.
ON WHEN I'M UNITS GO BACK INTO
THE MARKET ARE PIECES THAT.
I THINK OUR AS WAS SPOKEN NEEDED
I'M AND THIS WAS NEVER INTENDED
TO BE A LOOP AROUND.
LA.
I ALSO AND I KNOW THAT SOME OF
THE OTHER ONES ABOUT WHEN YOU
KNOW THAT THE TIMING TWO TO FIVE
FIVE TO TEN.
JUST CREE OTHER PARTICULAR
ISSUES SO.
IE I DEFINITELY I WANTED TO
SHARE THAT WITH YOU BECAUSE I IT
DOES CHANGE HOW I THINK ABOUT
THIS PARTICULAR BILL.
AND I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN VERY
RESPONSIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM
TO THE QUESTIONS THAT I'VE HAD
AND TO THE BACK AND FORTH.
AND I THINK THAT EM IT MERITS A
ADDITIONAL CONVERSATION.
I LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING WHAT
HAPPENS IN THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE ON AND HOW THOSE ARE
DEFINED BUT I DO WANT TO SAY
THAT AS THIS MOVE FORWARD.
.
I WORRY
JUST ABOUT WHAT THIS WOULD MEAN
I HAVE FOR ENTIRE STATE SHOULD
THIS THAT RENT CONTROL BECOME A
AN ISSUE THE ENTIRE STATE NOT
JUST MUNICIPALITIES AND ALSO.
AND LIVING IN PRECARIOUS
SITUATIONS WHERE WE DON'T KNOW.
ONE DAY TO ANOTHER WHAT THAT
HOUSING MARKET LOOKS LIKE
BECAUSE THAT'S HOW QUICKLY IT
CHANGE IN A DISTRICT THAT'S BEEN
IMPACTED BY MULTIPLE NATURAL
DISASTERS.
AND OF THE COMPASS
JIM WOOD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
AND.
SO I DID BACK IN JANUARY WE
HEARD BILL ON RENT CONTROL IN
THIS COMMITTEE.
.
AND AT THAT TIME I CONVEYED.
CONVEYED MY.
MY HOPE THAT THE AUTHOR IN THE
STAKEHOLDERS WOULD YEAH I I HOPE
THAT THERE WILL BE A COMPROMISE
AND SO I WHAT I WOULD. REALLY
WANT TO SAY IS I'M WAS START BY
COMMENDING THE AUTHOR AND FOR
BRINGING PEOPLE TO THE TABLE TO
ACTUALLY HAVE. AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CASH INCOME TO COMMON GROUND ON
THIS ISSUE I KNOW THESE ARE
THESE ARE REALLY DIFFICULT
ISSUES.
ALSO.
APPRECIATE THE OPTICIANS
RECOGNITION THAT OUR CURRENT
SYSTEM HAS BEEN ABUSED AT LEAST
IN PART BY SOME FOLKS. AND WE
NEED TO REVISIT THE PROTECTIONS
ARE OFFERED TO TENANTS AND I
THINK THAT'S A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. I STILL HAVE SOME
RESERVATIONS ABOUT THE BILL I
THINK THERE'S STILL WORK TO DO I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THIS
CONTINUE CONVERSATION CONTINUE
THOUGH SO. THERE COULD BE SOME
BAD ACTORS.
AND THAT HAVE EXPLOITED
LOOPHOLES AND TEN PROTECTION
LAWS AND I'M ENCOURAGED BY THE
PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE SO FAR
SO.
SO BE SUPPORTING THE BILL IN
COMMITTEE A COMMITTEE TODAY WANT
THANK YOU OFTEN STAKEHOLDERS FOR
THEIR WORK. THANKS FOR COME TO
COME TOGETHER TO THE TABLE*.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS
YOU CAN.
BOB I WILL HAVE US SECOND CHANCE
LOOK AT HIS BILL WHEN HE GOES TO
JUDICIARY. ARE BUT I WANT TO DO
WHEN I THINK OF BOTH SIDES FOR.
FOR YOUR ENGAGEMENT IS PROCESS
IT'S A VERY IMPRESSIVE.
A SO I WILL BE SUPPORTING IT
TODAY AND THERE WITHOUT I WANT
APPROVED A BILL.
GREAT THIS MOTION MOVE THE BILLS
ARE SECOND.
BY DOCTOR WOULD LET ME MAKE A
COUPLE COMMENTS A FIRST OF ALL
IN MY CITY IN SAN FRANCISCO IN
RECENT YEARS WE'VE HAD. OF
THOUSANDS OF TENANTS WHO HAVE
BEEN SUBJECTED TO THE ELLIS ACT
SANTA. A THE THE STORIES RELATED
TO THEM AND THE INTENSITY OF THE
CRISIS
HAVE WAIT ON ALL OF US WHO ARE
ELECTED OFFICIALS.
I THINK THE EARLY INTENT OF
THIS LAWS ONE THAT WE CAN ALL
AGREE ON TO ALLOW.
IN CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES FOR
PROPERTY OWNERS THAT WANNA GET
OUT OF THE BUSINESS TO TO DO
THAT ARMED BUT I DO AGREE WITH
THE CHARACTERIZATION THAT IN
RECENT YEARS. WITH SOME OWNERS
WE HAVE SEEN THE SHE'LL TURN
INTO A SORT. AND ARE AND I KNOW
THAT THESE ARE VERY TECHNICAL
AND AND DIFFICULT POLICY AREAS
TO. TO WRAP AROUND BUT I REALLY
APPRECIATE.
BOTH SIDES COME TO THE TABLE.
AND THE INTENSITY OF YOUR.
DISCUSSIONS ON THIS I DO WANNA
SAY THERE WERE THERE WAS A
COMMENT SUGGESTED THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT HAS A LOT OF CONTROL
OVER ELLIS ACT IN AND FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF CERTAINLY MY
CITY.
OF OUR CITIES UNITED AND AND AND
IN BELIEVING THAT THERE NEEDS TO
BE SOME LEVEL OF RELIEF OF THE
I ALSO WANNA JUST ASKS AND MR
KINGSTON ARM YOU HAD REFERENCE
THE SUGGESTION THAT IN SAN
FRANCISCO THERE THIRTY THOUSAND
VACANT UNITS. I'VE HEARD THAT
STATISTIC NO ONE HAS BEEN ABLE
TO ACTUALLY GIVE ME A REPORT
THAT SUGGESTS THAT SO IF YOU
HAVE ONE. I WOULD LOVE TO SEE
ELEVEN ASKING FOR FOR THE BETTER
PART OF FOR. MANY MANY MONTHS.
AND I DO KNOW.
AND UNDERSTAND FROM THE AUTHOR
THAT.
THERE'S A COMMITMENT FOR
FURTHER DISCUSSIONS ON THIS AND
I THINK THAT IS. ARE ENTIRELY
APPROPRIATE SO WITH THAT I HAVE
NOT MADE A RECOMMENDATION THAT
THIS COMMITTEE PASS IT.
WITH THE COMMITMENT OF THE
AMENDMENTS THAT THE AUTHORS MADE
I HAD THOUGHT I WAS AN EARLY CO
AUTHOR OF THIS I JUST CHECKED I
DON'T THINK I AM HAPPY TO BE
ADDED. TO THAT IS A SIGH GETS
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE.
AND UNLESS THERE'S ANY FINAL
DISCUSSION.
LEAVE IT TO THE AUTHOR TO MY
CLOSING COMMENTS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN ND
MEMBERS OF THE. COMMITTEE THERE.
WERE OUT I THINK MORE THAN ONE
COMMENT MADE ABOUT ISSUES THAT
GO WELL BEYOND.
THE.
.
THAT THE BILL THAT IS BEFORE US
HOWEVER I WANT TO SAY THAT I
THINK THE.
DISCUSSIONS THAT WE'VE HAD TO
THIS POINT AND I KNOW THE
DISCUSSIONS THAT WILL BE
FORTHCOMING PROVIDE. US WITH A
GOOD MODEL FOR RESOLVING SOME OF
THOSE LARGER ISSUES WE'RE AT A
POINT IN TIME IN THE STATE WHERE
THE HOUSING CRISIS I THINK IS.
WELL UNDERSTOOD DE UP BEYOND
THE WALLS OF THIS BUILDING A AND
AND AND THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THERE ARE A VARIETY OF OPINIONS
ABOUT. WHAT THE BEST RESOLUTION
IS TO THE HOUSING CRISIS BUT?
DISCUSSIONS AROUND RENT CONTROL
ARE ONE OF THE MORE IMPORTANT
DISCUSSIONS THAT ARE HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW AND I THINK IT'S NO
SECRET TO ANYONE THAT DATA. WE
HAVE.
AT THE BALLOT MEASURE THAT.
MAY HAVE A MAYOR MAY NOT GO
FORWARD. I I THINK I SHARE WITH
THE CHAIR OF THE OPINION THAT
THAT HE HAS STATED AFFECT THIS I
NOTICE. THAT LEGISLATION IS A
BETTER WAY TO RESOLVE THOSE
ISSUES AND SO.
SINCE
THE WORK OF.
A LARGER DISCUSSION HAS BEEN
RAISED HERE IN THE CHAIR'S NOT.
RULING ME OUT OF ORDER I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT I I THINK WE
OUGHT TO BE TALKING ABOUT THOSE
THINGS HERE WE OUGHT TO BE.
TRYING TO USE THE KIND OF
CONVERSATIONS THAT IT HAPPENED
THUS FAR AS A MODEL FOR
RESOLVING SOME OF THOSE DISPUTES
AS WELL. AND TO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
ARRIVAL.
RIGHT.
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND A
SECOND MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL PUSHING THROUGH
PASSING REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY CHU HI
SHOE I MAIENSCHEIN. AND CHANT
NO.
CHAO.
SHALL I CHOI. CHOICE YOU KNOW.
GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE LIMA.
THE MORE I WOULD.
BUT I.
YOUR BILLS OUT.
THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
COLLEAGUES WITH ONE FINAL ITEM
IN THAT IS MINE OF FILE ITEM
TWELVE A. B. THIRTY SEVENTY TWO
AND GOING TO HAND THE GAVEL OVER
TO OUR VICE CHAIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
.
COLLEAGUES HOPEFULLY THIS IS A
FAIRLY BRIEF ITEM.
AB THIRTY SEVENTY TWO WOULD
INCREASE OUR STATES AFFORDABLE
HOUSING TAX CREDIT PROGRAM BY
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
OUR STATES TAX CREDIT PROGRAM
HAS BEEN EXTREMELY SUCCESSFUL
ARE IN ITS GOALS AND WOULD IN
TURN LEVERAGE ANOTHER ONE
BILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL TAX
CREDIT LOCAL AND PRIVATE SECTOR
INVESTMENTS. IF THIS BILL SOUNDS
FAMILIAR AYE IT SHOULD FOR ALL
OF YOU WHO WERE IN THE ASSEMBLY
THE LAST SESSION.
IT IS ALMOST IDENTICAL TO MY A.
B. THIRTY FIVE BILL AND I WANNA
THANK EVERY MEMBER OF THE
ASSEMBLY FROM LAST SESSION WHO
VOTED FOR IT REPUBLICAN AND
DEMOCRAT.
WHILE WE MADE REAL HEADWAY ON
HOUSING LAST YEAR WITHOUT
INCREASE IN THIS TAX CREDIT THE
RECENT REDUCTION IN THE FEDERAL
CORPORATE TAX RATE. IN THE
RECENTLY ENACTED FEDERAL TAX
PLAN FROM THIRTY FIVE PERCENT TO
TWENTY ONE PERCENT. HAS HAD AN
EXTREMELY NEGATIVE IMPACT ON OUR
STATE'S AFFORDABLE HOUSING
INVESTMENTS
TO THE TUNE OF REDUCING OUR FOR
DOUBLE RENTAL PRODUCTION BY
ALMOST FIFTY THOUSAND RENTAL
UNITS A YEAR. AND ONE POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS OF LOCAL
STATE AND FEDERAL TAXES.
NOW THE ONE CHANGE WE DO HAVE IN
THIS MEASURE COMPARED TO WHAT WE
VOTED ON A IN THE LAST SESSION.
IN ADDITION TO INCREASE IN THE
SIZE OF THE PROGRAM.
WELL THAT THE SIZE THE PROGRAM
IS THE SAME AS THE LAST BILL BUT
THIS BILL ALSO ELIMINATES THE
CAP ON INDIVIDUAL TAXPAYERS WHO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE TAX CREDIT
AND THAT WAS DESIGNED. TO
FURTHER INCREASE THE VALUE OF
THE PROGRAM TO INVESTORS AND TO
HOPEFULLY COUNTERBALANCE A
LITTLE BIT OF THE IMPACT OF THE
CHANGES IN THE FEDERAL CORPORATE
TAX RATE.
GIVEN THE MAGNITUDE OF THE
HOUSING CRISIS AND THE BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS THAT WE'VE LOST WITH
THE REDEVELOPMENT ELIMINATION.
DURING THE GREAT RECESSION OF
THE DRYING UP OF HOUSING BOND
MONIES IT'S CRITICAL I BELIEVE
THAT WE EXPAND THIS TAX CREDIT
TO HELP LEVERAGE WITH THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OF
INVESTMENT. ANOTHER ONE BILLION
DOLLARS.
THROUGH OTHER SOURCES AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
SUPPORT TURN IT OVER TO OUR.
WITNESSES WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
ABOUT MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I
MICHELENA NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION OF IN CALIFORNIA
JUST BRIEFLY AS YOU'VE HEARD
TODAY LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX
BECAUSE THE BACKBONE OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FINANCE. WE
HAVE TAKEN HERE AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL WITH THAT CORPORATE TAX
REFORM WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CREATE EVEN MORE ROBUST PROGRAM
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
A LARGER PROGRAM AND THAT SHE
WOULD COULD AFFORD MORE VALUABLE
CREDITS WHICH ACTUALLY HELPS TO
BACKFILL AND STAND UP AS WE
SHOULD IN CALIFORNIA TO REALLY
HELP. ADDRESS THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY CRISIS IN
THE STATE WITH A PROGRAM THAT
HAS A PROVEN TRACK RECORD.
OVERSIGHT AND AND IT'S VERY
PRODUCTIVE AND RESPONSIVE.
TO TO THE DEMANDS OF THIS
LEGISLATURE AND THE T. CACKLE
ADMINISTERS THE PROGRAM WITH
GUIDELINES AND REGULATIONS THAT
REALLY DIRECT THE HOUSING WHERE
IT NEEDS TO WHERE IT NEEDS TO BE
PLACED IN YOUR DRIVE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
MAUREEN HIGGINS AND STRONG
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM
AND WE ARE MOTION FROM MISTER
WHAT A SECOND FROM MISTER CHAO.
DEMOCRATS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
AYALA OR ON BEHALF OF THE
WESTERN THURMOND POVERTY HOUSING
CALIFORNIA THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR ALL HOUSING AND
THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT.
LOUIS MONDAY FOR CALIFORNIA ME
IT'S PART.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE EVOLUTIONISTS SECOND.
I'LL BE HAPPY TO US SUPPORT
DISPIRITED VISTA THOUGHT
TYPEABLE PORCH WE SHOULD GIVE A
TAX CREDIT INCENTIVE SELF FOR
MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
LOVE TO HEAR THAT FROM ME MISTER
CHOI THANK YOU.
I I THINK I KNOW HOW THIS BOATS
GONNA GO NOW MISTER CHAIR SO. I
WITHOUT ANYONE A CLOSE
APPRECIATE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND.
ESCORT WAS CALLED OFF.
YOU PASSING REFERRED TO THE
COMEDIAN REVENUE AND TAXATION.
MAIN CHIANG MAI MAINTAINED AYE
CHOW CHOW AYE CHILI AYE CHILI
AYE GLORIA. GLORIA AYE IN LIMON.
LIMON I WOULD. WOULD I.
CHU. CHU LAI.
THANK YOU THAT MEASURE PASSES.
AND WITH THAT THAT'S THE END OF
OUR AGENDA LET US GO THROUGH.
ALL OF THE VOTES THAT WE HAVE I
THINK WE NEED A COUPLE OF
MOTIONS.
BEFORE WE HAD A QUORUM.
BUT LET'S START WITH FILE ITEM
ONE. COMPANY OVER.
HELLO ON.
MISSING MEMBERS A. B. AB TWENTY
FIFTY SIX.
THROUGH THIS MEDIA ITEM.
OF THE TWILIGHT OF ONE WE'LL
JUST GO IN THE FILE ORDER. SO
STARTING ATOP THE ORDER OF FILE
ITEM ONE MISTER GARCIA. THE
MISSING MEMBERS.
MAIENSCHEIN.
HI.
WOULD.
WAIT I.
THERE WAS NO.
S..
ACTUALLY FIVE.
TWO ONE.
ACTUALLY LOCATED IN THE HEART
THAT MEASURES UP FIVE TO ONE.
FILA ITEM TWO IS BEEN A WILL BE
CONSIDERED IN A FEW WEEKS OF
FOLLOWING ITEM THREE.
WE HAD FOR JUST SCOTIAN
PURPOSES TODAY SO THERE'S NO
VOTE FILE ITEM FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
AND THE VOTE AND THIS WAS FORCED
FRIEDMAN HERO.
A SHOUT.
SHALL I.
CHOI. CHOICE I. LEE MUN. LIMO I.
SEVEN TO SEE ALSO SEVEN ZERO.
THAT ITEMS OUT.
FILE ITEM FIVE I THINK WE HAD
EVERYONE VOTE ON THAT THAT IS
OUT. FILE ITEM SIX THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
I'M ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI.
AT THIS POINT WHERE SIX AUG TWO
ZERO.
MISTER CHOI FILE ITEM SIX MISTER
MULLINS MEASURE KNOWN.
NO.
SO SIX ONE. ARMS MOVING TO FILE
ITEM SEVEN I BELIEVE WE NEED A
MOTION FOR THAT. FOR MISS AM WE
ARE CURRIES BILL. MOTION BY
MISTER CHANNELS ARE SECOND.
SECOND BY MISTER WOOD.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AND THIS
IS THIS MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND REFER TO THE COMMAND
APPROPRIATION CHIU AYE. SHOE
AYE.
MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN AYE
CHAO.
SHALL I CHOI.
SEVEN.
FOLLOW HIM SEVEN.
JOINT AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE LEMOND.
THE MORE I WOULD.
WHICH I SEVEN TWO ZERO OF BILLS
OUT SEVEN ZERO MOVIE TO FILE
ITEM EIGHT MISTER TANG AB TWENTY
EIGHT NINETY.
COLLIE UPS MEMBERS WE STILL.
.
DONATE NINETY WE ARE SIXTY ONE
WE ARE THE POLICE OUT BILLS OUT
OKAY SIXTY ONE. OF FILE ITEM
NINE.
HAS BEEN.
PULLED AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR FILE ITEM TEN I BELIEVE
WE NEED A MOTION WE FEEL SO
MOTION. MOTION BY MISTER GLORIA
SECONDED BY MISTER WOOD.
.
IS CULTURAL.
MOTION THROUGH PASSING REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
AYE CHU. CHU AYE. MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN NIGHT CHAO. CHOW AYE
CHOI. CHOICE AVE GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE LAMONT.
FOR THE MONTH I WOULD. WHICH I
IN THE PHILLIES SEVEN ZERO.
LET'S MOVE TO FILE ITEM ELEVEN
MR GREY AB TWENTY NINE SEVENTY
THREE UP SOME NUMBERS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHOI.
I.
SEPARATE CHOICE I A. BILL SEVEN
TWO ZERO. ZERO FILE AND TWELVE
IS COMPLETE FOLLOW AND THIRTEEN
I BELIEVE WE NEED A MOTION FLUSH
MY MR MAIENSCHEIN SECOND BY
MISTER GLORIA.
CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE BUT
THE COMEDIAN APPROPRIATION SHOOK
OUR CHIU PIE CHIU AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN NIGHT
CHAO.
SHALL I CHOI NO SHOWING NO
GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE LEMOND.
THE MORE I WOULD.
WHAT I?
TWO ONE THAT ITEMS OUT SIX ONE.
WEAVING THE FILE ITEM FOURTEEN
AB THIRTY ONE FORTY SEVEN OF
TWO.
AB WE ARE GOOD WE HAD A MOTION
ON THE ABSENT MEMBERS PLEASE.
THIS BILL IS FOR TWO ZERO
ABSENT MEMBERS AT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHAO HITTING.
I.
THE SEVEN WERE CHOI.
YES.
SIMILAR CHOI AYE LEE MON.
ASSEMBLYMAN AYE IT DOES HAPPEN
SEVEN ZERO.
AND A FIVE ITEM FILE ITEM
FIFTEEN AB THIRTY ONE NINETY
FOUR DALY WE NEED A MOTION.
CORRECT SIR MOTION.
A COMMOTION UP MOTION BY MISTER
CHOI SECOND BY. MISTER WOOD.
MADAM SECRETARY.
DO PASS AS AMENDED AND BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENT CHIU AYE SHOE
AYE. MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
NIGHT CHAU. CHOW Y. CHOI.
CHOI AYE GLORIA.
MISTER FULLER.
MR DAILIES I DON'T.
I.
LEE MUN.
THE PART I WOULD.
WHICH I.
THAT ITEM IS SEVEN ZERO AND WITH
THAT COLLEAGUES APPRECIATE ALL
YOUR WORK AND.
AT THIS TIME WE ARE ADJOURNED